what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
uh before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification Bell the way you're gonna
be notified of my daily videos guys the
shirts are here they sent me the samples
today I have a shirt King is the shirt
blessing as a shirt we all have the
women shouldn't vote t-shirts all of
this craziness and debauchery that we
see going on in society today really all
started with the first sexual revolution
in the 1900s caused by what
women voting it's like the root of all
evil I mean look what happens when we
make decisions about boyfriends terrible
right and now they want us to pick the
leader of the Free World nasiki NADA
take it away get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today also guys
like the video that's the most important
metric that YouTube uses to push out
these streams
um okay a couple announcements before we
start the show two clips channels just
Pearl eclipse and pearl daily make sure
you go subscribe to both
um and also guys we're going to be doing
a meet up soon in England
um I believe uh the 24th I think on the
24th we're gonna do it so
um sign up to our Google form the link
to that is in the description to get
updates on the Meetup I know I've been
gaslighting you guys about this all
summer but it's happening two weeks we
booked the place today so it's happening
okay
um so guys welcome to the show
um why don't we start everyone say your
name am your age relationship status and
fun fact about yourself starting here
and then go around
okay hi everyone my name is Christy Jade
I'm 31 and I'm married I'm a
singer-songwriter and I'm also a lawyer
hi my name is Pixie I'm 24. I am Puerto
Rican and what else name age
relationship status and fun fact oh yeah
I guess my fun fact is I know Spanish
um and I'm single
um
Troy province is 47 years young uh
single obviously
um after that tweet and uh fun fact
about me is I am three percent Albanian
wow I have the Circa Gene and do you are
you like super you know
unfulfilled and depressed like the truth
I'm just I'm crying I'm crying into my
really crying into my drink really speak
you cry every day I cry every day I have
to get I have to get comforted by by my
friends it's a it's a sad situation man
I'm afraid
God
22 years old I'm in a relationship fun
fact about me I'm actually a YouTuber
here at the audacity Network yeah and
guys go subscribe her link is in the
description we're trying to get her to
20K so make sure you go subscribe
um hi I'm I'm Vic I'm 36. I'm seeing
someone and a fun fact about me I'm a
railway engineer
nice yeah yeah guys Romeo
um relationship status
um it's it's somewhere there I I
wouldn't say what it is but okay now
you're doing what the women do
uh fun fact about me is like I'm an
actor model
um also I can roller skate
oh you can blade yeah you should have
done some laps here the other day what
was it you was outside or not yeah yeah
we were doing laps on the blade I'll
bring my quiz when I get back yeah yeah
yeah and you recruit for us oh yeah oh
yeah so oh the main important
top recruiter right now obviously uh you
see all those people you see in the
panel I might as well join you guys
today that's what it's about so I'm here
okay so um today
um this today was sparked guys Troy did
me such a solid today I woke up I had no
plans for this I could I had no idea
what I was gonna do today and Troy
decided to go viral on Twitter and come
on today thank you for that it's
absolutely fine whatever I can do Paul
um can you pull up the tweet I sent you
King so Troy had a um
a tweet go viral and I think this is a
conversation about like what we talk so
much about high value men in the red
pill and we we've never we don't really
Define it often you know and there's a
lot of disagreements so Troy came in and
gave us an awesome definition
um okay put it on the screen
foreign
so we got
um a high value man is a bachelor in his
40s and 50s has a vasectomy Child free
by choice travels extensively reads
voraciously brackets I don't know
righteously I like I don't know British
words I don't know I don't know big
words I don't know them it's not my
thing
um all right swims in the sea every
morning in the sunshine is that
something you do well we'll get into
this in a minute okay something I'd like
to do it
okay enjoys the best of Life unfettered
by the consequences and responsibilities
that others have okay so tell me your
thought behind this tweet I think it all
makes a lot of sense doesn't it to be
honest I can't see any disagreement from
the audience about any of that at all
vasectomy though so okay so look there's
there is a little bit of context behind
this and I don't want to be like special
pleading here because I'm sort of holed
up in front of the court now to explain
myself so um the vasectomy thing has
been a little bit of a meme I would say
around and it's semi I know you've
discussed it sort of seriously
semi-seriously semi-humorously sort of
discussed I think he was sparked off by
Rollo tomasi who did a tweet a little
while ago which also went viral when he
talked about it was it was a very
similar sort of layout to this really
where he talks about High Valley man and
he was saying the fastest way to become
the highest value version of yourself
one of the things on there was to get a
vasectomy and he and when he was
challenged about that he said well the
reason for that is because if you get
into a situation with a woman where you
get somebody pregnant Maybe by accident
or maybe it's not the right woman for
you at that time obviously that's going
to impede your progress and he was
talking about basically like making
money and yeah becoming that sort of
highway I understood it perfectly but
everyone else was going crazy no
everyone went nuts and then that was
when he appeared on fresh and fit and
then he got challenged by well it was
Destiny wasn't it and sneako and then
there was this hot that whole debate
that that whole thing happened so when I
reference vasectomy in my tweet I was
sort of humorously referencing that if
that made sense he was kind of like a
little bit of a nod to to that but you
know some of the other things in the
tweet I I do think um
I I do stand by the sense that I think
that there's a model for life here that
gets shut out a little bit from the
conversation particularly with a lot of
the tricons are around that makes sense
yeah and why do you think that is like
where where well I think what I was
basically trying to say in that tweet is
that it is possible if you want to as an
older guy to have a great life and you
don't have to go down you know the
conventional pathway if you don't want
to now obviously for most people that's
not going to be applicable and I
completely accept that you know what you
know what I'm saying all I'm saying is
you know myself I mean I'm in my 40s I
have a pretty good time I travel around
a lot I date around I'm pretty I've got
quite a lot of personal freedom which I
personally could you know value I also
know dudes in their 50s even in their
60s who are also living a similar sort
of Lifestyle so all the the whole point
of the tweet and a lot of the stuff that
I put out recently which is a little a
little bit satirical a little bit spiky
whatever but the whole point of it is
just to say look
there's a load of track codes on here
who are basically telling you to get
shacked up at 22 find a wife have 15
kids go to IKEA every weekend and
pretend to be happy and all I'm saying
is you don't have to do that and you
don't have to be afraid if you don't do
that the organ just be left on the shelf
and actually I had I had a thought the
other day I was thinking about how
you're more likely to fail at marriage
than succeed and I thought about this
okay yeah what's the general reputation
of marriage pretty awful yeah negative
right it's not it's not a good thing
right yeah I'm not saying it can ever be
a good thing but just by and large it's
like a lot of times what I see them do
is they'll blame everyone else for
marriage is reputation I didn't create
the society yeah I didn't so it's not
our fault for talking about it so when I
thought about okay if we take 50 of
marriages fail and then we take the
other 50 and how if if there's a
negative reputation we can assume at
least half of those are unhappy which
isn't something that we would strive for
right then you can argue 75 failure rate
meaning you're more likely to fail than
succeed why is that the path to
happiness
yeah no I agree I because I think you
use that stat 75 I think in a tweet yeah
that was my reasoning everyone was like
it's not really 75 I'm like well yeah no
I did I did wonder what the figure was
but I think actually rich Cooper as well
had a tweet a while back and he had some
stats on unhappiness within marriage as
well and you know we'd have to look it
up but it was you know the bottom line
is that there was a lot of unhappiness a
quarter of them are sexless too so if
you're out of all these different yeah
yeah yeah so I think there's a just a
fundamental problem with and
particularly the treadcloud crowd you
look at something like Twitter or rights
or whatever it is you've got a bunch of
these track cards and they're just
pushing this narrative just get married
bro it's gonna be fine it's all gonna be
great that's the end point that you want
to strive for and I I don't believe
firstly that that's always the case
because I think as we said a lot of
marriages end up failing and secondly a
lot of marriage is not very happy and
there's a lot of infidelity as well and
secondly I don't believe if you don't
want that route that that has to be the
only route that's open well and and red
what red pilled me a bit was
interviewing these guys for this divorce
stuff documentary yeah and I would just
look and I'm like I can name at least 10
men off the top of my heads that are
absolutely worse off because they went
that route well there's no if fans or
I'm not saying don't do it like for some
people it's amazing and awesome but this
idea that like one is the best path
moving forward I think look I mean I
think if it worked as it's meant to work
correct it would be brilliant and who
wouldn't want to sign up for that you
know what I'm saying but unfortunately
and I think you've made this point we
live in a society where it just doesn't
work in the same way that it was meant
to yeah and a good friend of mine
recently has been completely you know
screwed over by this I mean he's having
big problems in terms of custody of his
child and you know you go down that
traditional route and suddenly the rug
gets pulled out from under you yeah so
again you know I'm not saying don't do
it but I think you do have to proceed
with caution and realize what the
reality of the situation is now yeah
what are you guys's thoughts on on his
tweet I mean I can see why it's
controversial and I understand like I
understand it from both perspectives is
because I'm married and I see the value
in marriage and I think that marriage is
really important
um
and you know I love my husband and he
loves me and he protects me he provides
for me
and like there's something so beautiful
in that so I see it from that
perspective so there's like the Romantic
in me and and the woman in me that you
know that values marriage but at the
same time also being a lawyer I
understand how the law discriminates
against men I understand
how especially when it comes to divorce
custody battles
um division of the assets all of these
types of things are all against men and
and it's true what you said Troy about
how the child cons sort of talk about
marriage as the ultimate goal and they
don't necessarily talk about the risks
that come with it and so yeah like you
said men get blindsided so I see both
sides of it the vasectomy thing is
controversial but at the same time it's
like
a form of birth control like women get
you know the the metal rod up you know
and that's that's extreme right I mean
it can be reversed I don't know much
about vasectomies but I understand they
can be reversed
um but yeah it I see both sides yeah I
think um it's a lot less guaranteed to
be able to get vasectomy reversed versus
using other methods of birth control I
think that when it comes to
contraception that's probably the number
one way to go about it if you're not
sure about having children if you feel
like it might be something that you want
but you want to increase your values and
assets so I feel like instead of going
the whole route of vasectomy which you
possibly can't reverse it in a lot of
cases a better method instead is like
okay make sure that your partner's on
contraception that you're using
contraception make sure that you're
playing against these chicks to tell you
if you're unconscious you know how many
guys I know that have been I mean yeah
you don't have to trust them I think you
should encourage them
um but you should also use a condom
right I'm just saying try to cover as
many bases as you possibly can if you're
not certain about having children in but
you don't want to completely cut that
possibility because I think having
children for a lot of people is a very
fulfilling experience that means a lot
to them of course I mean just on this
for sexy point I would say I think that
the argument that it is reversible I
think I would treat that with a lot of
skepticism personally you know what I'm
saying because I think I theoretically I
believe it is but I think if you're
going to go to that to that route
um
you know I I wouldn't rely on the
reversibility of it yeah just try to be
responsible try to be responsible here
no I do well you're going to lead these
men down the path well I know well I
didn't know I didn't know he's gonna get
a million a million hits you're just
that doesn't belong to say like you're
leading them down I know so do you have
a vasectomy here no God no are you sure
yeah
okay interesting well I'm shooting
blanks anyway
[Laughter]
it's just like you know
uh no I mean it no I don't and of course
that's you know I I again I have to say
it's a smart tweet bro the vasectomy
reference was a little bit
um
tongue-in-cheek and it was a reference
to some of these other tweets that have
gone around but you know I just think
it's interesting how you can't say it
without people getting so mad people go
yeah well this is the interesting thing
people go absolutely nuts yeah you know
and I kind of knew that I suppose when I
when I put it in you know it was kind
obviously it was meant to be provocative
result it was meant to piss people off a
bit it worked
um and it is interesting isn't it
because why is it and you we could I
suppose link it to the you know Plan B
kind of you know the the debate around I
mean I know a girl there was a girl that
came on the show that's infertile
because of Plan B
so it's like it's not like the birth
control methods don't have fertility
issues later no but it but it seems like
there's a sort of my body my choice when
we're discussing it from the woman's
perspective but from the male
perspective I mean look there's also a
lot of guys who are objecting to that
tweet as well so it's not just this is
coming from women but it does feel a
little bit like
that my body my choice thing doesn't
apply to men so much even though perhaps
it should something like this you know
what do you think Christian
yeah I mean
I see both sides of it as well at the
end of the day I think it is it is
interesting that that particular tweet
went viral and I do probably think it's
because of the vasectomy part of it
um it's exactly the same as what happens
with me
that's a vasectively oh my God yeah I
mean
look
everyone has free will right and if you
want to get a sec then of course
Guy Kenny think you need to understand
the risk behind that and you know if you
do then decide you want kids in the
future
um
you know who knows if these things are
reversible or not and the same thing
applies with women taking birth control
and plan B and all of that stuff um it's
the exact same thing but it is just
interesting the response to a man
talking about something like a vasectomy
but yeah no one's screaming at all of
the women about 90 of all of us yeah I
know 90 of us have been on birth control
at one point or another yeah I think
it's important to recognize though that
although if you like Miss properly use
birth control like if you use Plan B as
your main source of contraception then
yeah that can lead to infertility but
overall the methods of birth control are
a lot like safer
um and not very permanent compared to a
vasectomy well I mean I disagree with
that because I think that they tell us
that birth control is safe and they tell
us that birth control has no permanent
effects on us but at the end of the day
you're pumping synthetic hormones if
you're taking the pill or you've got
like the the marina in your arm your
pumping synthetic hormones into your
body and we have absolutely no idea what
that does on a long-term basis and and
imagine being the woman who's been told
it's been safe your whole life and then
you cannot have yeah let's talk about
the contradictions how about the fact
that the NHS website tells you that when
you're on the pill it can reduce your
chances of cancer when there are
studies left right and Center proving
that actually being on the pill
increases your chance of getting certain
types of cancer so let's not forget the
fact that a lot of these
stories that are talking about birth
control being a safe option of women and
a lot of the public health authorities
that are saying that it's a safe option
for women um there's an agenda behind
that and a lot of it's to do with the
fact that it like anything it's a
business and there's money to be made so
let's not be ignorant to that fact well
to be completely fair when you're
talking about like oh synthetic hormones
we don't know what they do et cetera Etc
um the fact is like there has been a lot
of data about how birth control can
actually like help with hormonal
regulations and although I would have
agreed with you if we lived in a
completely natural world maybe that
would be the case where it's like oh no
like it causes more imbalances and for
some woman it does
um the fact of the matter is there's so
much hormones in our food there's so
many things that we're consuming on a
day-to-day basis that affect our Cycles
personally I got an IUD and it really
changed my life for the better and the
reason why I say that is because before
that my hormones were all out of whack
probably has to do with my food maybe
genetics things like that and once I was
able to get it my period reduced my
cramps reduced I was able to actually
they start like living a more fulfilling
life and not just being put out of
commission one week every month but do
you not think you could have done that
naturally as well I mean well can you
not see that that could have been done
naturally and perhaps you're just
putting a plaster on you know an
immediate symptom you're saying all of
these symptoms have changed changed but
realistically you don't actually know
what the underlying cause of all of that
is I know it's increasingly hard in a
world where as you say everything's
unnatural completely agree with that
there's hormones in the water we all
know this there's you know probably a
bunch of [__] in the air that we're
breathing but
can you not see that perhaps you're kind
of buying into this idea that the way to
solve your health problems is just by
taking more drugs well here's the idea
right if I I'm not living in a jungle
separated from all people right I'm
living in a society where I constantly
have to interact with these things
whether I like it or not so unless if I
was able to put myself in like a
deserted island and live completely
naturally then I'd be like yeah sure
maybe that has to do something more with
my lifestyle there but you can eliminate
certain things out of your life and you
can take measures to ensure that you are
getting the least amount of hormones and
things like your water you know there's
filters and things that you can buy and
you can do things like the Elimination
Diet to see what certain foods that may
be irritating you and causing an influx
in your immune system there are measures
you can take that are natural instead of
shorting to hormones sure I'm not what
is it well yes and no right it depends a
lot also on your like personal like body
genetics
um you know for some people and this is
just a random example like having this
increase of hormones and whatever it
might not really affect them but for
another person it might really affect
them right so I think you should you try
your best to do whatever natural method
you can
um but at the end of the day like I
don't think you should be ashamed if hey
you know what that's not really working
it's really hard to live in a complete
natural world that seems to be the best
method I mean it's not really a a method
of there's nothing no no one's trying to
shame you but the point is to just
acknowledge that you know there are
there are ways to do things naturally
and they are the harder ways it is the
hard route I think it's more just about
acknowledging out the laziness of Our
Generation which is there are so many
easy options available and sometimes
it's just a bit easier to go yeah I'll
take this because it will solve the
symptoms immediately instead of having
to go through the mumps and perhaps
years of finding out what the underlying
cause is because the thing is like
potentially I've heard of women who've
had this happen to them where they've
been on a certain type of birth control
and they say I feel a lot better and
that's because of all of the like
Christine said it's basically a plaster
over your symptoms and then you come off
it and you have the exact same symptoms
that you had in the first place because
you never did anything to actually hear
what was going on and like Christine
said there's a lot that you can do
naturally to help your body and to heal
because you don't know the damage that
you could be doing but it is you know I
get that
that's going to take up a lot of time
and energy and effort but I just think
that we're selling this idea to women
that you know contraception can be used
for all these good things it's like okay
I hear what you're saying it can relieve
symptoms but we can't ignore the fact
that we're just talking about symptoms
that present on the surface none of this
is actually tackling any underlying
cause and unfortunately that's the world
we live in no one's going to talk about
the underlying cause because look I've
said it before I say it again a sick
patient is a returning customer and that
will continue to be the consensus for
our society because it's the world we
live in everything revolves around money
well I think there's a couple of things
to tackle here if this is reducing your
symptoms for like I'd say four to five
years or for as long as you have it then
you're technically not getting as
frequently sick as if you didn't have it
right so for example let's say I did not
have my IUD okay well then I have
extreme cramps like every month I'm
gonna have to be constantly getting um
Advil pain relief medication
um constantly buying more effeminine
products than when if I have that idea
do you see how you're going through when
you have these issues okay I need to go
get Advil I need to get this you'll go
to it it's like you you've been so
programmed that you can't see a way
around something other than to pump
yourself with more drugs well the point
that I'm trying to get across which I
think goes back to your whole laziness
comment is that if we lived in a world
where again there was no outside
influence sure but we don't and I don't
think it's fair that you can assign that
to like laziness I think um there's a
systemic issue at play here oh no that
we should we're all so lazy oh my have
you seen have you seen the 55 year old
60 year old women I mean compared to our
generation they'll do the laundry like
they'll they'll hand like have you seen
them just like get to work versus us we
get our ubereats they'll like cook for
uh house party of 12 and like 45 minutes
crazy I think we are lazy I think we are
absolutely lazier than the people before
us oh hey I agree I can see what you're
saying but I also think we have to take
into consideration that there's like you
know like Mega corporations out there
with a lot of money and power and like I
don't think it's fair to be what are
those have to do with us well we're
talking about like hormones in the water
we're talking about hormones in the food
we're talking about things that affect
our cycle and they are systemic levels
there's hormones in the food and
hormones in the water and all these
things and why add more hormones on top
of all the hormones that we're already
getting well the whole idea is that it's
trying to reach like a hormonal balance
right but it's not rechecking it it's
just masking the symptom it's not
treating the problem it's treating the
problem by basically getting your
hormonal levels yeah it's supposed to be
interesting because you're 24. so it's
interesting when you get because I'm
about to turn 27 and I'm sure same 31
yeah so you you start to see like the
chicks that were on birth control for
like 10 years really have and it's not
something that I really think they're
going to take an interest in in taking
the time to like I mean do studies and
real like they're not going to push this
they're selling the stuff but it's like
I know so many chicks that are
struggling to get pregnant now in their
late 20s and they had an IUD or they
were on birth control for Tanya and this
is just anecdotal like you can take it
or leave it but it's I just don't
believe the that stuff at all I think my
problem with that is that there's a lot
of more direct factories that we
actually have like consistently studied
to show effects and fertility so for
example like microplastics are a really
big thing that shows effects on
fertility and Plastics I'll give you an
example okay so growing up I had um I
had nannies so we would have nannies
every like two years they would come in
and I had one nanny I was I was so close
with her I was literally like she was
and she would have been such a great mom
and she got like this um shot that they
recommended it was like to prevent STD
she can't have kids now and it's like
directly from that shot now I know this
is anecdotal right I mean you could say
it's just a one-off but I guess I just
know too many random people that have
had stuff like that happen for me to say
that didn't have anything to do with it
yeah I guess my main question would be
like what else do these random people
have in common right are they consuming
like a lot of plastic
um do they live in the same area that
might have had like well I mean I've
lived all over Dude I live in England
now I've lived and it's just like a
weird thing starts happening when you
just interview so many people you just
hear the same stories from different
people it's like um the girl I'm
thinking of was from Germany you know
another girl I'm thinking of is from
America but like the commonality was
that they both had birth control now
again it's all anecdotal right but yeah
because I would argue like another
commonality is that they all probably
use like Plastic Products right or like
they so let me get this straight we
think that the plastic water bottle is
the same as like turning off your
fertility no what I'm saying is that
there's like a lot of like clear
evidence and data that shows that the
products that you know like micro
Plastics they get into our blood they
like affect our like hormones they
affect our fertility there's like clear
there's more clear data showing other
things that we consume that have major
effects on fertility
but I just I just think there's some
things I can like get through common
sense right I mean I think just use a
condom girl no I just think I think
there's like there's things that are
common sense right and I just think it's
common sense if you turn off your
fertility that's gonna be the biggest
effect that you can have on your
fertility well I think um what is it I
mean it depends on what type of birth
control you're using I think iuds most
of them what they do is they kill the
sperm so they're not really like
affecting like your inner
um what is it like having a piece of
plastic up there like I don't know
weren't you just talking about
microplastics
um I don't think all iuds are made of
like pure plastic
though that's the majority that yeah but
it's not the same no there's one that's
made there's one that's made of metal
but like the metal copper and also it's
not the most it's not the most common
though but the more people get like the
the plastic one yeah I think um what is
it again there's different type of iuds
so you can like work with your doctor to
find out which one you think is the best
for you
um and on top of that like again not old
Plastics are also created equal I'm
talking about like the plastic in your
water bottle like there's different
types of plastic out there as well some
are more likely to leak microplastics
and others so so you think that this is
more has more to do with infertility
than birth control
um not just your water bottle think
about everything you know I'm asking I'm
asking like microplastics has more to do
with infertility than birth control yeah
like based on the available data
directly you can laugh at it but you
guys can search it up it's pretty easy
it was a thing there's no denying that
microplastics can affect your fertility
but at the end of the day you're pumping
yourself with synthetic hormones you're
pumping yourself every single day for 10
years with synthetic hormones that are
designed to turn off your fertility that
is going to have a far greater effect on
your life than drinking from a plastic
water bottle well that's not how every
IUD works right there's a variety a lot
of them just kill the sperm before it
enters not every IUD is hormonal so if
you don't want to do an eye hormonal IUD
that's okay too you can do a
non-hormonal one yeah I just because to
me I just I just go down to the basics
I'm like you're shoving a big piece of
metal up there like that like that that
just can't be good yeah I'm you know I'm
not I don't like that's the thing you
just you start to be around long enough
they half of the research is funded by
people that have an interest in lying to
you about the research so half of it's
like funded by the people that are
making this stuff and selling it to you
why would I believe them that's like
believing like the the people that like
sell toothpaste and they're like mine
our dentist recommended this is the best
one yeah that's just how I think of it
yeah I think my main problem with that
argument is that you can technically say
that everybody's trying to sell some
sort of product right so you can be like
oh people who are convincing you not to
get iuds are trying to convince you to
have like you know children not safely
so that you have to like buy more
materials for your children like they're
trying to sell you diapers
that's why I always say like for me
personally it's like the number one
thing I think we can go about is like
common sense and what we see in the real
world and I just I just think like we've
kind of lost as a society where it's
like they want to convince you water
isn't wet the sky isn't blue
yeah you know and it's like I just to me
I I don't see how pumping your body full
of like just personally I I can't see
how pumping your body full of hormones
and and messing with your natural
fertility it just seems like that's
gonna have issues yeah I hope it doesn't
you know yeah I think um again if you
feel like a hormonal IUD is too much for
you because you have copper too I'm like
I don't that doesn't seem good that [__]
it doesn't to me it's so sensitive to
Copper
um out of curiosity do you feel like
people should still have the freedom to
choose it no I'd ban it if it was in
Pearl's world
I have no I have I have no power over
this decision you know but personal
opinion I think it does more harm than
good
um okay out of curiosity do you feel the
same way about like all forms of birth
control yeah I would ban it all okay I
just I think it's really interesting
because like we were just having a
conversation about like vasectomies and
like how they can be useful
um when it comes to making sure you're
having oh I would ban some other stuff
too like you can't just ban the birth
control okay I would ban I have a whole
list of like things
well I would but only you know hear me
out hear me out hear me out I would but
you have to ban divorce too okay so if I
ban divorce like you can't do one or the
other it has to all go together so I
would like ban the divorce I would ban
all that this is just if I was like
Queen you know tomorrow I'm not I have
no I have no sales and I'll see
something go for it so you're not on any
contraception are you on contraception
at the moment yeah I I have an IUD I got
it for health purposes
um it's really it changed my life for
the better so do you never use condoms
then
um that wasn't my question okay
I um I think I I think everybody should
use like as many forms of contraception
as possible because that's just the safe
thing right
um you know I want like to have children
in the future I don't want to get an STD
I think everybody should be safe okay
okay just use condoms guys skins all the
way
you guys think
um I think when it comes to vasectomy I
think it's like a it's like a choice
thing because I think for
one of the things I've been listening is
there is this expectation in society of
what makes like what makes you a happier
person or what makes you live a more
fruit-free life but I think no one
really knows right so obviously there is
they're being responsible being
responsible you have to make that choice
um me personally I've got children so
and I want to have you know a lot more
children so naturally from a personal
standpoint it's like okay I'm not I
wouldn't do a vasectomy however I
wouldn't feel like
you know I know enough to say to someone
don't ever do that because you'll make
you feel unhappy because I don't know
that I've never done it myself so I
think with the three I think naturally
you've acknowledged you've been
provocative by you know by by mentioning
it yeah and the fact you haven't got
yourself is quite telling you know what
you know to eating and having it so I
don't know I think um it's kind of a
preference
well I don't swim in the sea every
morning
I don't know if that makes it better or
worse
no I have to I would love to swim in the
sea everyone I think ideal in an Ideal
World I would swim in the sea every
morning
um but I mean you know if we want to go
to the letter of the law if you look at
the phrasing of the Tweet he doesn't say
these are the things I've done to make
me a high value man I've said it's a
proposition it's a notional proposition
of some factors that could add up to a
high value man of which the vasectomy
was you know a little bit jokey I mean
if I'd have known it was going to hit
1.2 million or whatever it is I probably
might have rethought it a little bit but
you know at the same time at the same
time I do think guys you know should be
allowed to have that autonomy if they if
they want to I don't see why there's
there should be any problem with that
really yeah I'm a little bit confused
confused about why um
Bannock complete or why you would ban
vasectomies and like birth control can
you elaborate more on that oh I just I
think it does more harm than good I
think we have like a collapsing birth
rate like problem and I just I think
family I I have I have weird views on
this right I I think family is good I
think marriage is good but I think that
the way we do it today like I just think
it's unfair to men and so I I think we
should get rid of birth control I think
one it gives us all these hormonal
issues two
um we're not having as many kids as we
used to have
um and three
I I want I also think it's kind of
weaponized against men a lot of times
like women lie about being on it not
being on it I think that's unfair
um but yeah I just I don't think it's
not good for society so I would ban it
but that's just my opinion yeah I think
um I mean obviously we're all well I'm
in disagreement with you guys when it
comes to like the hormonal issues
um but I do think when it comes to what
you're talking about like collapsing
birth rate a lot of people talk about it
as it's like this inherently bad thing
but I don't really think of it that way
and the reason why I don't think of it
that way is because having lots of
children isn't good if those children
aren't being raised right right if those
children are in like bad economic
scenarios
um if you're just having a lot of
children to have a lot of children
you're not gonna be able to have enough
time or money to give them the attention
and care that they need
um I think in a lot of Western countries
you see like a lower birth rate but in
return you see like a higher quality of
life for a lot of these children
compared to other places I disagree I
think we'd have less mental health
problems if that was true
um because I what I see is more mental
health issues in Western countries I
think what's much more likely is that in
Western Country trees you can actually
get properly diagnosed while in
developing countries like everything is
so messed up there that it's hard to get
a proper diagnosis much less afford to
go to a doctor or much less like afford
to get have you spent a lot of time in
developing countries
um I mean I yeah I would argue okay I
mean I would argue or yes I mean I went
to Columbia for like a mission trip the
other like a few months ago to help with
like doctors there translating English
and Spanish and you're in your like
conclusion was that they had mental
health issues they just didn't know it
oh my um my conclusion is basically like
if you're living in a low quality life
you're gonna have mental issues no
matter what but yeah like there's also
been like data researching this sorry
what would your class as a low quality
life
um having trouble affording food basic
necessities
um not being able to afford treatment
for like mental health or physical
health either
um having like trouble so what what
countries have a low quality like what
what countries would you say the
majority
um you can probably like search up an
index online right now I would argue
like a lot of African countries I would
argue a lot of like countries in South
America
I mean
I think you know what to be to be
obviously your entirety opinion but I
think to so Colombia is that the only
like country you've country I would say
is like developing um I've been to the
Dominican Republic public I've been to
Costa Rica I think considering like I
think me personally I think considering
how big the world is like to have such a
like you know generalized statement I
think you would like it would require
traveling more and just experiencing it
more so I think because because it can
become a dangerous rhetoric to say that
from going to a few places and one of
the things you referenced was oh you
could check the index online I don't
think that's like a representative of
how those countries are kind of like
what's going on over there like maybe we
should take a trip to more places and
just have a look okay I have a I have a
genuine question for you guys do you
think that not being able to have
um food water access to like Health
means that your quality of life is going
to be peachy and okay do not think those
things are relevant but that's because
you'll determine you're determining the
value of Life by your materialistic
consumeristic possessions instead of
health is not consumerist health is
literally how you feel your definition
of how it is how many drugs you can pump
into your body that is not my definition
of Health my definition of health is
whether you're getting the basic
nutrients to like survive and not be
like near death that's my definition of
Health Western company countries are
obese
so like it's a little less healthy no
but I just said that they're they're
like they would have issues because
they're less healthy but we're less
healthy okay
um at least when it comes to obesity you
can like lose that weight
um it's difficult but it's a lot harder
right what is it if they don't like I
mean you can't statistically like
there's a very big difference between
like hey you know you're overweight and
you can lose it versus you're not having
access to clean water you know like
these are vastly different things like
one is actually much easier to remedy
than the other where do they like where
would you say they don't have access to
clean water because didn't you say we
don't have clean water either I mean
there's a difference between like water
that's going to give you like parasites
and like you know like bacterial
problems versus like water that um might
have like a few hormones in there like
there's a very big difference between
those two I would say so um I have a
question when you travel to wherever you
travel to where you saw where they have
what does that have parasites was it
like the whole city of like where you
went to or was it like a French Little
Village well um what is it I mean in a
lot of countries they recommend for you
to like not drink the water without a
filter because drinking the water like
can give you those problems
um I visited the wyu people which is
like a whole like basically Northern
area of Colombia
um their population is like over a
million people but yeah
and they I mean they recommended not to
drink the water in general the
population of over a million people won
according to you are living in poverty
they have mental health issues and then
they are malnourished yeah one million
people I think um or a number similar to
that and it's not just there right we
there's Global poverty is a thing that
exists right like we're not going to
pretend that is like okay so those one
million people are living in poverty
they have health issues they have mental
health issues they have bad water and
yet they seem to still Thrive and
there's no widespread disease in that
area there's no like farming it's the
opposite there is there is widespread
disease in that area there's a bunch of
people who have parasites a bunch of
children who have parasites it's really
sad actually
you know you know I'm going to say I
think to be fair to you you're trying to
you're trying to improvise however I
think you're operating with limited
information very limited
mentioned Africa because 100
um yeah I've
it's just what I notice about Americans
you guys live in such a bubble you think
that America is the only place that has
technology or has
um
the answer to life the reality is what
you are speaking about when you're
talking about Africans that live in
poverty and all of that the thing is you
haven't actually spoken to these people
you haven't actually have discussions
with these people the truth is
most people that live in a family
a family unit depend no matter what
their economic status is are usually
happier than people that live the way
you live [__] and I'm speaking about
this from personal experience I grew up
in an in an estate where it was
literally like
a family unit where where in that little
in that little environment where we live
they were like more than a thousand
different apartments and we all saw each
other's family we all grew up together
we weren't necessarily the richest
people in the world but
we all thrived I'm here today I'm
healthier than most people I see walking
around even though I come from where I
come from so the fact that you guys have
this Narrative of uh just because people
from Africa they are not healthy or they
are they I didn't say that I didn't say
just be good okay I didn't say just
because you're in Africa you're
automatically going to live an
unhealthier life that's not what I said
what I said is that there are African
countries who have a lower quality of
life um and not just Africans I will
tell you is the places that have what
you're speaking about are usually the
minority it's not the majority you put
it out as if it's it's something that's
afflicting Africa okay which is and also
your point was on Mental Health that you
know these people are unhappy but I'm
saying mental and physical it's actually
the mental health point I'm actually
trying to tackle the health one is is
completely false but the mental health
one is very laughable because there are
more mad people in America than you find
in Africa I can't guarantee you that
okay you have people walking down the
street shooting people going into school
shooting things like that don't happen
in Africa people don't just carry guns
and start shooting up a school in Africa
the same time doesn't happen in Africa
no crime happens but you
think about it what kind of Madness do
you have to have for you to pick up a
gun and walk into a school with children
and shoot up at school yeah there's
definitely different types of Madness um
wait has that ever happened in America
in Africa bro has it ever happened in
Africa has anyone have you heard about
shootings
um the main argument also the people in
Africa suddenly wake up and decide that
they want to be a different gender
okay I don't think that happens if
you're trying to go back to the main
argument I think um what I was trying to
say is that yeah developing nations tend
to have like worse outcomes physically
um I would say mentally as well that
doesn't mean every single person has
mental health issues or that you know
it's all one or another I'm just saying
that when you're in a less developed
Nation you tend to have like a worse
quality of life overall and I think
that's messed up what makes a good
quality of life
um access to basic necessities lower
risk of um so so like money like food
and water okay but you know what's
interesting what you don't say a stable
family I mean I think that's the most
important thing because I I Know Rich
Kids that literally are so messed up
mentally because their parents like
didn't care yeah for sure so it's like
like to me like the most important thing
like kids need is parents yeah I think
that's like above access to all the
stuff you're talking about I I genuinely
like think that the most messed up thing
you you can do to a kid is not have
parents yeah and I would or I would
respond with that that one of the things
that makes it hard is to have a stable
family unit is being in poverty and not
having access to those those supplies
and there's been like a couple of like
studies about this that yeah guess what
when you help get people out of poverty
when people are moved out of poverty
their home life situation improves
because they're less stressed they can
take more time to focus on the kids to
nurture them instead of having to worry
about like okay where where am I going
to get clean water where am I going to
get good I think then why why why when
the quality of life has gone up in the
last hundred years have you seen more
divorces that doesn't make any sense
like 90 90 percent of people were
married 100 years ago life was a lot
harder now then well here's the thing
she's conflicting she's conflicting
places that probably have
issues that come from either war with
normal African places so for instance
the point I'm trying to make is if you
go to any Village in Nigeria you'll find
way more healthier healthy people than
you'll find in America you see people
that live until they are 90 because they
eat natural food they Farm their food
they know that they get their medicine
straight from the ground they don't take
drugs they don't take all of that you
see people that understand in Africa you
have people that they call herbalists
these are medical doctors
that you call them medical doctors in
the west but there we call them
um Native doctors that understand plants
that can heal your headaches heal your
menstrual issues heal your fertility
issues without having to go to a
hospital and you find all these people
there in Africa and they live a very
high quality of life because they don't
have the problems of the western world
like for example and they find solutions
to most of the problems you think are
problems for instance you were saying
something about dirty water
you look at it as dirty water because
you probably went to a place where there
is water literally they go to the river
fetch their water go home and boil it so
you saying dirty water as if they're
just going to pick up the water from the
ground and drink it straight from there
these people understand these things
they've they've had systems that they
have developed over centuries just
because they don't do it the way the
Western people do it doesn't mean that
they are wrong or you guys are better
um I have two things to say I would love
it if you could give me the name of like
these Villages that have like a higher
um you know longevity of Life compared
to Western countries like like that
would be cool so that way I can like
research it myself and I could see and
learn more so if you can give me a list
that would be awesome she's on TK um no
no I don't have to give you literally
just search Nigeria and search any any
state you want to search and just look
you can find information online look for
any State in Nigeria and look for a
village okay
um and then the second thing I would say
is that you can boil water to make it
cleaner in certain circumstances but
there's other circumstances where you
know a lot of people the way that they
get their water is from the ground right
and what happens sometimes is that
depending on like the mineral
composition of that area it could be
very salty so you can't really boil salt
out of water which makes the water like
very hard to drink and makes it like
kind of bad to drink this is the problem
you're speaking about this from a
western point of view the people that
indigenous to those places know where to
get their water from not because they
just happen to stumble on something yeah
no the why you knocking knew they've had
generations of upon James because most
of them are indigenous to the place they
know where they get their good water
from they know where they get the water
where you'll probably be poisonous to
you they're not just stopping I know
whatever ground to pick up whatever
water I know but even then like the Yu
people still struggled because that was
a problem like even though they knew
where to get clean water it was still
like a limited Supply so they had to get
it from other sports sources as well so
that's that's just a minority you can't
use that well as a blanket to say well
that means African people and Colombians
are awesome you can't say they're all
poisoned you can't wait I feel you can't
say that about yours as well you're
saying like oh no like this is how the
majority of people live and I feel like
we would need like datas or studies the
majority of people in Nigeria actually
live really good average life okay well
I'm talking about Africa as a whole they
have access no my point is the majority
of people in Africa
live in cities they have we have cities
in Africa just the way you have in
America yeah sure the villages are there
obviously but most people live in cities
just like we believe we have skyscrapers
we have elevators yeah absolutely yeah
well you didn't sound like you knew that
but I was trying to make sure that you
did well yeah what I was trying to
convey is that you know you have Global
poverty in a lot of places in Africa
India China
um South America like I'm not trying to
say like oh Africa is the only place
that has Poverty of course not I know
that there's people who live a great
quality of life there
um what I'm trying to say is that hey
Global poverty is a thing people are
living lives that could be better that
could be improved and we should try to
do that but why why do we assume Western
is better I don't assume Western is
better I assume access to basic supplies
is better yeah so so yeah I will just
listen to this and as an African
Cameroon I wasn't born in this country
um shout out to King Nigerian shout out
to obviously all the African chat to Vic
as well Germany brother so I think
you're talking about this from a very
Western way of looking at it I think
it's quite offensive as well how you're
speaking it's not for us to tell you
what the the percentage of of African
countries that are living is for you to
say because you're coming out with a
very broad statement right now we don't
need to prove anything you need to prove
what you're talking about and it seems
that you have a very very my new um
um specimen and dates or to come from
and you're talking about little tribes
in South America that's not Africa no no
wait let me carry on so the reason why
I'm saying this is because America as a
whole there's parts of America that are
literally like a third world country you
have people you have crackhead epidemics
you have um what's that other one what's
that one they got fentanyl fentanyl all
these types of things right and to come
out here and to speak and to say to
somebody like King who came from nothing
literally and is here now um you know as
a producer of the just Purley show how
did he do that if he was struggling if
he was skinny how did he do that so this
much so this so This I find it quite
offensive I'll be honest with you
because in order for you to say these
things you need to have data and you
don't have data and when we ask you it's
kind of like well you know you tell me
the countries no you tell me the
countries because Africa is not um see
when people speak about Africa it's not
money Africa is a continent it's made up
of so many different countries right and
um let's let me speak about RFP RP
Gaddafi see Gaddafi Gaddafi was a great
man a very great man Canal Gaddafi
um Libya used to be we used to fly
through Tripoli we used to fly through
freaky Airlines to Cameroon Libya was a
very um very developed country uh you
know none of the residents needed to
pretty much do anything
um they used to um Gaddafi used to pay
for a lot Gaddafi wanted to have um a
central Africa kind of like United
States of America he also wanted to put
a pipe for Africa to run water across
Africa
um The Other Nation didn't like this and
they started a war in Africa and
obviously now Libya destabilized and
obviously like to the outside world you
guys will think that Libya was Libya was
a war zone but Libya was never Wars on
Libya was a beautiful place not Libya's
Awards on and now they're trading the
slaves so the reason why I say this is
because America has so much influence in
Africa and you guys and literally Africa
is the backbone to the to the to the
modern society so when you speak like
this it's quite offensive because we
couldn't even be doing this show right
now without Africa you couldn't be using
your phone without Africa you can be
using the computer we're using without
Africa Africa is the is Africa is the
bloodline of the world so when you speak
just get a little bit more education and
if you want to speak about countries
make sure you say some names okay I can
pull up my phone right now like I'm
feeling please please do please okay
sure I'll pull up like the global
poverty index but by the way I just want
to make it really clear I think it's
insane that people are saying oh access
to basic food and water is a western
concept I think that's something that
all nations strive for wait wait wait
let me add on top of that
um you guys asked me to name some
countries some places that have poverty
I said some countries in Africa
obviously Africa isn't the only place
that has poverty okay like I never said
that I feel like you guys are twisting
my words
why was that your first thing you go to
what was your first thing to say because
at least to my understanding and to my
knowledge there are high rates of
poverty in certain countries there that
are war-torn and yeah a lot of it has
been because of European and United
States influence in the past I'm not
denying that I would never deny that
um but then I followed with countries in
South America India and China have also
really high rates of poverty like I'm
sorry if I came across saying like Oh no
just Africa because that wasn't my full
sentence and that wasn't my full
sentiment the point I was trying to get
across is yeah there's a lot of Nations
around the world that are poor and that
sucks I think you attach you attached so
see what king was saying about Africa's
is very has a big sense of family family
unit and that's what we promote over
there so it seems to a western thing
where you attach monetary value of how
happy you are and this is why we come
people work so much they get you know
they go get the mortgage they go get the
kids you know get the finance they get
all of these things and they feel
suffocated because they were told that
this is what's supposed to make you
happy but come to Africa and you're
going to see people you're going to see
kids literally just walking down the
road playing with sticks and they're
gonna be way more happier than you you
know why because it's quality of living
versus what you think it is so you're
talking about boiling water people do
that every single day people do that
every single day but to you it seems
seems like wow how could they do that
their life must be so hard I couldn't
believe you said that if you don't have
access to health that means basically
you you have mental health that's crazy
to me because I'm saying it's higher
there are higher correlations no way
because that means I'm sorry you're
pretending like if Axis or lack of
access doesn't add stress to your life
sorry you're talking about stress
everyone has stress versus
um mental health condition that's that's
completely different
affects your mentality no but that's not
well documented it's not cool just
talking about correlation versus cause
right so what I'm talking about is end
of the day is across the world people
have stress
people are poor everywhere people are
poor come come around London I'll show
you some poor people too yeah yeah so
exactly and the more stressed you are
because of those situations the harder
it is to deal and create a healthy
family Dynamic I'm not saying it's
impossible no this is definitely not
impossible I never said that
um but I am saying like hey yeah it is
hard to maintain a happy family when
your family's struggling in general to
get basically
this is what we're saying you literally
don't know what you're saying
no I'm speaking from Facts I'm sorry
that's not Western do you do you have a
big family yes I have a big family
absolutely
um at least 17 first cousins
I'm talking about your immediate family
siblings directly okay how many siblings
do you have I have uh what is it mom dad
and brother but I consider all right
dude I'm Sorry by Hispanic no you now
I'm gonna tell you about my culture I'm
gonna tell you about Hispanic culture
okay the point that I'm trying to make
is that when you say oh direct family is
the only thing that matters that's
[__] I never said okay then why are
you being like Oh you know like you how
many directions do you have I asked you
for a reason why you let me land okay
ask for a reason for instance I would
say um obviously the whole family thing
has started being destroyed all around
the world it's just not even the worst
it's not even affecting Africa my point
is our generation we live in a selfish
generation everybody is all about me me
me if you go back two generations ago if
you go to like for instance my mom's
generation my mom had 12 siblings
now my mom came from a family that had
that she had 12 siblings there's no
issue on Earth that she could be going
through that she will not have someone
to go and speak to there is nothing she
was she could have gone through no
matter how stressful her life is that
she wouldn't have someone in her Corner
that she could speak to but now all you
guys do is you are Source things that
your family should do to you too like a
therapist you associate to a doctor you
are Source it to your friends you are
Source it to all other people people
that don't actually care about you and
that is the culture that has been
perpetrated in the west the point is
when you have families you literally
have a place you can run to in your time
of need and these are people that you
are sure at least for the most part that
have your best interest at heart that
was my point so when you say things like
oh it's hard to have a good family when
you guys are in poverty that's not true
because I can literally point to many
people that are living in poverty and
they have tons of brothers and sisters
and they are all happy they all sleep in
the same room they all sleep side by
side with each other they all eat from
the same plate and they are all happy
oh you wouldn't know that because
obviously you think that you have to
have a certain amount of money in your
bank to be able to raise the phone can I
say something can I can I say something
so
um my family my dad is from Nepal which
is a poor country in Asia so I
understand what you're saying so for
example when we go there there's no
clean water
you can boil the water but then you know
there's problems with that and so coming
from a western society and then going
and see how they live there it is hard
for me to see how they're living like
that and I understand what you're saying
like in in terms of like
um access to health so say for example
yes it's true that these people can have
big families but in my family where
there's lots and lots of people My
Grandmother Had
she lost two babies because she had no
access to health so like I understand
what everybody's saying but I also I
think that
access to clean water access to
healthcare where you can go to a doctor
you can get help I'm not saying
obviously I'm against like the General
Health Society where we're like go to
pump drugs and all that stuff I'm not
saying that but that does affect your
life it doesn't because like for example
my granddad taking care of all these
kids you think he wasn't stressed do you
think their lives weren't hard of course
yes having a big family they had the
support they had each other and they
were happy and like for example in Nepal
you go up to the mountains and you go
tracking those people have nothing and
they're happy but when there's a problem
when somebody gets sick that person
could die because there's no doctor
there
so it it goes both ways and I I like I
think maybe what you said was taken out
of potentially slightly out of context
like I understand why everybody got
upset because it could be taken one way
but the fact is that having no access to
healthcare is a problem that is a
problem and it happens in this world
like can I can I let me give you a fact
right so
um I've never been to a hospital for any
illness my whole life and I grew up in
the circumstances you guys I've never
not for one illness not for nothing ever
and I grew up in a village with no
running water no electricity we had to
walk to the spring so if you look at
this thing tell us what was the water
you're drinking any any water company
what does he trying to show you of why
they put a price point on the water we
got it from a spring you know where
Springs are yeah I know exactly so
naturally you should like what the
brother was saying over there it's like
naturally the people that are living in
this indigenous part they had they know
how to Source water because I come from
one of those Villages so I think it's a
dangerous assumption and I'll tell you
why it's dangerous when I first came to
England the representation of Africa was
this Oxfam adverts on TV yeah that
everywhere in Africa that's how it is
and I was like completely sure that I
know that's not what it is
I might be completely honest with you
yeah I grew up thinking Africa everyone
lives in a mud hut no one has anything
because that's that's just nice
that's a stereotype so it's shown to us
and it's the truth of it and it's only
through you know talking to people like
for example working here speaking to
people like King but I've I've learned
you know I've seen uh our other producer
uh blessing has shown me like places in
Zimbabwe like they literally have houses
that look like what we would imagine a
five-star hotel so but we don't get
shown that because they want you to
think oh in Africa like that they're all
starving and they're all struggling and
they could never possibly be happy with
that no and I think that's the problem
is thinking that they all have because
they don't have the standard of living I
agree with you like not having access to
health is a bit of a different issue
however to think that just because they
go through all of these struggles that
we couldn't possibly get in our ignorant
Western lives we couldn't possibly
understand that to think that just
because they have different issues and
stresses from us that they therefore
then have mental health problems that
probably aren't diagnosed like no I
think you're ignoring the fact that we
just overdike every we over diagnose
everything in the west because we just
we like to make problems because we have
our basic necessities Mets we make
problems well we're just a bunch of
whiners oh my God it's like complain
about everything yeah but at the same
time like say for example somewhere like
a a developed a developing country
um something like for example postnatal
depression won't be recognized because
they don't have that kind of mindset
when it comes to things so people will
be suffering in silence and we can't
just say that those things won't happen
and for example like say for example you
said that you've never been you'd never
been to a doctor when you're living in
your village and things like that
but women die in childbirth because
there's complications and there's no one
there yeah but here's the issue if
you're going to bring up isolated
situations which obviously is very real
and it is happening right like make sure
you specify you're talking of isolated
incidents but when you generalize the
statement that's that's the thing I'm
talking about so I understand like
there's an element of trying to apply
empathy and I get that however there's
also sensitivity when you speak of these
things and say for example if you're
speaking of it instead of you know I've
traveled around 15 20 countries and this
is what this was my experience I can
respect that and accept that okay that's
our experience I'm trying to say to you
but when you say it there's an element
of presumption and assumption based on
what the general thought is or the
general perspective well I'll tell you
why I only asked it because what I found
is like people will go on like three
mission trip a couple mission trips and
then come back with like the rest the
world needs saving oh wait wait wait
wait wait
like I just find this phenomenon because
where I'm where I'm from like people do
that they're going a couple mission
trips and like be like but you know what
yeah but you know
no I'm just I just find this phenomenon
I don't know but then I'll like talk to
the people like from these places and
they're like no we're okay
you know what it is yeah
see it's like it's like okay so how many
we have like 200 000 is it 200 000 years
of recorded human history right you guys
have to understand that people have been
giving birth in caves like it's did
There's a western notion that if you
don't have every single thing you're not
going to be okay you do realize in
certain parts of the world we're not
going to have certain diseases because
we can't have those diseases we haven't
I'm not gonna say people can't be
depressed but I promise you this
depression is not going to be the same
way because people have to get to work
there's no time to be depressed when you
have to feed Africa is not the same here
you can have 10 kids over there if you
can't feed them No One's Gonna Give You
a house No One's Gonna Give You no
benefits that's it's not the same type
of things over so is it so is it Chris
is it China nice to meet you um
what you're what you're talking about
what you thought of Africa is when I
went to school some people thought the
same because of the images that got put
in them so let me just before you see it
so you can that's fine but let me give
you a slightly different like
um like my upbringing right so I came to
this country when I was probably about
three like three and a half or what have
you not my dad was a diplomat for the
Cameroon Embassy
um and my dad is a professor with two
phds and and and he's and he's a very
learned man he's a smart guy he's also a
professor yeah yeah yeah yeah like um
he's also a doctor as well and my mom's
got a PhD as well I have three I have
three sisters a brother
um they're all educated all my little
child right I grew up in a seven bedroom
home my sister went to private school I
had a very good upbringing
um and
laughs
if you really want to know about Africa
speak to Africans like seriously it's
okay not to unders not to know something
but to come on a platform and to make a
blanket statement when you haven't
because you haven't traveled enough
countries to make a statement and it's
okay but it's ignorance
where can I just say something can I
just say something and the problem with
ignorance is when you meet the people
that are trying to educate no matter you
keep trying to interrupt you think you
know more than the African person that
was born in Africa that grew up in
Africa that came here you have several
Africans here that are giving you their
experience not an adult we have three
Africans here
[Laughter]
he don't look like he's starving to me
you know what I mean
wait you guys are being very African
look at what I said and see that you're
trying to like twist my words you're
twisting my words
okay let me finish my sentence you can
finish your sentence I let you finish
your sentence multiple times you
actually did it okay well right now I'm
addressing to the people who are
actually listening right I want to
apologize I don't I didn't mean to come
off as saying like oh all Africans are
poor I didn't I thought it was general
knowledge that Africa has cities and
that you know not like it's not all a
destitute place like obviously it's not
I didn't know that that's a experience
that you guys had growing up here or
being here that you have got a lot of
people thinking that way that's my bad
because I just want to stay
I'm African you're like oh don't do that
don't do that all right listen I listen
all right listen I feel like can I say
something
everyone's ganging up on this girl and I
feel like it's unfair to be to be honest
I feel like it's unfair because I've
just looked at a statistic 1.1 billion
out of 6.1 billion people in this world
live in acute multi-dimensional poverty
across 110 countries and I feel like
that's what she was trying to say and
it's just being taken out of content
it's really unfair like that's what she
said none of us would have said that
that's not what she said you weren't
listening to me wow so you should not
list other countries did you not say
other countries as well it's not fair
like she didn't just say you know what's
not fair do you know it's not fair do
you know it's not fair you have three
African people here that wasn't born in
this country that are giving you their
experience and you're choosing you said
I just read a statistics Colombia
because so many questions in Colombia
and Africa no I said no I said some
African countries what ones oh hey I'm
pretty sure Sudan
um Ethiopia I believe like there it's
not like this super out there idea
like there like as I said before there
are countries in Africa obviously not
all of them obviously not all of Africa
that do suffer from poverty so is the
countries in South America States of
America suffer from poverty yeah but
it's a different degree and different
level and the reason why it's a
different level is because it goes back
to like access to like basic Healthcare
I think I think their point I think the
point they're trying to make is that a
lot of it's like misrepresented by the
media and so they'll go to these places
and say they're living in this terrible
terrible poverty and then they'll say
well no we're not and then oftentimes
like when when they say that they're
like well where are your studies and
then they're like well I'm from Africa
yeah I'm saying so I think that's their
point yeah I could tell it's not that
like they don't have like there's
certain things that you know but it's
like it goes back to like who has a
lower standard of living like the People
Like Us who have the birth control water
or them who has to boil it you know well
it's like yeah I I think like what I was
trying to say is that like oh you know
there's a lot of data showing that
there's countries in Africa South
America around the world that when you
have like lower access to Food Water
Healthcare it can cause a lot of tragedy
and it can cause a lot of stress within
families that doesn't mean that there's
no happy families it doesn't mean it's
impossible to have a good time I think
like what I was trying to say is like a
lot of a lot of times we like equate
that that's gonna break up the family
but it's like the West we have a higher
standard of living than ever before and
we have more divorces we have more
marital problems we have more we have
more issues like mental health issues
and I I don't think it's just that we
have more people to diagnose it like I
don't think that's true I I think we
just have more issues because of single
mother homes which we reward in the west
I mean it's the cultural issues in the
world isn't it that's underlying it
really it's the cultural the fact that
you know the the family is less
respected the fact that you know
religion's eroded so therefore there are
less societal controls on you know
divorce and all the rest of it it's
those things it's those cultural things
I think that
I think also something what part was
alluding to earlier on that we didn't
even go into our fingers this idea of
poor like people don't want to say the
truth about you ever have money or you
don't right so when you when people say
poor they normally think of money or
Rich you think of money right but
there's such a thing as being rich and
support being rich or family being
because you can have all the money you
want I don't have all those other things
does it make you does it give you a
better quality you know than another
person so I think right which which is
why I was saying like why do we assume
the West is better when a lot of times
like in these places they'll have a lot
like tighter knit family units yeah you
know I think um the main argument that I
was trying to get across was that like
hey you know there is a chance that a
lot of these places are suffering from
things that aren't diagnosed there's a
chance that they aren't but I think we
all overall can agree that hey these
people should have access to like
healthy food clean water Healthcare in
general do you think do you think we
have access to like because we're it's
just it just contradicts a little bit
what you said earlier we have all these
like hormones in the food and the water
yeah but the point is that when we
compare like the water quality to
certain places to that of America like
there are places that have significantly
worse water quality so even though you
can argue that like our water quality
isn't perfect it is still better than
like getting a potential parasite but I
I think my my whole point is that in the
west even though we have all these
amenities like the family unit is it's
terrible like I think like what a third
half of kids are born out of wedlock
into single mother homes because we
reward all these terrible decisions yeah
rockets in the UK are likely to have an
iPhone than they are to have a dad in
their lives wow that's a real statistic
wow yeah I had the same reaction and
this was actually in 2013 so chances are
that the numbers have gone drastically
up by now but in 2013 kids who are sat
there sitting their gcses were more
likely to have an iPhone than they were
to have a dad that's mad I mean it's
probably some of these iPhones are
probably more useful than some of these
dads out here to be honest with you
you already you already know every
single problem is linked to single
mother no 100 but at the same time like
I have to I have to I hold women account
every single day and I have no problem
with doing it the part of holding women
account is that I see men that are not
holding himself account and you know
part of doing the Manning's voice is
that I see men that go out there and
create these homes yeah you understand
so it's like yeah but the women open up
their life I understand the women open
up their legs but anyone that's got
gamer anyone that gets girls understand
that you can make a woman open up her
legs per se right to get me yeah and if
I do that one where I say okay no 100
also then I'm doing a little bit where
I'm come on man Romeo come on you know
what I'm saying there's that little bit
where Magnum can twang they can do the
bars they can do all of that stuff yeah
I understand but that's the point where
women have to say is that men always
want to sleep with you they're always
going to do this yeah they're always
going to lie to you so if you do if you
choose to believe the lie or then that's
up to you no one's forcing you to but
men we know we got the time we know man
that always is like a strong word like
sometimes maybe not always okay okay
sometimes right do you know what it is
um because it's because like I always
I'm very I'm very hot on the women out
you know everyone that's in the content
knows I am but I keep seeing men that
are doing certain things and I can't
really co-sign it like what bro like
[__] man it's about to get done
you want to say like what backing out of
a fight huh
in China
what have you done bro what have you
done
let me get back to business
trying to
[Laughter]
wait what was I saying he's talking
about man I'm talking about the guys the
the bad dads the bad that's it yeah yeah
like like certain amount of like what's
a statistic what have you ever been a
stepdad before what step dad come on you
know I don't play those games
no I'll never be a step dad why not why
not huh why not because so no but if but
if you really love the girl here and you
and and okay she's got kids okay
why would I be the woman that couldn't
give me so check this out do you agree
that step dads have held down a lot of
homes that rule fathers left I wouldn't
I wouldn't say real fathers women choose
the men they choose to be with and if
you choose to lay down with a man that
choose to leave you that's that's all
new you should have picked a man that
would have stayed there's lots of men
that would have stayed so you're saying
the woman should know what the man's
gonna do the woman should listen I
really think most of the time it's the
woman being spiteful and not letting the
dad see the kid that's like my opinion
on it that does happen a lot so for me
this is what it comes down to right is
is is is is is is
I don't know if you have kids okay let
me change this if you have kids blended
family you guys that got kids if you got
one I got one let's get together make a
blender family that's all cool but what
we tend to have is women out here with
kids that that you know that don't
understand that most men men don't
really want to be a stepdad most men
will lie to you they just want to you
know blow your back up
I'm just being honest bro man I'm not
trying to and the reason why girls will
be girls would be like oh you know what
but I've never had a problem man I
always date me the kids I'll say where
are they now of course men are gonna
date you because they don't gonna be
around for a while if you love the woman
so much no the chance of a single and a
hand butchering it but it's like the
chance of a single mom getting a guy to
marry her it's like uh 13 to 18 roughly
percent live with her 22 percent so it's
pretty much over for single mothers yeah
with a high value man marry a single
mother why would they do that why don't
make him low value exactly okay and I'm
glad you guys I mean miracles happen but
they usually don't I'm glad you guys
I've been holding this back waiting to
talk okay okay high value man what's oh
oh yeah this is what we came here
what's the high value man you told me
you had to finish in China don't tell me
what you think tell me what you tell me
what you class as a higher value man let
me hear your opinion bro
see
if he
no do you know what it is because I can
give the definition of a high but
there's a definition
my definition unless you're telling me
your definition
no it's not the crowd there's a it's see
we all can't have this is what happens
when women do I'm a 10 I'm a ten I'm a
ten if everyone's attended no one's a 10
so there's only going to be one high
value because if not then we can always
bend it to to I'm high value what's your
definition so my my definition is the
original definition you need to be a man
that's you know earning will say in this
country for about 70k you need to well
you need to be yeah earning 70k or so
you need to be and earning that over for
like this four to five years you need to
be um wow you can't be a lone wolf so
you need to be somebody that's you know
that's all to others in the group yeah
usually the others in the group so just
saying that yo I get money by myself but
no one around yourself doesn't get money
that's that's you know I mean you can't
be someone that's out there being loose
with your seat so ideally you wouldn't
have any kids already you wouldn't be
divorced
um yeah man just just can you see why
that's a dangerous rhetoric wow for like
the I got a teenage son for example yeah
right I wouldn't say to him okay son
this is the definition of a high value
man and this is what you need to like
measure up yourself up to because
society says that's what you should do
don't you see how dangerous that is no
he's a good man good man your definition
is quite westernized because you're
taking the word value and determining it
no because where are we I'm not in see
see here's the thing right even though
this is the problem with this convert
always gets stereo she's everybody so
where are we right even if I went if I
went to Africa I would tailor it
slightly different but it would it would
still come down to be a man that could
be um a man that was useful a man had
access to tools a man that was other
stuff so it they will always come around
resources who you are finances can I
just tell you how the way I see it for a
second so the what you're saying about
the money side of it
a certain level of wealth and more money
it just means you're still going to have
the same problems as when you had
perhaps say slightly less say 40 Grand
to say 70 grand yeah right 40 Grand like
you basically you're able to provide no
problem right and you can provide for
wife children and you can have a certain
quality of life 70 grand your quality of
quality of life you know goes up in
terms of materialistic possessions
things like that but so does your house
bills so does your car insurance so at a
certain level it's like okay you have
more money but your problems have also
grown as well so I personally wouldn't
take the whole you know top 10 one
percent earners into being high value
because I think you just need to have a
certain amount of value I I guess my
problem with what you said is the whole
70 grand okay so I'm not talking about
the money so here's the thing right if
we don't set anything then anyone is
yeah so what I'm trying to say to you so
we do when you say we usually well no I
agree with it I agree with it right
because when roller tomasi was got
caught in on this or yeah exactly the
same thing happened what rollers roller
tomasi said also the Russian whale he
was like well it depends on culturally
so the high value man in a small village
in some remote place is going to have
different characteristics to the dude
he's in like Miami whatever and that is
broadly speaking true but at the same
time I think there's a certain amount of
like when I get into these conversations
with guys on Twitter and they live in
the UK or they live in America or
something there's a certain amount of
disingenuousness because I think the
reality is and also as well my tweet in
particular we're talking about it's kind
of from a dating perspective right we
kind of know what we're talking about
don't we we kind of basically know what
we're talking about and you're right it
is those things it's like are you are
you in are you in decent shape do you
present well do you do you have
Financial Resources do you have the
ability to command the respect of others
around you you know do you have some
kind of social sites those things
broadly speaking
uh equates high value and I think
sometimes people try and chip away at
the definitions around it'd be like well
you know it is I can learn and then I
can say too like I said it to before I
look at man I know he gets girls I just
and this is when women do these things
pretend like that I can look at a guy
straight away and I can assess him
especially without I can look at the car
he drives I could I could look at his
watch I could look at um I could look at
where he stays I can look at the
business he does and all through that
already I already know I look at the I
look at his Friendship Circle I look at
who follows him and from that already I
know who he is a question what about the
guy that's using all those things just
to control the environment what do you
mean using those metrics like to control
the environment like obviously because
they know what you think of when you say
a man of a nice car or what people think
of this year guy OverWatch yeah why are
the people are using just to control the
environment no but at the same time they
should no but see here's the thing
you're still finessing the way to it and
if that gets you to where you need to be
it's still going to get you in the room
wherever if you are faking it it will
get exposed later on if you're faking
the lifestyle trust me you'll get
exposed but if the watch is fake if the
if the car is on if the car ain't yours
if the place is an Airbnb trust me bro
you'll get found out but if it's not
then you are high value and then it's
gonna only open access to more things P
like even the network that you surround
yourself with like you know when you you
know when you go to places if you can
get get into places and people invite
you to places it's because you're
somebody that already makes you somebody
so you go to a lot of press events you
go to a lot of things right you're like
yeah that that means you're somebody
that means you're not yeah
well trust me okay I wouldn't I wouldn't
say here's the thing I just wanted to
where I'm from the real definition of a
high value man is down to two things one
is his character and two is his
usefulness to others right yeah the
group thank you
to others is different from the way they
put it in these like Western so they
always make about money but the reality
is anyone can get and lose money at any
point in life okay but what is most
important is the man's character because
bro
has nothing to do with what women want
thank you
you cannot be a you cannot be a high
value man if you cannot provide for what
women want you cannot be a high value
man if you cannot provide for what you
cannot it's impossible if you are not
providing for what your woman wants you
are not high value you are low value is
it possible if you come again if your
missus wants something and you cannot
provide for it you are you are low value
bro 100 so you have to be rich bro yeah
okay you don't have to be rich guys okay
I'm gonna let him finish and then you
can go okay I never said provisioning is
not part of it I said being a high value
man has nothing to do with what women
want what women want everything to do
with what's your purpose as a manager
Thank You Preach so it also has
everything to do with what women need no
it's the Versace
china are you a high value man would you
say are you a high value man no I'm not
okay yeah because because you know what
I'm saying to you like
because
my point is there are people that don't
ever get married
EG Catholic priests that are of way more
importance to society than most of these
rich men are okay okay so all right so I
think it's jumping around a little bit
bro he's jumping he's jumping we're
talking about Catholic priests being
high value bro
[Laughter]
sorry can I say yeah it provides to
society yeah guys okay okay I need I'm
gonna let I'm gonna let him go and then
you go okay okay I think we're focusing
too much on money on money right when I
said for what a woman wants like you
should not even be marrying if you can't
if you can't if you can't provide for
your women this is the problem men are
supposed to be leaders and providers
yeah and and one of the things that
women keep saying is these men want me
to do this and do this but they don't
want to provide I don't want to do
nothing you expect women to do something
but you can't even lead them so I'm not
saying that oh you're supposed to bend
to your wife swim no but she needs a
house bro she needs a house wait hold on
a second to buy a house together just
together foreign
you see me I'm a provider bro I go out
there and I make sure that my Miss is
gonna get it you might wanna go 50 50
live with a girl and dude no cause I
can't get no respect like that because
man what I'm saying though just like
just follow follow me here I'm with you
just follow me it's what king was saying
right
see when a man's a big step up you step
like that anyway because that's who you
are principally right so you see when
you when you find a woman that like you
know some women attracted to the mind
I'm never gonna go into that right when
you find a woman that like aspires to
that and she's powerful as well you
don't become a union the motivation is
not let me become successful because I
want to get a woman or prove the woman
that I can pay a bills that's not what
it is you're supposed to have those
principles and those characteristics
anyway I think there's two slightly
there's two slightly different things
here though because what King's saying
is correct in the sense that a high
value man in the sort of like moralistic
sense of the world yes he should be
Noble he should have you know good
intentions he should be you know a
leader in the community et cetera et
cetera is that stuff necessarily going
to get him laid not necessarily so so
there when you think about if you're if
you're in the nightclub if you're in the
nightclub in Los Angeles and you you're
talking to it and this has been told to
me anecdotally by somebody that I know
you know you're talking to a group of
girls it's like high-class models or
whatever and then Leonardo DiCaprio
walks in right what do you think happens
to the [__] girls do they stand that
do they sit there singing to your broker
or do they all [__] disappear so if
value didn't exist if value was just
this completely nebulous concept that's
entirely subjective then how is it that
somebody who's a movie star who okay
he's not as great now but who was decent
looking has huge status and and let's
face it money within Society how is that
he comes in and sweeps all the girls
right there's clearly something going on
here right otherwise it wouldn't it
wouldn't be like that otherwise they'd
just go well no this dude over here is
more noble than Leo so I'm just going to
stay with him tonight and not go to the
mansion party
no boys
[Music]
what I want to say is like for me a high
value man is somebody who has integrity
and somebody who can be a good husband
thank you because like for me my husband
is an amazing man an amazing leader and
has nothing to do with money like you
can have so much money and be a bad
husband you can have so much money and
be a bad father you can have so much
money and do lots and lots of things
terribly and I think like your example
about you know you go to the club and
all the girls interested in Leo they're
not white that speaks
in China listen free but in the brutal
reality of the sexual Marketplace who's
gonna win out is it going to be Leo or
is it going to be the Supernova couple
if the girl goes for Leo then it's not a
girl for me I get what you're saying
like the more options available to you
than the chances of of a man being
successful not give your goals sleep in
the morning
I think I think we have there has to be
way to measure it and my problem is a
lot of times when we go back to the
character arguments which are all like
fine and dandy how do you measure it
yeah I mean like because then it's very
subjective
King's Point is entirely right like if
if we lived in a society that was fair
and decent and we were all like you know
I don't know we all behaved as we should
do then then absolutely right the dude
who's got the best moral character
should be at the top of the tree but
unfortunately I don't believe we live in
that world or certainly not in the west
anywhere and honestly I just I really
don't believe these like where they're
like if women I think most women even
wives if they thought that some of these
celebrity dudes would take them
seriously I I don't really believe that
they wouldn't be interested
like they're like the high value thing
the reason why I said it has nothing to
do with women is because if you're
measuring a high value the value of a
Man based on the Matrix of women that's
just
think about it like this Leonardo
DiCaprio yes he might walk into this
room and grab all the girls and all of
that but in a situation if a serious
situation comes up do you think anybody
if we're in a groom of men do you think
people are going to look to the United
for leadership no I don't know so that
he inherently he's not a high value man
in terms of he's a waste man I have a
question
who's gonna get their end away though
because a man can get delayed by women
doesn't mean that's not what I said okay
wait okay I'm way more than women okay
I'm gonna let trigger then you can go
okay no look I mean I I agree with what
it's like I don't think a guy should set
out to measure his own value by how many
times he can get laid I think that's
[__] pathetic I totally agree with
that however it depends on what prison
we're looking at this high value
question through if we're looking at it
through the brutal realities of the
current modern dating Marketplace the
reality is that Leo or whoever other
ex-celebrity you want to put in his
place right he's going to get his end
away more than the average dude however
nice the average dude is I'm not saying
it's right and I'm not saying that is
the true measure of a man's worth
whether he can pull some you know clubs
home or not but that is the brutal
reality of the way the sexual
Marketplace is now because the majority
of women in the social Marketplace at
the moment are these hoes hype women who
do put these things at the top of their
well value systems yeah what does that
say about women when we're given all the
freedom and that's all right
question okay
um so to my understanding like you guys
believe that men should be like the
leaders of society slash they are the
leaders of society right yeah um so I'm
just trying to make this clear
um but it seems like you hold
responsibility about like broken
households like only on women and to me
that's a little bit strange because it's
like if men are supposed to lead the
woman then it's a failure of leadership
if women aren't like falling to place so
okay I'll actually I I blame women all
the time so I'll take this one
um so I think it's the woman's fault
because the women tend to leave and they
tend to leave for stupid reasons yeah
but then my argument is that if you
believe like the natural order is that
like men are supposed to lead and that
women are socially submissive there's
obviously something wrong with like
leadership if some women are so
willingly and easily okay so I would I
would argue it's because men have no
power in this Society they know that if
they leave that they lose
um they they know they lose everything
honestly if if it doesn't work out women
know they gain everything if you pay
people to make bad decisions they're
going to make bad decisions yeah but I
thought my understanding was that like
oh you know high value men do have all
the power in society like that's at
least maybe that's different in this
podcast but at least in the ones I've
been before they talk about like oh you
know the one percent men get older women
they get all the money well I think
Global all the resources so when it
comes to the dating Market yeah they
have the most power in the dating market
like the most choice of course yeah um
but so so when I okay if me and you if
me and you make a business deal right
and if the deal fails you get all the
money and if the deal fails I lose all
the money I'm always going to be trying
to make you happy because I don't want
you to leave and that's and I just don't
think that works women hate guys like
give them whatever they want but a lot
of marriages turn into that because
women have all the power and the average
men have no control over this you know
you could I would argue that Elite
liberal men did this by giving women the
right to vote and Women Voters
policies that I would argue discriminate
against men
um but I would I would say it is out of
order and men are not able to leave
because of the leverage that women have
yeah I think maybe I just like
fundamentally disagree because in most
divorce cases like alimony is only 10
like at least in the United States it's
familiar 50 50 when it comes to divorce
unless if you have like those what about
what's the most important thing what do
you know what's the most important so
what is the most important thing
I think um what is it I I'm not sure
what would you say in a marriage is the
most important thing
um communication no no no not like and
and to make it work I mean like what
what is the most important thing that
you get out of marriage like a loving
partner children okay and men only get
custody 10 of the time at least in the
United States the way that it's phrased
is that the primary caregiver right so
they punish men for doing the right
thing no because because if if men I've
talked to lawyers if men do the right
thing and we you know she could tell you
she's a lawyer uh but if men do the
right thing which is to provide for
their family they're punished because
they didn't spend as much time with the
kids but that's what you're supposed to
do yeah so the way they write the laws I
would argue discriminates against men
because even in 50 50 relationships
quote unquote 50 50. it's like uh 70 of
the time roughly men are are still
paying the majority they still make more
so do you believe that men should have
like you know more time off to be able
to take care of their children or should
be able to like because you know you
have like maternal leave in a lot of
places right you believe that there
should be like an equal amount of
paternal leave that's also paid no um I
I'm not here to say how you should like
structure your family with words Society
I'm saying no I I'm saying I'm saying
that with the divorce laws and the child
support laws being the way they are it
makes it very difficult for men to lead
because women have so much leverage yeah
and I'm saying that like when you're
painting this picture of society and
you're saying oh no the men are getting
punished for being like providers but we
have an increasing Society where you
know women also work and they're
expected to do health so women but women
they're doing both of these things women
the one thing is women chose to work so
we didn't have to work we chose to do
that and the other thing is women want a
lifestyle that men that average men
can't afford so they want to get their
nails done and I could just say this
anecdotally from having so many chicks
come on the show they all have their
nails done a lot of times they have
botox a lot of times they have fake hair
a lot of times they the latest fashion
trends like our grandmothers and great
grandmothers didn't have all of that
stuff and they went down in lifestyle
for the children for the family that was
what was important but we have again
back to the me me materialistic is the
number one thing in this Society
Instagram social media why do you think
women divorce
um I I think women think that they can
do better and I think there's a couple
things that go on I think one social
media deludes us I think we live women
it's like we spend eight hours a day on
social media you don't think that's
going to influence us 80 percent of
consumer buying decisions are made by
women telling us we're going to be young
forever telling us we're going to be hot
forever telling us men like [__]
telling us old women are attractive
they're starting to cast old lady actors
in as leads like why is the 33 year old
telling them baby and so I I think that
like really makes us live in this La La
Land and delusion and no one tells us
the truth for our whole lives and I
think a lot of times we think we can do
better better which the data will tell
you we can't we don't we don't remarry
typically if we have a kid and I think
that you know I I think we do leave for
stupid reasons and and you know one of
them I think women also starve men of
sex and then they get cheated on but
they a lot of times they don't sleep
with them for two three years as a
divorce attorney I'm sure you've heard
that story a million times yeah
um I think women are also very
controlling and conniving and I and I
think yeah and I think we try to control
situations because we're told we should
have an equal say and be an equal
partnership yeah I think um at least
when it comes like the divorce stats I
read it seems like one of the primary
reasons for divorce is that women are
doing you know the labor outside the
home and I know you're saying women
choose to do that but I also think that
there's a reality that we live in a time
of inflation we live in a time where I
want us from personal experience about
the whole like cost of living argument
okay wait wait let me finish
um
wait so so you know we live in a time
where there's like inflation where it's
harder to have like this minimum quality
of life where you know we're just
struggling as a society as a whole so
this whole idea that like oh no like you
know women just choose to work or
whatever A lot of them like don't a lot
of them need that to keep the family
afloat and I think that causes a lot of
stress and problems and I think there's
ways we can fix it right as a society I
think um this is a controversial opinion
for both sides but yeah I think we
should give like a minimum tax credit
for people who have children to like
encourage the woman to stay at home to
make it less financially like
distressful but I think this whole idea
that like oh no they're just leaving for
stupid reasons okay so so if money is
the issue is it going to be fixed when
you have two rents
what do you mean by so you you said that
the issue is that women have to not it's
not just money it's money okay okay so
now you have two households to do labor
in how does that solve the problem well
no you don't have two houses no because
she gets an apartment and he gets an
apartment yeah and now he she only has
to take care about her and her child she
doesn't take care of her her child her
work and her mouth so but I'm saying
there's two rents right yeah
right but she still has to cook for
herself yeah for herself and her child
but I just I think we live in like this
is deluded like you also get less help
like from the guy like if you wanna if
you want to change a light bulb and when
women single women always have their
smoke detectors going off yeah
like there's things that men provide
like the thing is women and this I think
actually brings us to a problem in
society well women are always keeping
score and you can't keep scoring a
marriage even that mentality right there
that's keeping score well I did this for
you I'm also working I'm doing this this
which you're thinking about me me me me
when it's not about you it's about your
kids like we're gonna divorce over
chores well it's not just chores right
it's a built up resentment
yeah on top of the built-up resentment
it's the fact that like yeah there is
added stress even if you're not
consciously keeping count it does add up
when you have to do more chores more
labor more housekeeping more everything
right right but this goes back to our
conversation about Africa because
according to you African people don't
have families I'm just obviously that's
not what you said I'm just being funny
well anyways the point is in the Western
World you guys have roombas you have
washing machines you have electric
cookers you have
um
[Laughter]
she does it for her personal life and
she even does it as a job you know well
and this other idea that women haven't
worked in history it's like the dumbest
[__] I've ever heard women women would
work twice as hard for a lifestyle that
was worse like you think that the women
on the farms were like they spent all
day helping their husband and feel
Google like a day in the life of the
Amish those women like they get up they
milk the cows they're sweeping the bar
then they go cook for their husband like
the difference one the difference is
they're it at home I think um what is it
I I think this idea that just having two
parents in the household automatically
equals good household is wrong did you
have did you did you grow up with
married parents yeah I grew up in a very
traditional household so I think that's
a really privileged position to have
what I
yeah no I didn't say that it
automatically
equals a happy household I'm saying
that's a very privileged position from
someone that has had two parents in the
home it's because I've had two parents
at the home that I can say like hey you
know what like this is not necessarily
the most ideal lifestyle that people
make it out to be at the end of the day
no I'm saying that we should strive
towards healthy like communication and
healthy who decides who decides what
communication is healthy I mean I think
we can like all decide that together
right you shouldn't scream as a partner
you shouldn't um down to them no see
talk down that's subjective what is
talking to the problem is the problem is
I mean but then women take everything as
an insult
[Laughter]
I don't know but this is the this is
abuses anyone women abuse men way more
than men would even abuse women yeah I
just don't think that either way I don't
think either partner should insult their
partner
is you think that there is this ideal
way family should be the fact is there
is no perfect family and they can never
be a perfect family what they can be is
a family yeah but we can say like hey
you know what some families are in a
healthier structure than others for
example everything in life but yeah but
that's what we everything but that's it
but that's the whole point is two parent
homes are better well there's no even
there's nothing there's no nothing okay
we didn't say perfect but there is no
like there should be no disagreement
that two parents in the home is better
100 I don't I no there is disagreement
because if you have a two parental
household and you have one of the
parents like for example leading a whole
lifestyle that's not a healthy leading
what a whole lifestyle like let's say
with them like either the mom or dad is
constantly out like cheating um bringing
those problems at home that's not a good
like I would say they're better off
separate if you have a relationship wait
if you have a relationship where one one
of the parents is constantly hitting the
other that's not healthy either your
child do it can I can I tell you
something it's interesting that like
women it's like I can't go a single show
without abuse being brought up it's
really funny because like it's the
propaganda they added this propaganda in
the 1900s to make women think if they
submit to men that basically you're just
gonna be abused I don't know so so what
about the statistics of the the literal
fact that um the the majority of people
who are struggling with things like
mental health conditions which obviously
you were talking about earlier the
majority of criminals majority of
problems suicide Society
um most of them grew up in a single
parent household okay there's two things
to take into account here I wonder if
you're taking into account like the
financial level and income because yeah
guess what even if you're a single
parent household if you have uh let's
say your mom has a lot of money or your
dad has a lot of money chances are
you're going to be a lot better than a
two parents okay do you know what's so
crazy you keep going back to this where
money is better than I'm talking about
Western Society no but even in a western
Society yeah like why is why is a money
better than a father because that's what
that's what it is at the end of the day
it's never a single father home it's
almost always a single mother home so
you're basically saying that money
replaces fatherhood and you know what
that is that no it's funny because that
is the conclusion that most western
women come to because in the last
hundred years when women have gotten the
opportunity to take money over a debt
that is what we do okay and that's why
we shouldn't vote and that's why we
shouldn't have all these privileges and
that's why we shouldn't go to these
goddamn therapists that just tell you to
get divorced because when women get
power over men they abuse it and it's
from the horse's mouth okay I'm not
gonna Pretend We're Not Gonna pretend
that in a society money doesn't matter
at all okay like that is just like no no
no
family is more important than money
Family a father is more valuable than
anything money can buy okay
let's be clear because if you're in an
abusive situation why do you always
go because
women are abused
I think just physical even no they
include everything either way verbal
abuse mental abuse and one-sided abuse
women are more likely to hit men than
men are likely to hit women okay and
when it comes to one-sided abuse which
means because most in most abusive
situations they're hitting each other
when one person's hitting the other and
it's not retaliated women are more
likely to do it to men than men are more
than men are to do it to women we all
know that the police don't believe I've
been hit by a woman and that's messed up
but the point that I'm trying to make is
that hey you know what there are certain
situations whether it be abuse or the
say hoeing around it doesn't just have
to be one where yeah if you have an
unstable parent in the household you
know threatening your child's livelihood
threatening the stability yeah you're
better off awake but it's like it's like
you know it's so it's so crazy because
again you go back to abuse
around example we can use the one where
you know they're bringing random other
people into them
this kind of goes back to how women
think we just operate out of fear a lot
so it's like always like what could go
wrong what could go wrong when the goal
really needs to be families should be
together fathers are so important to the
development of the child and I am so
tired of women with two parents whining
about their childhood we had two parents
we had it better than most people do and
it's like then we're gonna say oh it's
not perfect so therefore it's not always
a healthy environment fatherhood is
extremely important I'm not disagreeing
with that what I'm disagreeing with is
this idea that it's like always going to
be better than an unstable father
okay but then when you're talking about
like single-family households how
they're ruining Society Etc
yeah well I think you have to take into
consideration like hey you know what a
lot of these like situations are caused
because of instability in the household
but it's not a loss the minority it's
the minority and no one's saying that
the people who go through these awful
situations of things like abuse drug
addiction all of that stuff the things
that can't be helped that is awful and
no one is sitting here and saying well
they should have just stayed right no
one is saying that but we're talking
we're having a broad conversation about
the state of society and the truth is
the majority of people who have grown up
in single-parent households
they're not the exception to the rule
and what you're talking about is the
exception to the rule and I don't think
anyone here is denying the the exception
to the rule exists but if we're gonna
stay founded in in reality we have to be
able to talk about the general consensus
well yeah aside from the I thought I
feel like you're over inflating I feel
like this is all to try and make it this
is like what what about is um it's just
like it's just there's always something
else there's always something else
there's always another scenario another
situation yes it can happen whenever we
speak we're not speaking up in absolute
So when you say oh well it could be
abusive it could be a whole of course
they could be abusive of course there
could be a hole that's that you know
that's what happens right but what is
the what is that what is actually can I
say one thing do you know what the
solution to this is is
fathers because fathers are supposed to
vet the men we pick that's the real
solution fathers fathers don't pick
abusive men they want what's best for
their daughter well that's but the
problem is again was women have gotten
more Choice what have they chosen to be
by our damn selves and take money from
the government instead of fathers and
then when when there are situations like
that what what is the what is the slogan
daddy issues there's a reason well that
kind of like contradicts your own point
because the whole idea is that hey guess
what there are bad fathers out there
that would pick bad spouses for their
children they don't care about their
children very much or they're not it's
not that's not what they're saying no
that's not what I said did you say
fathers are the solution I said fathers
are the most important thing to a
child's upbringing a kid needs a father
yeah and but you also said that like oh
you know if fathers just chose their you
know spouses I would say women get
pregnant
um four men that do not wish to be
fathers often and don't really give a
[__] about them a lot of times because
they're trying to trap a guy
um and I think that's a bad situation
and I think that that's why it's
important that we have fathers to vet
the men that we choose yeah but that's a
that's a problem within itself because
you have those bad fathers that keep the
cycle going that you not everybody has a
good father that can choose a good
spouse
are the majority yeah they are the
minority 100 but narrative to push
because you're making it seem as it
because the way saying it it for it to
be that big of a problem it means that
it has to be the majority of fathers
that are bad but if it is not the
majority of fathers that are bad then
you should stop pushing it as a
narrative now you I think it's fair to
say that there is like a strong
percentage maybe not majority of people
who are bad fathers I disagree this is
like an African thing again oh okay
speaking of the parents speaking as a
parent I can tell you personally
definitely right so I'm cool I'm in this
I got 18 year old 13 year on a one year
old right same same same same mom now
naturally we're co-operating no matter
how it gets between us because we both
understand that we're both needed in the
kid's life we find a way to stay
amicable now the alternative could be oh
I don't care because we're not getting
on leave my kid like it so so what
you're saying I'm saying to you both
parents like the problem the problem
happens is that sometimes when both
parents fall like if they can't see if
they can't put the kids first that's
when it turns into a lot of what you're
talking about but parents that can say
what person and say you know actually it
is about the child and actually I've got
like for example I've got a daughter I'm
I'm gonna pick a boyfriend she might not
like it but I'm gonna be there to vet
I'm gonna be there to play that role and
that is important to stop you know
perpetrating the same circles that we're
speaking about I mean think about it we
make the stupidest buying decisions you
know what I mean like we make 80 a
consumer buying decisions even though we
make less money what does that tell us
we're not very logical we don't make
good decisions why on Earth would we
pick good partners I think when it comes
to the consumer point at least
um a lot of that at least my
understanding comes from like household
expenses so like you know know the
mothers are usually the ones like buying
groceries like buying I mean that's what
they tell you but I see every mother
with fake nails Botox and a fake hair
it's like and a pound of makeup come on
I feel like um I don't know I at least
maybe I disagree with that because like
if you think about it like for example
the Cosmetic industry I used to work in
the Cosmetic industry at a counter
selling makeup and like that is not a
household expense yeah women will come
and spend hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of dollars on things that they
don't need
um potentially just because yeah for
their own uh selfish reasons and like
going back to the fathers and
particularly
when it comes to the legal system like
Poe was saying men are disadvantaged in
this in this society and especially in
the legal system for for partly the
reason that you said where we're just
viewing men as these like abusive scary
perpetrators that just hurt children and
do all these bad things and we're not
saying like Christine said that it
doesn't happen it does happen but like
that narrative is so dangerous because
most men are not like that most men are
good men most men love their children
and most men should have access to their
children yet for some reason the legal
system says no give the child to the
mother
why just give it to just give it to the
mother and then they don't actually
assess the outcomes for the child they
don't they never did a study and said
when we put the children with the mother
do they have a better life are they
happier do they have a more logical out
look on on their lives are they
emotionally stable they never did those
studies and the data actually supports
the contrary it supports that actually
the children who are with the father
tend to do better yeah exactly so it's
like if we had these terrible fathers
why is it that the single dad homes are
turning out better than the single mom
homes exactly well I would argue that
like a single dad home most likely has
like a larger if you're able to let me
start here I do think that there are
disadvantages towards being a man and
legal system I just want to make that
clear now if you have the money to fight
those disadvantages chances are you're a
lot more stable and you're a lot more
like Financial but you agree that
there's uh what is it that there's a
disappearance really you really equate
money to everything like you keep going
back to this okay the reason why I keep
going back to it is because it's a fact
that at the very least in Western
Society hey guess what
um being able to have a lot of money
means being able to give your child a
good education surround them with like
very like this
what just happened to Elon Musk what do
you mean Elon musk's kid you didn't hear
about it what about came out came out
awoke liberal hating him yeah money
money doesn't buy because good children
look at Michelle look at the Obama's
kids look at Joe Biden's kids those are
all people with access to the best of
the best let me be clear it's money and
good Parenthood and I don't want to
start like what is it putting down good
Parenthood that was never my intention
here my intention here is to show like
hey you know what like I don't think
that the vast majority of single mothers
just you know divorce out of whim I
think um there are structural issues I
would say I would say they divorce out
of selfishness and I would say that's
that's the that's the biggest thing
because the thing is if you talk to like
grandmothers great grandmothers because
we really have like one maybe two
generations in my opinion of just shitty
wives bad wives overall just bad and and
um so but if you talk to like the
grandmothers the great grandmother's
divorce was never an option because they
cared about the family more than
themselves but now we have a generation
of wives that care about themselves more
than the family and their personal
happiness and when the kids are supposed
to be the most important thing yeah I
think um again and I think that would
you agree with that the kids should be
more important than you yes okay okay
wait okay wait wait so so if the kids
are more important than you wouldn't it
be selfish to divorce for personal
reasons not necessarily because of those
personal reasons in general
um in general
um can I finish the sentence no in
general I guess in general in general
yes okay so in general it it's selfish
to divorce for yourself that's where I
disagree because no you just you just
said let me I have to I have to finish
this statement I have to put it in a
context okay I know but because what you
tend to do is just like go to these
Fringe well if this crazy thing happens
then okay but like in general well
that's the thing it's not Fringe right
we live and I think this we can argue
this goes back to traditional gender
roles we live in a society where hey
like a lot of women are doing a lot of
you know labor outside the house inside
the house you know taking down two roles
I have a question I have a question do
you think most modern chicks have
recipes that they've learned from their
grandma that have a cookbook of stuff
that they know how to make do you think
that's the norm
um no okay okay do you think like if you
go into a random person a random girl's
car is it neat most of the time
um no no no no Okay so we've just that
we so now just based off of all the
people in this room shaking their heads
at these things we're showing women
don't really have those traditional
skills okay but why why do women not
have these traditional skills well
anyways
wait until you're blaming it on men wait
you're literally blaming it on men now
no no listen no the women they don't
have fathers it's a man's fault then
it's not the man's fault you're saying
they didn't have fathers so that's why
it doesn't mean it's a man's fault wait
so you chose not to have a father do you
know how far that means the man's fault
you can see the way your you
process information well anyways my
point is I wanted to correct what you
said you said the reason why father
single father homes do better than
single mother homes because the man will
probably have money has nothing to do
money the reason why single father homes
do better than single mother homes
because men are generally better at
instilling discipline in children than
women
you can tell that it's evident because
men in society the way we interact with
each other we tend to build hierarchical
structures women tend to build communion
structures now men who are used to
understanding what Authority is and
understanding what rules are women
typically believe that everybody in the
group is equal nah so by that alone you
can tell that when it comes to Children
men always know how to set boundaries
way better than women
so obviously men who always have way
better results in raising children than
women and and the reason and I would say
the reason that there are no fathers in
the home is because women kick them out
because I mean we just talk you agree
you know that men are are discriminated
against in the legal system right yes
okay okay you agree it's harder for them
to get custody but yes or no
is it is it harder for a man
that's harder because okay okay why
don't they fight for customers because
so have you okay do you know why do you
know why they like genuinely do you know
why they don't fight for custody well I
think a lot of them don't fight for
custody because they think that to the
get-go they're not going to have a
chance okay I think that's true yeah
yeah because the system is so stacked
against them right and a lot a lot of
them you know I know men on the brink of
suicide that have been fighting for two
three years that that their kids are a
mile from them and they don't see them
and so a lot of men think well I don't
want to go broke I I have no chance in
this anyway but that's not that's not
their fault right yeah I think okay and
that's a reasonable conclusion to come
to right okay okay so it's harder for
men to get custody yes or no
um yeah yes okay okay wait wait wait
wait wait wait can you wait all right
thank you
um so it's harder for guys to get
custody
um you know they have more to lose in
dwarfs right
they typically lose more in divorce than
women yes no yes okay yeah you can't
even do this conversation okay so I live
I'm sorry alimony is like less than 10
if you look at the long-term outcomes
and you even agreed with this earlier
women tend to have like a worse outcome
after divorce like no they can't tell
mothers choices okay okay okay what how
could we tell who has worse outcomes at
least when we look at like oh we're
gonna be like back to money but yeah it
is
um they tend to do worse monetarily they
tend to do like worse I can just like
well you do you do go back to money I
mean I I would I would disagree I would
go to two things you could look at okay
number one the children men want to be
with their kids men love their children
I know so many men that want to be with
their kids so many times we phrase it as
a chore that the women get the kids they
get their kids they get to see their
kids that is a good thing the second
thing I would look at is suicide rates
and you see an increase in in men
committing suicide after divorce often
times because they have no money they
don't have their kids oftentimes the
woman's disparaged their reputation and
and they just don't see a way out yeah I
think my biggest confusion is that
earlier I asked you like hey would you
be in favor of like parental leave and
the reason why I asked that question in
specific is because I agree hey custody
is awarded to the primary caregiver that
most of the time is women but if we
allowed in our society to create spaces
where men could take care of their
children and not be punished I don't see
that as a solution
because women will always ask for more
and more and more and this is just what
I see is like and then the same way like
you're from a two-parent loving home and
yet you still find a way to whine like
when did I whine about my family this is
I mean you're whining about the about
that it's not perfect in a two-parent
house
wait wait wait wait wait wait so so what
I get is just women just like to whine
and like to complain and and for
whatever reason that's what we do well
her solution to the problem wasn't even
to say the law should be changed when
men get 50 50 custody of the bat her
solution to the problem was that men
should do less work no my solution to
the problem is that men should be able
to spend more time with their children
and not be punished
so I think raising first of all I think
raising your children and spending time
with them is work but good work I think
it's a work that everybody should do
okay I don't provide yeah but that's
what I'm saying I'm saying that we live
in an era of immense wealth right we
live in an era where companies should be
hey you know what you're having children
you're contributing to this society and
you're a good worker you shouldn't get
punished you should live in an
idealistic world yeah well this isn't an
idealistic world there's a there's
countries in Europe right now yeah and
this is why we have this [__] I have the
reality
reality is the reality is women
um
I have a question do you think that we
have a higher standard of living than
ever before in the west
um yeah from 100 years ago yeah and yet
you're still whining well you see like
it's the same thing it's like now now we
need more right if I'm whining then like
we're in the same levels of whining I
guess because I'm literally arguing
right now that hey men should have more
access to their children you know but
okay I I would say that women should
stop leaving I think that would be a
better solution I think we should stop
paying women to leave I think that that
would be the ultimate we could agree on
that right you shouldn't be paid to
leave your husband well that's a thing
they're still getting they're still in a
financial assistance when they leave
their husbands okay but they still power
choose that they said why did they
choose that so how are okay if they're
at a financial disadvantage uh when they
can kick their husband out of the house
that he owns with one phone call
how many men that have been divorced
have you spoken to it's not about who
I've spoken no no no but this is but
this is the problem we get into is like
these these liberal people think they
know everything and they read some
studies and Google some stuff online but
the people that have actually spoken to
the people and are actually I've spoken
to 100 guys right I've said that all
right like that's not what I'm saying
this is the issue that we are coming
into earlier when you were like making
you were talking about Africa and the
guys from Africa are like no this is
what it's like and it's the same thing
it's like I I genuinely think we can
come to the best conclusions by what we
see in front of us what is in reality
and even just the reputations that
things have why do we have phrases like
it's cheaper to keeper if if men are are
doing so much better after divorce why
is that a phrase okay I think when you
say anecdotal evidence is enough to me
that's crazy because I could have a
completely different life anecdotal
experience in you and guess what at the
end of the day they would both be equal
because it's the anecdotal that's why
well again you can look at the anecdotal
evidence of of say you you know you
broaden your sample in that case so you
would look at the anecdotal evidence of
everyone in this room and see which
general narrative is more common than
the other and that's why we have studies
where we literally take the data of you
know like we could take the data from
the room to take the data from the
immediate vicinity because at least that
way you you have a bit more validity in
in the sample that you have right in
front of you because that's like say if
100 studies came out tomorrow that the
sky is green we can all read that right
by realistically we can look you can
look okay to me that's radically
different than like oh just getting the
sample data size from this room because
there's something called selection bias
and that's that that's a problem that
happens in general right we surround
ourselves with people who generally
think like us have similar life
experiences than us okay you know that's
okay
I think
from I'm from Puerto Rico I was born and
raised there okay okay where do you live
now um I live in Florida okay so I I
just think from my point of view like
how many guests have we logged here
no at this point well over 700 yeah well
over 700 gas Street interviews like we
aren't as different as people think like
that that's the biggest conclusion that
I've come to men and women just kind of
have General things that are true about
them and when it comes to like the legal
system I I think it's really silly if
you have any other conclusion other than
men have a harder time in it oh I think
um what I'm trying to say or what I've
said before is that I don't think it's
enough to just go by anecdotal
experience I think um so what's your
definitive statement like what I need
because you just kind of I think men
what is it I think do you think men in
general are good Fathers
um yeah okay do you think men should be
in the home yeah okay do you think it
should be 50 50 custody off the bat no
okay why because I think the whole idea
of like the primary caregiver is the
fact that like okay
um this man is still outside providing
they might not necessarily have like the
time or like resources is once a divorce
to be able to like take care of them so
it should be it should be what's best
for the kid right it should be best yeah
the primary care okay so it should be
what's best for the child then yeah okay
so then why don't we give custody to the
dads who who do better in every metric
raising children okay they're actually
they're also less likely to kill their
kids again the problem no no no no no
but I'm saying go off the data you love
data I do love the data I believe the
database here's two problems as I said
before one I don't know exactly what
study you're citing I'll look at it
later and you know I can like talk about
it later as well once I read it but then
second of all again a lot of these men
already have if they're gonna fight in
the court system a financial advantage
which gives them like the opportunity to
raise their children better I think
maybe it's possible that it could be
because of discipline but again you
would literally have to go how do they
have a financial advantage when before
they can get before they even get to the
court date so kovid pushed a lot of
these trials out like a year two years
before the men could even get to court
to fight for their kids and they're and
I'll tell you what happens a lot of
times they're paying for a mortgage that
they've been kicked out of a lot of
these guys are living out of their cars
and and no wait wait see you listen to
respond you don't listen to listen from
people that know more than you I'm doing
a documentary in this you see there's a
lawyer right next to you you listen to
respond no and so on top of that on top
of that she can put them on child
support and and she could do that for
two years before he even gets to court
so how is he at a financial advantage
when the system has been draining him
women are a net tax loss you're not men
pay more than they men pay more than
women in taxes
you just described one of my friends
actually they've got the kennel move
that's where Luna is so he's been um his
daughter is she must be coming up to
five now
um he was engaged to his misses
um they had a child they they bought he
bought a house he did he was doing
everything and I'll be honest with you
I'll be real she was she was dead
tonight I don't even know why he did all
this but I did I don't know why no but
for a man
she's a dead thing I
but you know what happened you know what
happened I'll tell you what happened she
caught him at a point in his life when
he felt low and when a woman catches you
a point in fact when you feel low and
she's around you it can sleep in so for
some reason he moved off the end he went
about and and she was some fat thing as
well like it just wasn't like so he got
engaged to it so he had a baby with it
move move to Kent
living the life forever then she had the
baby and then she started getting
um
uh postnatal depression right then he
discovered that she was taking pills and
basically she was a complete different
woman that we fought so now he's trying
to like speak to her trying to help her
and she just snapping out on him hitting
him dude so he's like bro I can't deal
with this no more in it so he wants to
leave you know what she does
she calls this is during covert times as
well she calls the police yeah please
come black man white woman in Kent yeah
yeah I already know yeah okay okay the
reason why I say it like that because I
want I'm trying to set up the scene for
you yeah so you see it right police have
come my friend is a data analyst on top
of that he works for the police could
you imagine that yeah he was working for
the police as a contractor the same
place that he works for and came to
arrest him they arrested him initially
took him straight away from that moment
which was
now about three years ago he hasn't seen
his daughter yet he hasn't had one
access to his daughter due to covid-19
and other stuff you know he had to buy
the woman at the home he had to
literally buy the woman at home but he's
at a financial advantage
can I just tell you this because I don't
just tell you this story just just so
you talk about an adult but it all we
can you talk about stats and adorable
well I want to give him fluid that my
friend that's going through this I don't
like I'm not going to say his name but
he's going through this right now so now
he has a he has a black daughter that
has been raised in a white home that has
not seen her black father she has no
idea who this man is so by the time he
actually gets through courts and he has
an opportunity to see this girl it's
already messed up so what is he doing
now he's he's making money for the
daughter when he grows up he's writing
letters he's doing all because at this
point he has to just go to her when
she's older and say listen this is what
your mom did to me and this is what I've
created and like the reason why I'm
saying it is because it's hurting him
and I'm watching him go through it but
at the same time I'm telling you bro why
did you breed up this girl you should
have like you know what I'm saying no no
but I'm being real because she's a dead
thing and now a dead thing is put in for
you all of this but when women say that
men men want to see their kids another
one of my guys spent 50 Grand trying to
see his daughter 50 Grand and when I say
to him why didn't your message just take
the money he was like no she's going to
put me through hell bro I could have
given her the money but she didn't want
the money she just want to put me
through her head and in the end of the
50 Grand you know he said to me it was
worth every penny because now I don't
have to deal with this woman there's
something set in stone that me and my
daughter don't have to do this so
sometimes when I hear these stories I
think about all the men that I really
want to be providers and I will speak to
myself it seems to be the men that
provide the men that got jobs the men
are doing something for themselves their
women always put them through stress but
they're meant to have multiple baby
mamas who don't actually do anything
they're the ones that their mom don't
yeah he just comes and just picks up the
kid and just takes them out so yeah
that's that's all I'm saying I just
think for a lot of men out there you
have to be careful of who you who you
choose to to lie down with and women
like women aren't making it easier for
men and the suicide rates are high in
the stress and to the point where he has
to put to the back of his mind now and
say listen like if I don't see her again
I don't see her but when I do UCLA 18
she's gonna have this yeah wait wait I
say something okay you can speak to so
many men out there and almost every man
knows a man that's going through some
[__]
accident it means that you haven't
spoken to as many people as you should
be speaking to I want to acknowledge
everything you guys said and I want to
because I feel like I was like trying to
tell you guys something and you guys
weren't listening and but now think
about everything you just said how much
Financial stress the person had to go
through how much money just to see their
children right so that's why I'm saying
you would agree with that that that men
have a harder time financially yes but I
mean in divorce right right after
divorce you would agree wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait I'll let
you finish but I'm asking really quick
the long-term outcomes no but the short
term the court battles sure okay
wait but can you guys let me finish some
outcomes has nothing to do with the
divorce was saying man then lose in
divorce what then happens after is due
to the woman's choices it's not because
she lost in divorce it's because she
doesn't know how to manage her finances
it's because she doesn't know how to
make new money okay that is why it's
because men can still even though not
all the time but a man can still go
through all that [__] and still struggle
and go and build his life back women
don't have that same Drive okay that is
why going focusing on what I was trying
to say before right where it's like okay
they went through all that Financial
stress so the men who are able to
succeed at getting custody right have to
have like a [__] ton of money right
we're saying like they're going on can I
just say something so as a lawyer I
understand how this works now when
you're saying when he has all this money
he can get custody that is not
necessarily the case because at the end
of the day no I know I know about this
and we see this it doesn't matter how
much money he has because the family
courts are against men they say that
they are for the the best interests of
the children are Paramount but they have
decided and it's written in law that the
children should be with the mother so it
doesn't matter how much money you have
half the time it's not even about that
so if it has money would you get really
wealthy guys then who are still trying
to go through this process and they're
still yeah I get messages from them 100.
it's not about how much money can't you
guys see oh yeah but you know has a lot
of money but he doesn't have customers
it's not about money no okay but you
guys don't understand or I maybe I'm not
communicating clearly like you okay
you're literally saying like hey it's
not about the money there's people who
even have a lot of money who fail yeah
but the point is for the people who
succeed which we agree is a slim amount
right they already have to have like an
abundance of resources to fight for so
long to win so obviously those people or
they just got a crackhead mom pregnant
yeah
but the point is if these men are going
above and I mean I'm serious a lot of
the reasons they get custody is because
of crackhead mothers okay but the point
is if you're gonna say like oh like you
know like these single men or you know
single parent households are doing
better than the single women households
it's because the men who are single
parent households
you just you go on for okay you don't
really get to the pool okay go ahead the
point is that these single parent
households to begin with are already
giving a bunch of money or going above
and beyond in their children's lives so
you're self-selecting for like the best
dads to begin with when it comes to the
statistics how do you how do you know
that because we literally just went over
how difficult it is no but I gave you
another alternative I said or he got a
crackhead mom pregnant well you guys are
even agreeing I'm saying you're arguing
so strongly for something you don't seem
to have a lot of experience in and I
wonder like why you're arguing so strong
okay so question how do we become how do
we know who's a better parent who raises
kids better by themselves well that's
what I'm saying no so how do we how do
we come to that conclusion well
according to you guys you guys were
citing a study okay well I personally I
would say anecdotally but you like
studies you like studies right so I'm
asking you yeah I would look at studies
okay okay so if the data is saying one
thing that's that fathers have far
better outcomes single fathers have far
better outcomes than single mothers okay
that that criminals come from single
mother homes that people with mental
disorders tend to come from single
mother homes kids that drop out of
school come from single mother homes all
of the big problems in society okay the
homeless tend to come from single mother
homes why is it that you only believe
studies that suit you what do you mean
I'm not saying no because because when
it comes to a conclusion you don't like
and so I say hey let's believe the
studies that single father others are
better than single mothers when it comes
to raising kids in every metric and when
we look at the outcomes of the people in
prison they're from single mother homes
when we when we look at the outcomes
even like the homeless shelter down the
street I've been there I've talked I've
talked to the guy asked him what what is
the main reason for this he's like multi
single mothers with multiple baby
fathers that's that's what he tells me
okay so anecdotally and studies they're
both telling me the same thing you only
believe the studies that benefit you no
I'm literally explaining like why the
results
I know but this is what what you this is
what the liberals do is they'll they'll
say well it's because this and then
still find a way to defend the women
right and then find a way to like make
it okay how did I well because you said
oh it's because they have money well
that's that's why you guys what women
should then get 50 custody because
surely the solution to hearing all of
that data would be okay well the
conclusion to that should be that the
the law should be changed yeah and you
still said that women should be the
primary kick no I'm saying about what
should change is that men should have
the opportunity to caregiver for their
child so that's another bonus change
yeah the law should change in favor of
giving men like hey they should be able
to take time off work get paternal leave
be able to spend time with their
children that's not custody yeah that's
a different law that's basically labor
right so but we're we're specifically
talking about a set of data that affects
custody law yeah and I'm saying that if
that Labor Law changes then it'll be
easier for men to argue that they're
also a primary care this is the point
that Paul's making liberals tend to have
this habit of going outside of the area
that we're referring to to try and fix
the problem instead of saying huh maybe
if I look at the information in front of
me and find a way to to create a
solution a conclusion with this set of
information in front of me that will
obviously cause a direct solution
because it's come from the data
available in front of you what you're
doing is you're looking at the
information here and going well
um nah we'll just we'll try something
from over here and see if it works well
because like oh no men should
automatically have 50 custody when
they're not actually taking care of
their child fifty percent of the time
you're speculating no I'm not
speculating the whole idea of the giving
custody to the primary caregiver if a
man if it was 50 let's just say a
hypothetical scenario I mean you're
speculating we want to talk in Fairyland
let's go there so let's say that men and
women get custody 50 of the time right
a man gets custody what do you think
he's gonna do well I think no I think
what is going to end up happening is
that if we don't have the proper labor
laws to give them that space yeah their
children are going to end up getting
neglected because the guy is still out
there working I'm not saying oh how is
any different on the mom's side what do
you mean yeah you said that mum still
have to work anyway you said Mom still
have to do labor in the house and out of
the house what's the difference well the
difference is that like according to the
data we have moms do do both of them men
have a harder time acclimating to that
because we don't raise them to be you
know proper caregivers if that was the
case how is it that children from single
father homes do better than children
from single motherhood thank you as I
said there's already a selection bias if
women are such great caregivers why are
they the most likely one to kill their
own child yeah I mean like literally 90
if it's a parent that kills the kid 90
of the time it's the mother and let's
let's take a look wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait so so let's and
see do you see you did it again who's
more like who's a better parent who's
more likely to to kill the kid that's a
bad thing right we'd agree that's bad we
want the kids alive well okay let's look
at the moms and look at the dads okay
it's the moms not good well there has to
be a reason and then she makes up some
reason well yeah I'm sorry is it not
true that women are more likely to have
the child so that's not a reason to kill
your child
no no seriously seriously seriously
seriously the mental gymnastics you do
around simple no seriously no seriously
seriously seriously you did this about
Africa now you're doing I can't believe
you were actually supporting women
killing their children just because
you see it's not what you said yeah
don't twist it she didn't say that no
relax okay she made the argument that
the reason why women are more like
because they have it more because they
have to eat more so is that just because
you have the kids also doesn't that then
support that men and women should have
50 custody because if your whole point
is that more well we we just acknowledge
that women kill children more than men
right okay because they were saying
that's because they have them more so
surely that's the reason why they should
have them less and the law should be
changed so that men have just as much
custody as women I'm saying if it's 50
50 you're probably going to see similar
rates of men killing your children so
let's see so let's make it I mean
what I'm arguing for is literally to
give men the ability to be able to
primary caregiver for their child
without getting punished I get what
you're advocating for I'm just saying I
don't think that's the way to solve a
problem is to take outside issues and
make that solution to a problem that's
in front I think when we see it when
she's arguing because the reality is
when women are the primary caregivers in
divorce and they are giving custody what
you're saying doesn't make sense by
saying that the men when they have the
case they won't be able to make time for
their kids because the woman still now
on her own has to provide for the kids
so she's still going to neglect the kids
well the problem that point is mute it
doesn't make it's not meal it is we live
in a society where we train women from a
young age to do both no we don't no we
don't more than women
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait but you you just agreed earlier
that women are messy and don't know how
to cook
um so you know how to cook and clean
more than men do what
now I'm not having that I'm not
having fun how dare you how dare you you
goes up no no seriously seriously
[Music]
what is it I think I think one of the
things is this right back to what we're
saying if we're obviously rather than
making it like like it just anecdotal
like if we're going by the reviews so to
speak there's a certain element of you
just accepting that currently this is
what the review is indicating it's not
about even necessarily that you arguing
against the review or giving a reason
why the reviews might you know be
projecting the you know these stats it's
just about okay right is that what the
review says okay fair enough and
obviously let's all look at the review
and educate ourselves because the risk
is like making this generalized
statements in defense of obviously the
point you're trying to make it doesn't
make you make the point easier you get
it yeah I'm just trying to like put a
context for what these statements might
mean because if we take a statement
without like any context whatsoever you
can come up with a million different but
these are reviews these are reviews
conducted these are reviews
is purely speculation when you said that
if we give 50 50 custody we will see an
increase in men yeah I said possibly
right
um and that's why I'm trying to advocate
for things that I don't know
historically have worked I know that
countries in like Finland Sweden um
Denmark they have instituted policies
where men have parental leave where
they're able to take care of their
children and that leads to a higher
quality life for all so that's why I'm
advocating for what I'm advocating but
you don't mean it you don't mean in a
custodial sense though and that's what
that's what I'm struggling okay if you
really believe what you're saying that's
what your advocating for why do you have
a counter argument against men having
custody of the kids oh no I think what
is it I think nobody should have
automatic custody so I don't think the
woman has a higher divorce rate than
here thank you okay well they let me go
back but am I understand you have a
higher quality of life I'm not sure by
what you mean by here do you mean the us
or UK or wolf are you sure yes 60
seconds 45 U.S okay regardless right we
know that people I don't think it is
you can't do that have a higher quality
of life no but the thing is yeah are you
telling okay does Finland have a higher
quality of life than the United States
and then UK I've never been I don't I
don't speak out right now but this is
this is the difference between me and
you I'm not gonna search about the
quality of life in Finland of a place
I've never been to but see you you go
this is what the nerds do they go on
their phone and they think they know
something about a country but you've
never you're not going to know until
you've been there okay and I'll tell you
I'll tell you this I'll tell you this I
grew up with nannies from around the
world okay so I grew up with a nanny
from Russia a nanny from South Africa uh
my dad hired people from India so I grew
up like super from people around the
world and they would always come to
America and they would say you Americans
think you know everything because you
see us in the media you you see it like
you Google stuff and you think you know
what it's like to be from there and my
point is you can't really know until you
talk to the people that are from the
place and actually go so do you want to
take a trip with me to Finland
I think I think that would be very
tiring for me it's cold if you want to
take a trip um I don't know I I schedule
a trip to Finland I I honestly and I'll
schedule a separate one and then we can
come back with our anecdotal evidence no
you should really schedule a trip to
Nigeria that's where you should go yeah
sure no I mean yeah you should literally
go to Nigeria or literally go to Nigeria
and go to somebody's place and boil some
water and to and you know and go to the
springs go to camera listen because
because only by doing that will you get
a level of Education it's going to open
you up more it's gonna you know I'm
trying to say to you it's not you don't
want to do nothing to hurt you but
literally if you really believe in what
you believe even come to Africa because
I promise you this if you come to Africa
yeah you might even want to come back
here that's the truth of the matter with
some of the richest Secrets some of the
richest people in London are from
Nigeria right aren't they there you go
but but why are we why are we getting
lost in the weeds in this whole argument
I mean isn't it clear that what happens
when couple splits up or what happens
after divorce needs serious review I
mean isn't that the bottom line because
like you know I I'm listening to all
this stuff you guys are saying I've also
got another anecdotal evidence but very
good friend of mine is currently going
through something very very similar to
this you know he's got arrested he's you
know having no access to his kid there's
all this [__] going on you know there's
he's taking away stuff like that and
it's like that I mean it does seem that
there's enough of these anecdotal
examples out there to say at the very
least surely the whole system needs to
at least be examined yeah you know and
then what comes from that well I guess
we'll see right but it does seem like I
think you said it actually like default
custody for the woman should should no
longer be the case I think absolutely
you know
um we're going to the ways about this
stuff I think we'll get you real for the
point a little bit somehow yeah I just I
guess my main point I was trying to make
is that I don't think it should
automatically go to the woman I should I
think it should go to the primary
caregiver I think men should have the
ability and opportunity to be able to do
that without getting punished I actually
have a question I'm gonna I'm gonna use
a dog in this example okay so me and you
we're besties we get a dog right now if
I pay for the dog doesn't it make sense
that I have authority I get to keep the
dog if I pay for everything even if you
watch the dog while I'm at work well
like what you said before money isn't
everything right no I'm not masking so
well yeah so do you think do you think
you should take the dog and I should pay
you to take the dog no I know I know I
know babies are different but I'm just I
I I'm using a different yeah just to you
know prove a point but go ahead yeah the
problem is like to make that analogy
closer to our current reality you have
like me who's working also paying part
for the dog and then also taking care of
the dog while another person is just
working right so that's when it is
complicated why do you think women work
um I think women work because our
current economic situation does not make
it possible for a lot of women to be
single okay so okay okay I have a
question how much money do you think you
need to raise a child
oh it depends where you live okay so
what like how much
um I what would go into raising a child
but if you want to raise a good child I
would say um you need to be able to
provide basic necessities good education
okay how much does it cost
I don't know I don't I'm not sure and
this is what yeah Cal root supers in a
second but but this is where like it's
going back to it's like we argue so much
that the women are working because they
have to when most people haven't really
done research most people don't have
kids they've never done any research on
what it takes to raise a kid and from my
experience
um from like the stay-at-home moms that
I know this is just what they tell me is
that it doesn't take near as much money
as people think you just can't go on any
trips you have to pass down clothes you
have to make food from scratch you have
to live very frugally and most people
don't want to do that for the sake of
the kids now
um I I did a show where I like broke
down a budget because I was really
curious about this because I kept
hearing
um and the truth of the matter is poor
people have more kids so I I do think
they're kind of it's really just
propaganda to make you not want to have
children
um and I I would also say I I think
women don't want to go down down in
lifestyle for children I think we have a
selfish generation of women that wants
makeup they want Botox they want fake
hair fake nails fake eyelashes and all
that stuff Trips Trips yeah trips five
times a year and I don't think most
women nowadays were raised to live in a
small apartment or a small house not
really go anywhere just stay at home
with the kids I don't think most women
want to put in the work to homeschool
children which is an option and that
does eliminate a lot of the costs that
you're talking about and I've talked to
women that actually have done this
and I think it's a lot more possible the
numbers that I've gotten from women that
do this
um and I'm I'm not claiming to be an
expert on budgeting for kids but this is
just from talking to the people that do
it she said around 45 55 000 what you
can do is you can get an apartment
um outside of the city or a small like
townhouse or something and then your
husband commutes and he's gone a lot and
it sucks but you're home you're raising
the kids yeah I think most women don't
just want to raise a bunch of children I
think okay okay but they're they're no
no no no no no no no no no sorry you're
here you're here my show
um so you said just want to raise a
bunch of children just and like I just
want to point that out because it shows
the mentality of modern women when it
comes to children they don't want to
just raise children they want to raise
good children they want to raise
children who are going to have a good
quality of life and they want to raise
children that don't have to worry about
living correct so children that ride
around in their mum's Range Rover and
piss off to Bali twice a year they
they're better children than the kids
like me who grew up on Butlins and you
know Mom and Dad were you know screaming
at each other some weekends but other
weekends they were getting along and you
know we had a roast on Sunday we
couldn't afford to go out to bloody The
Shard every other weekend like did you
have your mom and dad at home I had my
mom and dad at home my mum was at home
full time because she didn't have to go
to work because she didn't get her hair
and nails done every other week and my
dad only only see this is the generation
we live in
um my dad is on 40K a year he's a tram
driver himself what do you mean that's
good on top of that I could tell that
you had both of your parents I just just
when you said it I was just like yeah
but you can always I mean you can tell
the people and my dad on 40K a year
which is that's not let's not ignore the
fact in this country like that is on the
upper scale like yeah no no that's good
and I'm not I'm not ignorant to the fact
that I have lived a very blessed and
sheltered life however if we're going to
talk about you know quality of life yeah
I would agree most women have this this
idea that they they want to be able to
to have all these things and then they
go to work but like the truth is from my
personal experience my dad has always
been in you know normal we're working
class family he owns 40K a year he looks
after me and my mum like I'm I'm not a
bad kid just because I don't have
parents who both work high-end jobs in
the city and and we we have a household
income of 200k a year and you know a lot
of people make the argument oh well if
you have more money you can create
better memories for your child but
kids don't care if we are sat on a ride
in Butlins or if we're at the top of a
skyscraper in Dubai we don't know the
difference so the argument that you know
to raise better children it comes down
to to quality of life through money I
just think I call [__] but how do
you even equate the fact that because
for you to have that quality of life
obviously both the parents have to work
both parents have to be out of the house
most of the time so but you you look at
that as better quality of life when the
kids have less time with either of the
parents than when they have more time
with their mom at home but they might
have less money yeah a lot of the
friends that I have where where both of
their parents are working had um you
know things like child minders and that
and they don't spend as much time with
their parents and and you know what like
I'm so close with my parents and and we
literally you know tell each other
everything and like that we can only do
that because we have the time to spend
with each other and it goes back to the
point I was saying earlier you know the
more money you have more problems you
have and you know parents who are
earning much more money like sure they
might be able to buy their kids more
presents and take them on more holidays
but
they can't sit and have a chat with the
kids really because they've got more
problems on them so Christine so for me
yeah like like my dad because he was
Diplomat he spent his whole life flying
across the world I didn't like it's only
now to be honest with you to be
physically flying back to Cameron in the
morning because he's always spent his
life half year and half over there he
just comes he doesn't he just comes
because of us to be honest with you who
prefers time over there and it's like
the sacrifice that him and mother had to
go and do is not a sacrifice that to be
it's a sacrifice that many first
generation African people did this they
came over and they you know whether or
not one person was here while the other
person was there and they did sacrifice
just so that the kids could have a start
and you know what I'm trying to say to
you
and that's something I wouldn't do
personally I wouldn't want to be away
from my for my wife and obviously for my
kids but these sacrifices that people do
it's for the greater good that it
becomes bigger than that there's a big
difference between people making that
kind of sacrifice for the sake of their
children having a better life and people
who grew up like me and and had pretty
much everything to still then say like I
need 200k a year and we should both work
to give my kids a good quality of life
my dad made good money but when I grew
up it was never about money see if I
think about money that's because of my
outside influences my dad was never was
about educationals about doing certain
things if I think about money and
getting money and jewelry and stuff that
is not what I was raised upon yeah this
is why I say the memories because even
back in my country all the rich people's
kids I knew that had good Fathers yes
they were rich but they didn't grow up
rich their parents made sure they kept
their money away from them
they were raised like regular kids they
had to play on the streets they had to
even pass down clothes even though their
parents were Rich King it's only sorry
but it's only now I understand what my
dad did if he said to me was my dad the
million I'll tell you no but come to
Africans he spent millions of pounds in
Africa of his money right building roads
building schools building Villages doing
so many things like
um houses left right and Center I have
houses all over Cameroon because of what
my dad did right and it takes a very
unselfish man to go and do this my dad
has done so much thing for so many
people and it's like
when we speak about money and money and
money even me myself even me myself when
I look at some of the things that I like
and what I'm attracted to this is not
what I was raised upon no and when I
when I take it away that's not who I am
um and sometimes I have to remind myself
like try like why do you want these
things do you really want because my dad
doesn't want these things it's not what
he cares about like if I buy him
something he doesn't he wants you know
what he'll tell me buy him a book that's
what you tell me who you say I want some
books I want some stuff get me some
stuff back for back home for the kids
that's what he'll say to me and it's
just sometimes when I think where I get
this consumerism and this it wasn't for
my father I was raised majority by my
mother but I think I think back in the
day I say back in the day like maybe 80s
70s maybe early 90s you know there was
much more of a sense of just getting on
with it you know what I mean just
pulling yourself up by the bootstraps
you know we can have a windy day at the
brainy beach in Britain yeah yeah the
eggs the egg sandwiches with the sand in
it
yeah yeah well that's what you know
that's what it was like when I was
growing up you know we go to the we go
camping in Cornwall we go to the beach
and you know all that [__] and that was
great but our people and let's face it
women you know all women is Keen to to
take that on now you know I mean I've
certainly I've certainly dated women in
the past and they've been like you know
when you talk about you know children
and stuff like that they'd be like oh
yeah but I'd have to get I'd have to get
Annie's to look after them do you know
what I mean and they're kind of saying
it half jokingly but what they mean is
they want to maintain that lifestyle now
you know they can party they could go
out they can have a good time they can
wear nice clothes and then oh yeah I
want the kids but you know so there's
nothing wrong with admitting that you
want that but the problem that I see
time and time again with women of our
generation is that they try and justify
it morally they try and justify wanting
all the things like this is the problem
I I encounter with liberals all the time
it's like you know no one is necessarily
shaming you for for wanting this you
know I call it the Range Rover lifestyle
like if you want that just admit that
you're more selfish and you do want that
but don't try and make the argument that
it's like for a better quality for the
kids and better memories I think that's
yeah bollocks it's just bollocks
and even think of the number one
expenses rent so if you're divorcing
you're paying two rents
keep it to keep up you know
I'm gonna add to that as well you see to
support what you're saying a little bit
right so I was a young parent so I too
believed okay yeah you know because I
came from poverty he's like oh yeah now
make sure the Christmas trees are all
these presents and make sure this make
sure that I did that for my do you think
my kids remember that they don't
remember that my son remembers when I
fixed his bike with him or when I done
some some random stuff of him and I I it
took me to get one I think hold on a
minute they don't remember no prep tree
for the present you know holidays to
Dubai it don't resonate to him he just
remembers I when I spent time with my
dad like one time yeah that all he
remembers when they pick me up from
school when that told me whatever he
doesn't remember none of that stuff and
I wish I somebody told me that earlier
because I would have put all that money
in savings instead for his future but I
was pressured by the prescription of
society now to be a dad I respect you
need to give your kids all of this other
stuff and I did all of that you know he
was doing the big presents like
Christmas a picture
that's the whole point is like like kids
just want you there yeah that's it and
like that's why I say I think it's
selfish when women get divorced because
all a kid wants is both of their parents
that's all that's all you could talk
about Fringe cases of abuse sure it
happens but in general most men are good
Fathers most men want to be in the kids
lives most men love their kids more than
anything and to like minimize that by
saying they don't do enough housework
really well it's like it I just think is
a bit disingenuous and it doesn't show
how important dads are well that's why I
keep going back to this topic of like
parental leave because you guys are
right you know what kids want is to
spend time with their mother and father
and if the father has to always you know
be the provider gets punished for
providing either you know by the courts
or by not being able to spend as much
time with the kids I think that's unfair
so that's why I keep going back so I
disagree with you because I just don't
see that as a solution because I don't
think women will the dad will get
parental leave and the women will be yes
I'm so happy and I will not divorce my
husband like guys just asking for the
men when you give women what they want
do they typically reward you
and well they realize they don't want it
and so this is this is the real problem
is women being selfish and leaving
that's the real problem because at the
end of the day you could say oh parental
leave this the biggest drawback and
setback a kid can have in life is not
having their dad around
that is there's a reason we have phrases
like Daddy Issues moms don't do it the
same way we can't especially young boys
because men just don't respect women
like they do other men they don't want
to listen to women I don't even think
women should teach other men to be
honest like like in a teacher role I
just don't think it works because men
like there's an underlying like threat
of violence with men and it just I I
just think men are more structured men
are more disciplined you know men are
the one that are going to fix your car
they're gonna screw in a light bulb and
women think they're God's gift to the
Earth because they can load up a
dishwasher it's like
it's like the stuff that guys do I think
is a lot more complicated
I don't know I think we got roombas we
got dishwashers well like we have vacuum
cleaners now like like men build all
this stuff to make our lives easier and
we still complain I think um what is it
again it goes back to how our society is
currently manufactured because you can
say like oh you know women are choosing
to um work and do the household tours
but again why are women choosing to work
it's okay because of selfish reasons a
lot of it goes back I have a question
the reason why Society is the weight is
is because women choose to walk it's not
Society it's not the other way it's not
the way you said it it's actually
because women choose to work that
Society became the way it is now why did
women choose to work because they were
tired of sitting at home okay why were
they tired of sitting at home I mean go
and ask them
no also the the majority of women who
push the whole you know women want to
get into Workforce weren't the women who
were
you know happy at home the idea is
always like oh well women were
Housewives at home and they were getting
beaten by their husbands so they wanted
to go out and work so they could fight
for themselves all of this actually like
the feminists uh didn't have husbands
didn't have children they were just bit
us single women who couldn't it's a man
so they're like all right let's just go
out and make their own money because no
man wants to Steve women the majority of
women did not want to work they actually
didn't like you're saying I think it was
a minority of women who were pushing
this agenda I think it was I reacted to
a video recently and it was in like the
70s I think and they were asking the
majority of women
um on the street like uh so what do you
think of the women's Liberation movement
and they're all like yeah I think the
women who are doing it are a bit nuts
but you know each to their own because
women were like that we were we were
always tend to go you know each to their
own and even one of the women actually
said I think it's all gotten a bit too
extreme and she was saying it's it's
women punishing other women because they
were saying look we we don't want to
work majority of women didn't want what
happened but because when you have and
we're seeing it now when you have a
small minority that has a very loud
voice things can get very messy and I
hope everyone is aware of the minority
that I'm referring to but we are seeing
it now we're a minority of people with
very loud voices scream these things
loudly and it changes history suddenly
things you know that they say has
happened is what happened but you know
why that is that's because the minority
right the majority allow them I know to
do it because of all Mana reasons
because they don't want to be canceled
they don't want to speak out yeah they
don't want to be politically incorrect
what happens is is is you become
complicit in your silence because you're
allow it to happen and don't buy
Omission yeah and it's like you know
women see women need to take back their
spaces and take control it's not for me
as a man to do this and I know what
you're talking about and women need to
take back this space and take control
and the only reason we've gotten this
far is because so women speak about the
patriarchy but it's the same patriarchy
that's allowed this thing to happen you
realize that right yeah it's so and it's
gonna own this can only happen because
men are in control fully sorry
um wait what did you say your dad did
for a living he's a charm driver I have
a question and he made 40 000. he makes
makes 40. what did he start at do you
know and so he started as an apprentice
in uh Phillips when he was 17.
um he worked there for about 20 years
until Margaret Thatcher shut down all
the factories and then he lost his job
but we won't get into that um and then
he went straight into being a charm
driver for another 20 years and he is
now 67 he should have retired a couple
of years ago but guess what a man's
still working because he wants to make
sure that me and my mum are okay
um what so what did he what did he start
at roughly do you know oh so back then
oh
I mean when my dad was 17 we're talking
maybe the 60s early 70s
yesterday I guess today an apprentice
Maybe
between I would say 19 and 22k a year
okay do you think most women would stay
at home go on zero trips and and submit
to the authority of a man for 19 to 22k
a year no no I don't think okay you have
to provide
um you guys literally just admitted that
40K was like the what is it the number
you guys know that's what she said she
she that's what she said that she makes
that he makes today yeah but but yeah so
what happened what happens what happens
is people men make more money over time
so women would know okay in our early
years he's not going to make a ton of
money but he's going to make more so the
average guy Peaks at his income peaks in
his 50s so his income Peaks at 55.
so so but the the thing is and they
might know that okay I might have to
work in our early 20s but we can save
some money and then have kids yeah it
seems to me that the old thing of like
oh we'll strive together we'll grow
together and you know we'll go through
the hard times
[Music]
now it seems like it's gone you know
like I just can't see that flying
anymore really you know why do you think
what's the movement why do you think
that is well because I don't know
because because people well women's
expectations people's expectations have
been risen so high because of Instagram
and because of advertising culture and
pop cult you know pop culture in general
movies TV whatever you know I just don't
think the average woman is going to
accept the kind of lifestyle that you
would get on 20K to be honest you know
and it's like they have to pay for
themselves somehow
you know what I mean so it's like
they'll say oh we can't afford this but
I'm like you how do you how do you eat
now but there's also availability of the
day marketplaces well I don't believe
it's all about money I don't I genuinely
don't believe that the dating thing I
think rizz is extremely important I
don't think it's all about money how
having said that of course if the girl
is she's dating this bloke he's on 20
grand a year and she's like looking
around and she's getting some DMS on
Instagram and this upload with the
Ferraris like sliding into a DMS is she
gonna be potentially swayed by that if
he's decent looking probably do you know
what I mean it's like it's not I also
think like everybody does way too much
now so it's like so you so you meet a
girl get a number also get Instagram
social media go look on social media
you're gonna see she's in Mobile you're
gonna see she's going to Dubai you're
gonna see she's gone to Cancun you're
gonna go see that you should actually
been everywhere and a lot of times she's
done this done these in relationships so
for like Paris so basically she's been
getting her back blown out in tropical
destinations no that's the truth for the
matter she has she's been going on when
a girl goes on holiday with a partner
they go in and having a lot of sex lots
of sex crazy sex you know drunken sex
drug-fueled sex
on the beach on the sand clapping cheeks
listen you know what I'm saying this is
because as a man when we look at that we
know already what that means who's
taking that picture oh oh oh oh you went
oh you went with a Time understand no
you didn't let's not do that so A lot of
times when a man starts dating a woman
the expectation is so high because
they've done they've done everything
already and I think this is important
because it just keeps relating what we
say to men guys if you're not on your
purpose don't be dating it's only gonna
exacerbate the problems that you
currently have right I suggest for the
younger men real life I suggest for the
younger men go out there get on your
purpose put your head down I know it
feels like you know you know that
everything's happening right now but
trust me it's all about compounding it's
not happening right now it's it's gonna
happen later on in life and then we tell
younger men right and then the same
woman as we talk about before that are
ignoring you when in their teens and
their early 20s because they want the
older guys with the big cars and all
that they want to do all these things
now these are the women are going to
line up because they're gonna end up
becoming baby mamas in their 30s and
gonna be outside and they're gonna be
the ones that want to see you but guess
what at that point you don't have to see
them there's already a fresh batch of
and you can pick the women in their 20s
and they're going to be online saying oh
these older men only want these younger
girls because they want to manipulate no
they're just trying to make it fair it's
never ever been Fair because and this is
and this is the thing about about some
you know some things played to women
double standards something things play
to men in the prime of your life we call
it 18 to 28 when you know this is when
you get your proposal this is when the
world bends for you if you choose not to
secure a man and get out of there that's
your own fault that's your own fault
yeah I agree I think I think the
experiences things happen absolutely
right though because I remember Tristan
Tristan Tate was talking about this and
talk about money and he said um it's not
necessarily it's not the money necessary
per se that women won it's not like
every woman is this hard and gold digger
but it's a bit like look we've I've got
this amazing car I could take we could
drive across Italy we'll get on a yacht
blah blah blah it's just that experience
is more fun like is she gonna rather
have that or go down to Greg's and have
a coffee in a [__] you know steak
bait right you know
so it's kind of we've we've had the
expectations Race So High because of
Instagram and what our mates are doing
and what people on reality TV is doing
and all that sort of stuff so um I'm
gonna Read Super chats for a second so
sorry sorry to the chat I know I know
you guys have been bothering me about
these for a while okay um but thank you
for the super chats the super chats are
gonna guys you wanna know what king
looks like right you wanna you wanna see
what can't you want to get King a camera
right right he's good looking guy right
everyone yeah yeah don't they yeah
everyone you donate to get King a camera
okay Desmond parties pixie I don't agree
with a lot of your opinions but I enjoy
the way you express your opinions on
these podcasts 90 Frito pie can you ask
arguing women if she ever sat down and
had a talk with her dad about his life
if so what did she learn his struggles
his dreams Etc Robert um women farmed
these factories made farming obsolete
wait women farmed then factories made
farming obsolete to earn a living
um Daniel int good job pixie keep
joining um don't give up
um black up so when men take time off to
care for their kids will women take on
50 percent of the finances Moon pilled
rash we know the answer is no like why
are you asking stupid questions sorry
um okay uh moonpaled rational Optics
this is why Rolo deals and what is not
what should thanks Pearl and Troy Eric
misses something thank you for the Super
Chat 93 topi Finland Sweden ha mostly
white people right interesting point
liberal why don't you say Africa Chris
to the delusional girl in the middle
have you ever seen girls argue stupid
points and go viral on the show congrats
this is you today 90 free tip my earlier
Super Chat is for tiered eyed liberal
also my friends uh baby mama accused him
of essay but stopped when the court
asked for proof still has to pay child
support I I've had guys you don't even
understand I used to think women were
just I think were just completely
different and then I started reading
court documents I'm going to tell you
what happened I started reading court
documents and I and I saw this happen so
many times where the woman tries to
falsely accuse a man
um I had one guy that asked actually
there was printed out texts of the girl
saying talking to her friend because
they they got it in the affidavit she
was texting her friend and her friend
says you have to get him to hit you oh
yup so she was trying to get and guess
who got primary custody the primary
caregiver what do you know even when
they're batshit crazy they don't care
and honestly stuff like this is why I
can never advocate for marriage even
though I believe in marriage I believe
in two parent households I I think it's
like you know you hear story after story
after story after Story these same
stories from people that don't know each
other this is why the trackpads are so
[__] yeah people from different
countries that have the same story
people from different parts of the world
that have the same story and it's like
how many stories to have to come forward
of men getting absolutely ruined men in
the media getting ruined where we can't
say that maybe this isn't anecdotal
maybe the men actually have a point here
that you never hear the same argument
from liberals about the whole metoo
movement you never hear it ever and and
it's funny because I could you know just
show of hands from the guys and girls
why not do you know someone that's been
falsely accused
do you know someone that had their lives
ruined in divorce there you go and this
is this is I could do this in pretty
much any panel
um I I actually I went so far guys in my
research that I started asking Uber
drivers okay Uber drivers I just started
asking them about their lives I just
started doing deep dabs do you know how
many Uber drivers are Uber driving
because they lost their job during a
divorce and were financially ruined guys
it's so common a lot of guys ubereats
like a lot of guys have these jobs
because one guy I talked to had a high
paying job working in electricity or
some something like that he made six
figures he made a lot of money he did
Super well and I don't I don't say this
to be Doom and Gloom but it's like you
can only get so many stories of the same
thing happening so he works in
electricity right some really high
stress job his wife makes one phone call
kicks him out of the house she'd already
been to a women's shelter who advised
her to to accuse him of abuse right then
on top of that he the covid pushed his
court date off for a year and a half
hadn't seen his kid in a year and a half
because she wouldn't let him had to pay
child support every month a year and a
half later do you know what happens they
give her the child because she was the
primary caregiver he hasn't been in the
life for a year and a half and this is
the funny games that the court system
plays it's these gotchas it's like
damned if you do damned if you don't
um the men that were there more than the
mother they weren't providing for their
families the men that weren't there
didn't get their parental leave I guess
and this is the problem it is the whole
system and his women's way of like
thinking it's like when women infiltrate
um a system for whatever reason we just
we we we're so emotional we just ruin a
lot of these systems it's like if women
left work HR would disappear tomorrow
men men aren't the ones going to HR it's
women and I don't know why we're like
this this isn't to hate on women but to
understand we have a nature when we get
mad it's like we just do certain things
not every woman acts on it not not every
woman will but it to act like these are
like Fringe cases is the most delusional
thing I've ever heard in my life we have
men with money power status the same
thing happens to them the exact same
thing like if a woman's not happy with
Tom Brady who the hell is she going to
be happy with
um so yeah and like you're gonna I've
said 100 I've had men send me ring
camera footage of women neglecting their
children and they still get custody like
it and a lot of these fathers do
everything right there's nothing they
can do and it completely ruins the
entire system because it changes the way
we interact because again you know men
are at the whims of women and it's
really unfortunate and this is why you
should get your women shouldn't vote
t-shirt today or the sex of Me Okay
um well you Advocate what is that was a
joke
um okay okay
um all right so my earlier okay middle
couch is a perfect example of the type
of woman who'll be adopting cats no
peace just argumentative for argument's
sake please um Robert um is the wig
middle couch scroller what if a woman is
a multi-millionaire but was very
secretive about it would a man feel less
manly or valuable when he discovers that
his wife earns more after marriage do
you think
hmm I don't think they would care
if I just said oh you know what I just
wanted to just keep that low because I
wanted you to marry me for who I was you
know what I'll be like you know what I
wish you trusted me but girl that we're
not going to get divorced
all right four stinky armpits women
Pearl please look up women-led
civilizations and let's point out the
common factor compared to man-led
civilizations
um Daniel uh Pixie is a product of Third
Way feminism Doug MPA picks he is
showing that American white liberal
women are the most dangerous demographic
on the planet so hateful and spiteful
U.S Americans apologize for her behavior
she's a demon Daniel
there's some that were for you there's
some that were for you don't worry
there's more Daniel
um pixie has been going to several
podcasts trying to find support and
validation for the wrong views taking
L's everywhere and still refused to
learn Black Ops take away all the
benefits of divorce like the right to
half a man's wealth and alimony also
take away child support and make child
custody 50 50 except for those who waive
the 50 50 rights and women will stop
leaving marriages I'd go so far I would
just give men custody off the bat I I'm
here for the for the sake of the
children give the men custody but you
know that that would what you propose to
be better than what we have now okay bro
horse horse Davis
um send
seeds seeds produce of the kind children
belong to men beaten beaten cheeks ask
see this are women in the west depressed
if a man sleeps with a trans woman is he
gay
he's definitely in the closet
um are women in the west depressed um it
depends on what metric
okay so yes or no
um yeah in certain ways okay we'll come
back to this The Savvy ninja a high
value man is a man women want to be with
and man envy and want to be there's
plenty of things outside of money that
are highly valuable enter black dragon
um value has little to do with money and
everything to do with Integrity respect
honor wisdom ability leadership
accountability responsibility skills and
confidence all of which money can't buy
but acquire through hard work zero
Fallout many parts of the US have third
world problems pixie is just another
privileged Westerner speaking for others
Daniel or or Kay every part of Africa is
better than Kensington Adam Sutton
poverty
um Adam Sutton poverty stats are a
fiction to justify embezzling taxpayer
money they say a third of children go
hungry in the U.S because a third
qualify for food stamps but many live on
those Farms yeah and that's what I
started to learn and this is why I just
started to lose so much faith and stats
guys because this is they'll manipulate
and I'll give you an example you know
they consider people in poverty ones
that have television sets
it's like like do you know what I'm
saying like they'll add in they'll keep
raising these numbers to qualify them
under poverty so they can get more
benefits for from whatever agenda
they're trying to push or pass a policy
that takes away Freedom that's what they
do
um and you you start to see just how
manipulative and it's it's the same
thing with like okay the women are more
likely to kill children and then what
does she say oh well it's because
they're with them like it's like this
nonsense and so again we go back to you
know I personally I think the best way
you can come to conclusions is what we
see in reality
um Daniel okor I'm happy the pizza girl
is getting pushed back
um Carrie I don't like pixie but she's
right most of Africa and other
continents she mentioned mentions do
have poverty poverty does cause mental
illness Doug MPA American women have
aborted more babies than most African
countries there are two cities in the US
that don't have clean water Jackson
Mississippi
and Flint Michigan picks season
dangerous she's a demon Sigma mph as a
man we need to get out of our feelings
when we have these conversations as of
2020 the life expectancy of Nigerians
was 52.89 compared to 77 years in the
U.S it's not an insult to say westerners
live longer zero Fallout love how the
white liberal women talking for
minorities but pixie has never been to
Colombia she's a true acting like a
racist people don't know how to survive
Dragon stallion pixie do you know
anything that must Maasai tribe in
Africa is a very happy bunch of Hunter
and gatherer people they don't base
things on on what you think they should
live like be in cheeks if you guys paid
for pixie's plane ticket for this
appearance get your refund back Columbia
is better maintained than her entire
brain can master I go there once a month
they are happy just sad a15 pixie names
to change her name to Cutlery because
she is Arc cut out country wow guys you
guys are you guys are a bit rude
um you know demon that's a little we
don't have to call the women demons like
you could just say she's a different
point of view I'll read it though sorry
um because she's a contrary person on
YouTube beaten cheeks pixie doesn't know
anything and I lived over South America
Europe Asia and she needs to put her
ignorance out of the butt thing Mantra
the lady knows nothing I'm from a third
world and mental health issues yeah and
kids are a new ADHD Nada people can be
poor and really happy pixie what does it
feel to have the same mentality as
Margaret Sanger okay a lot of these were
at you so go ahead if you have any
thoughts
um I never said the Messiah tribe I
specifically referred to why you
obviously every single country has like
a lot of different people you're gonna
have areas that are nicer you're gonna
have areas that have horror I don't
think that should be controversial I
think that's just the fact
also I'm not a demon
um believe it or not
can you prove it
and sadly I can't
throw some holy water on me or something
sent to me in the chat telling us how to
speak now she's getting entitled
I'm sorry guys I'm sorry I'm curious why
do you think women are oppressed
um I think it depends on like what
metric I think um for example like women
are more likely to face like sexual
harassment in the workplace
um they're less likely to like um so I
have a question I'm gonna we're gonna go
to the next one but just quick question
do you think men typically will report
sexual harassment
um no but I also think that so so how do
you like why do you why do you think
that
um at least when it comes to like
surveys that make it more possible to
people report truly like Anonymous
surveys it still comes out that women
are still report higher rates of sexual
harassment do you do you think women are
honest about sexual harassment we don't
we don't see a metoo act like
problem
um I think most women are accurate or at
least honest especially when it comes to
like Anonymous survey data where there's
like no incentive to really lie
um I think um a lot of it what is it
you can make like biological Arguments
for like why that's the case I just I
don't think it's like okay anyway I
think getting someone that you dislike
in trouble is enough is a big reason
yeah
anonymously no no I mean like surveys
where it's like oh you know they send it
to like a thousand random people and
they're like have you ever been sexually
harassed what you Define harassment blah
blah blah and they still answer so what
is what is sexually harassed
um so your boss is making like
inappropriate comments about how you
look about wanting to do like sexual
actions with you
can you define an inappropriate comment
um like
dang girl you got a good booty I wanna I
wanna touch that what what if the women
are dressing half naked to work
um I Think Jesus said that like pluck
thy own eyes out or whatever when it
comes to wondering but I'm but I'm
saying like do you think there's a
problem with women dressing
inappropriately to work um not that I've
seen personally you've never seen that
um I'm sure there's like a couple of
examples of women who don't know how to
dress properly but I think most of the
time like they get in trouble for like
workplace like violations true like that
can be considered as form of sexual
harassment you know if you're like
showing your breasts to like a man just
like how if like a man and what happens
when they try to enforce dress codes do
women typically say oh that it's so
reasonable
um I think it depends on the company I
think most of the time if it goes like
out of bounds like there could be like
legal issues no but I'm just asking in
general like like in general when we
hear dress codes do women typically
comply or complain
um I think they I mean have you ever
heard a story of women whining about the
dress codes and calling them sexist yeah
I have okay so why would they have dress
codes well I think sometimes
um sometimes it is sexist right like the
idea that if I show my ankles I'm
somehow like trying to seduce a man like
that's sexist oh so it's uncles
no no but
my point is it's very can I'll tell you
it's very confusing to guys because what
women will do is they'll dress really
provocatively and then the guys will say
something because I mean by every metric
you're signaling that you want to be
approached if you're dressing Super
provocatively A lot of times I would
argue women flirt for attention and they
flirt a lot in the workplace men don't
mind they don't care but a lot I think a
lot of times when men respond then women
cry harassment I actually think that men
are discriminated more in the workplace
because I think a lot of times if they
they're afraid to look at a woman wrong
they're afraid to say the wrong joke
because again it's it's a joke that you
deem appropriate and if the wrong joke
is said or they say the wrong thing or
look at you the wrong way the women can
go to HR or cry harassment 100 we see
this happening all the time and we know
that HR is for the company and it's for
women it's not for men I know somebody
personally who was sexually harassed a
man sexually harassed at work over time
constantly and then the woman had the
audacity to then go to HR crying like
poe just said lying about what happened
saying that she was uncomfortable from a
comment than he made when he made
comment to literally just protect
himself and to stop what she was doing
to him and then he lost his job he lost
his job I know another girl we were
speaking with the other day she said
that two people in the workplace had a
consensual relationship the woman wanted
more the man didn't want anything with
her she then was upset and then got him
fired because she said that she was
uncomfortable and potentially sexually
harassed him this man lost his job so I
think and and also there was something I
saw that women always have a man in the
workplace that they're excited to see
they always have that work hubby exactly
why women wearing pencil skirts high
heels showing cleavage having buttoned
down top all of these things like even
in my workplace you know obviously
working in a law firm sometimes it's
casual sometimes it's not but some of
the women they dress so sexy and it's
like I'm uncomfortable I'm like wow she
looks good that's a nice shape whatever
like
our men thinking I think that women
dress provocative and then they cry when
they get the attention I think the
common theme here though is the
believable women thing isn't it
my advice to men is right because the
workplace traditionally it's like
statistically speaking it should be
where you would meet your partner right
it was either like in school or like
high school and then or work a lot of
people would you know the office work
party at Christmas time you know what
okay but now it's very dangerous so I
say to men do not speak to any girls at
work I don't care I don't care what
industry you're in do not do not men do
not speak to these girls at work because
if she likes you oh it's okay at that at
that moment it's okay but if she doesn't
lack your advances it's a trip to
Carolyn HR and once again like you know
we
there's always there's always a
character there's always a cow and a HR
but like you know we talk about stats
but I'll give an adult or one of my
friends you know I'm not going to
mention his name but the reason why is
because most men have friends that have
been through this or been through
something similar same thing he was a
girl at work and these these won't even
they won't even sexual nothing happens
you'll just flirtatious things you know
a few messages you know she'll drop
messages on his on his um on his car
little things like that okay they both
went for position
I both went for managerial position he
got the position she didn't the moment
he got the position problems start to
arise now and then she started saying to
him basically after he became my manager
so he had to obviously now instruct her
and start telling us certain things so
then she started saying you know to the
other she doesn't like she doesn't like
working with him obviously he doesn't
like the ways he's become a manager and
they say what's the problem what's
happening well and then the other thing
is like why why is he flirting with you
like because like the women will
complain about these comments but it's
like men are pretty timid nowadays you
know they don't typically want to
wrestle she was leaving messages I know
that's what I'm saying like typically
it's like were you dressed a certain way
like usually there is some signal that
women give to men to when they give you
like I think they said 90 of the time
women make the first move so po like
either
if they include yeah if they include
like um I can't remember how they
counted it but there was some like
pre-signal that women get to get men to
approach them I mean usually you guys
know like women will give you a look or
like yeah yeah that's true sorry to just
answer that to what you're saying that's
very true because in recent years of
dating I get told oh yeah you don't make
the first move but because of the way
Society is made I'm like I'm not gonna
make it do I feel like you're saying
it's okay you have to almost tell me
like I'm saying you're playing too and
it's like would you I said no because
for men so it's like if a guy is gonna
risk his job like typically she has done
something to Signal she likes him and
like but we just automat and you kind of
had it too you said well I think most of
them are telling the truth I think
there's so so let me just tell you what
happened with him so essentially so now
that's happened now and she's told them
that obviously it's because of you know
uh misconduct and the officer so
misconduct at work so now he has to go
in that's the right statement go through
all these types of things he has to go
through he has to go on a course of of
conduct at work
um and essentially she got moved to a
different place she got moved to a
different place nothing how he's still
kept his job but what happened was is he
didn't go past further than was going to
go to that was three years ago he's
still suffering from it now like like
PTSD from it and he's a black guy she
was a mixed race girl and the reason why
I say it is because he felt like why is
my sister doing this to me like he was
telling me it was literally saying it to
me he's like bro I don't understand it
like I'm trying to come up and we've
come up from nothing and why is my
sister doing it to doing this to me to
the point of where now he hasn't gone
any further he doesn't want to because
he's like oh I've seen what happens when
you try to rise up this is what happens
so I think we just really need to listen
to to the stories of men that are out
there that are really that going through
it and I do not recommend any man should
be approaching women I believe women I'm
not someone that approaches women I've
said it before women approach me I mean
I'm just what can I say this approach
people no they do but um no but a woman
can let you know if she wants you to
approach women have always traditionally
let men know this they can look at your
handkerchief I mean handkerchief like
literally they can smile at you they can
do whatever and then you do the rest all
you have to do but that one where girls
walking past you try to grab her armor
has not even looked at your immense
please stop doing that yeah don't do it
don't don't touch it yes I like you yeah
I want to be touched yeah I don't even
bother putting on a no woman yeah so I'm
curious when you hear this stuff what's
your thought
um I think that there's two sides to
every story I think um it definitely
does happen that some women you know Cry
Wolf I don't want to be like that never
happens
um I think the idea of like I'm sorry I
don't think a pencil skirt but in blouse
is like sexy for me are you serious have
you seen like the fantasy that men have
about like a woman at work experience
pencil skirt that is tight to your
figure that shows your curves you don't
think that's sexy yeah she's not a man
so obviously she can see I'm a man no
but also
trying to like shame off essentially of
course she doesn't think he's sexy
because she's not a man no yeah what do
you think guys I feel like the problem
is
like men can sometimes make almost
anything sexual I think like again to me
that's not it's true though look at the
people like look at historically right
when it's like oh like no like they
can't show their ankles like that's too
sexy oh wearing shorts like that's too
sexy like even like in Arabian countries
I mean it is sexy you're showing your
whole leg you're showing the shape of
your bum you're showing that your hips
it's sexy okay okay
with like Anatomy I don't think that's
inherently sexy like I I think it's sexy
if I start showing my breasts sure if I
start like you know making it close
where you can like see my private areas
like yeah that's sexy but I don't think
it's enough to just say like oh yeah
like I I have a body like that's I don't
think you don't think there's such thing
as provocative clothing
um I do if I have if you're not showing
so who wait I have a question who
decides what is provocative well that's
a million dollar question I don't think
it's fair to say like oh I could give
you an easy yeah well what is it then
that's the argument that people give so
why all women should wear I have a
question why why do you think women
dressed so modestly before
um I think that was a societal standard
at the time and yeah men were like oh no
if you show ankles that's too sexy okay
okay so you think it was because the men
just couldn't like handle it like what's
your what's your thought as to why
um what is it I I think that yeah they
were just like social norms in place
that like as we started growing as a
society we were like wait men aren't
dogs so men can look at an angle and not
like why did we have why did we have
those social norms
um we had those social norms in place
because I I do think that they were used
as a tool to try to like control women
and like repress them okay okay so
because people were married and they
wanted to protect their wives
people were 85 percent of people got
married people were married back then
they had a family and women did not want
to signal to other men that they were
available do you think that dressing is
always signaling to other men yeah yeah
I think I'll give you an example okay if
I dress like a police officer am I going
to be shocked that anyone comes up to me
to solve a crime or to arrest a criminal
you send messages like this awesome one
right here based on what you wear you
are sending a message to the world about
how they should perceive you yeah I
think um you want to be addressed it's
the same for a reason I think what is it
I think clothing is a part of identity
and I think people Express themselves
through their clothing I don't think
that automatically means that old
clothing is meant for seductions
can walk into a woman's bathroom then
you're saying like Okay like you're
acknowledging that clothing is part of
an identity but you're saying that's not
the whole thing well if it's not the
whole thing then how come we live in a
world where a man can walk into a
woman's bathroom just from wearing a
skirt because clearly identity is the
whole thing and and if you can
acknowledge that then you can
acknowledge that a woman sending certain
messages through how she she is dressed
is going to lead to certain Concepts no
because then you can't control how you
can't control how people
um what people think of you but you can
control the message that you send to
people yeah do you understand so you can
never we can never ever control what
someone's gonna think but I can control
the message that I send that to the
world and this is the thing what people
don't like like this you know I mean
like you the choices and trade-offs you
can dress however you want to but you
don't get to dress however you want to
and expect no no consequence and when we
every speak about it they're gonna start
saying oh you're victim shaming you're
police and women you're saying to women
how to dress but as a man with three
sisters I've always said I just told you
how my father raised me to look after my
sisters and whenever we speak about
women be careful about what they wear
who they run their surroundings there's
always oh but it's because
modern women want to feel as if they can
go out in this world without any
consequence but us as men as Leaders we
understand what built the world we know
it's these consequences the whole reason
you can go out in these dresses because
of the patriarchy the same patriarch
patriarchy you keep complaining about is
the one that has made it allow for you
to be safe if you now call the police
who's coming is it women or is it men
it's gonna be men and if women if a
group of women come you're not going to
really feel too safe so this thing where
women don't really understand men have
built and civilized the world so you can
now go out in a short skirt and do
whatever you want so you can literally
you're protected but you're only
protected because men have prior to that
you needed a man by your side and if you
was walking around showing ankles then
you might have found yourself in some
trouble but you see it goes back to
women wanting to do whatever they want
without consequence like you said so for
instance she's saying all these things
about her just because I'm dressed a
certain way blah blah blah which is the
normal rhetoric around women but the
reality of the world is the way the
world operates you are literally address
how you're dressed even in the world of
men if I'm walking down the road wearing
a balaclava or wearing a durag obviously
I'm going to be stereotyped I'm going to
be looked at a certain way
if I'm wearing a suit even the women are
going to look at me a certain way
if I if I walk up to a woman wearing a
suit
now and I speak to her maybe I'm rolling
a Ben scheme in my hand
I'm passing a message he would look at
me a certain way if I go around the
corner and the next five seconds rub mud
on my face wear some tattered clothes
and come back to the same woman she's
going to think I'm a completely
different person and we can't ignore
these facts either I was on a talk show
recently
um with a lady who was literally a
self-proclaimed bimbo and uh she had you
know all the
facial work all of that the fake boobs
and it was all out like I even I was
like
anyway she she yeah it was all out and
and she was wearing these stilettos and
the stilettos literally said sex on it
I'm not exaggerating it literally sounds
like a great gal like you you shouldn't
make any conclusions based on that she
told me a story about how she was uh she
was walking somewhere and a guy just
sort of came out and he was uh
how do I put this politely uh
getting himself off
to her like in front of her
um
and what came to mind for me and and I
really regret not saying this at the
time actually because it it only came to
mind afterwards
um that's never happened to me
and I don't think that that's a
coincidence that to someone like her who
presents herself in such a way that she
has had that kind of experience now I'm
not taking away from the fact that that
is wrong that is weird he shouldn't have
done that however people like that do
exist in this world and I think it's
down to each of us and our own you know
sovereignty and responsibility over how
we present ourselves to
take efforts to not put ourselves in
dangerous situations and I think things
like provocative clothing
um you know you shouldn't then complain
when you're getting those kind of
results because you have in in a way you
know boy on yourself and I know that
sounds so horrid it's true but I can't
say stuff like that
the other day um just quickly I was
speaking to a woman on the street we're
doing Street interviews me and my
husband and this girl she said you know
something terrible happened to me today
I wasn't going to say anything but you
know I tell you guys I'm like what
happened she said I got cat called
oh and I'm not joking she had a
see-through top on you could see her her
belly was showing it was very sexy and I
was just like duh again like I'm so
confused are you you're shocked and the
thing is with this cat call thing like
if the guy's attractive and you like him
you're gonna be fine with it and if
you're on if you find him ugly and
unattractive you're going to be offended
let's be honest that chick at like 55 is
gonna be whining that nobody's yeah
I don't know I feel like um I think when
it comes to most office women I like you
can like literally just sit outside a
building and see that most are not
dressed proactively I think um when it
comes to like anecdotes that you gave
like I experienced like when I was 13
there a guy did the same thing to me and
I wasn't I was dressed in like a 13 year
old's clothing like I wasn't dressed
like sex I mean like I said that's not
to take away from the fact that people
shouldn't have to go through that full
stop and it is weird and wrong but I
just found it interesting and it's like
you say I mean it's periodically I just
found it interesting that someone who
presented herself such as that did have
that kind of story
um and and and someone who didn't
present that bad I mean you know 100
years ago standards I mean I'm dressed
like an absolute [__] like but you know
there's there's levels to it you know
I'm not wishing these kind of
experiences on anyone but I am saying
that we do need to be a bit wiser we
can't just expect to have the benefit of
dressing extremely provocatively and
then not having any kind of can I ask
the ladies like when you get dressed up
to go out or whatever like if
relationships or what what have you not
but do you if no one ever gave you a
compliment if no one ever recognized
anything would that be a problem like if
you went out and nobody saw you like
like when I say no one's true like just
you're invisible yeah would that would
you how would you feel how would that
make you feel
it would make a difference yeah you
would you'd feel kind of um
you know
yeah
like I would be like nobody liked my
shirt
[Laughter]
that's understandable but the reason why
I asked there's levels to it because
it's like it all comes down to this this
uh Trend that we keep seeing of like
narcissism like there's levels to it
there's no one ever having coming up to
come up to you ever but then there's you
know most women you know none of us here
are dressed extremely provocatively most
women have had someone say a nice thing
to us you know every woman has mostly
not everyone
everyone here girl even fat chicks
that's because they're easy so then
there's the narcissistic level where
it's like people not so hooked to
wanting that validation through things
like compliments that they then go above
and beyond to present in such a way that
it's happening so much and then when it
happens from the guy they like it's like
oh great love that for me blah blah one
night stand whatever you know but then
when it happens from a guy that they're
not interested in who are also going to
find them attractive obviously right
because they're presenting in such a way
um it's sexual assault he did this to me
and I can't believe this happened to me
but it's like well you've you've brought
that on yourself in the sense that
you're so hooked to this narcissistic
egotistic idea that you want to get
complimented all the time that you are
then putting yourself in a position
where people are gonna compliment you
all the time so who do you do makeup for
and who do you get dressed up for when
you go out them
it's a very difficult question isn't it
it's a very generous it's a very
difficult because if it's for yourself
it's always men because if because if
for yourself as women always say women
or women's have a problem like for me
personally men don't have a problem of
saying we do everything for women
because technically we do everything we
do we got we make money for you I get a
new outfits for you I get haircuts for
you get a new car the first thing I can
think about the types of girls I'm gonna
pull up in it not because it but most
men we it tends to lead to women at the
end of it right because the things that
we do it tends to be you want to secure
them and you want to have a family right
but women seem to have a problem with
when yeah I think it's saying that I do
things for men for for men it sits to
attract a mate you know and it's also um
yeah I can't even really justify it any
other way it's it's for the attention if
you think about it like when we're at
home and we know that nobody's coming
over no one's going to see us do we have
our hair and makeup done but as soon as
you know your partner's coming home okay
all that stuff and then when you go out
in public you want to make sure you look
your best so if it really was for us
only then we would be like this from the
minute we woke up and in the house with
no one there I I don't agree and I think
there's a couple of things to break down
here like
um China right yes you don't have like a
shirt that you like for yourself or like
it's everything you buy you think oh
women are gonna like this like you don't
have an article clothing or something
and you're like I like this and you just
got it because of that okay so I don't
okay so when I say women everybody gets
this shirt yeah
I I like how I look with makeup right
[__] [__] no it's not a panther
yeah no so I'm not saying I go out
because I don't actually go out thinking
of women but I'm saying men every night
we do at some point it leads back to
women so I don't do it consciously but
why would I get a haircut
and it's not to try and not acknowledge
the fact that like of course you know
it's not saying that we do it all for
men like if it
for example like I I much prefer how I
look with makeup on right but I'm not
ignorant to the fact that the reason I
feel better with makeup on is because I
get a better response from people men
included with it on so you know no one's
sitting here and saying that you know
that the whole reason is because women
we we don't care about ourselves at all
and it's all about men like no of course
you you do things for it for a variety
of reasons but you have to be able to
acknowledge well why do you like that
and and generally that's because we're
social creatures and we feed off of
positive reinforcement and and you know
that positive reinforcement might go
back to say when you were a little girl
you wear your hair a certain type of way
and your parents say I love your hair
like that or something like that but
ultimately human beings we can all
derive generally what's attractive and
and what's not and what does that come
down to well it's mating selection so I
think that's the point that everyone's
trying to make like when we say like
women wear makeup for men
um it's not this idea that oh I really
need a man to pick me and I don't care
about myself and I'm just gonna put a
load of makeup on so that I can get a
man it's like no we're just
acknowledging that by logically men and
women do things to to attract a mate
yeah I agree that generally happens the
only place where I would be hesitant is
I do think um all humans have like an
inherent sense of beauty regardless of
mate selection so for example like we
can acknowledge like a sunset is
beautiful we can acknowledge like a lot
of things are beautiful that don't have
to do with mates and I think that also
can come down to appearance not saying
that never happens with appearance like
obviously sometimes people dress for the
opposite mate and stuff but I'm just
hesitant when people are saying like all
the time because I'm like no I think I
just I think we can look up at General
Trends right and I had this thought okay
and I thought what happens first do men
ask for sex or do women ask for
attention what comes first
and I thought to myself and I was on a
trip when I had this thought and I went
to Vegas
and I saw women without clothes on
walking around the street with stickers
on their boobs and what I see is that
when women don't get the attention that
they want we just tend to take off our
clothes
some women are prettier than others so
they don't have to do it you know but I
I go to workplace I see women start to
take off their clothes you know you used
to have to wear pants now they're
wearing these mini skirts
um and they just seem to get more naked
and more naked and more naked and I
don't think it's for women now I mean
maybe you could argue that women put on
their like fake eyelashes and like the
boat and all that
but it's usually they do it to compete
with other women for men because they
call me for men because if they're
awesome and we'll tell you we don't like
that take off them eyes like eyelashes
take out the fake hair take out the fake
nose Not all men I'm I'm okay I was it
was for a podcast get out stop being
weird guys now
um no question what else do you think
we're oppressed because so uh I told you
why I disagree on the workplace I think
men are discriminated way more because
they can be falsely accused and then
have promotions taken away and that sort
of thing what what else yeah
um I mean again we disagree on that
exactly I'm not saying it never happens
just that oh I think more likely than
not it happens that women are harassed
to a level I think another example what
can a woman do if she's harassed
um is she able to report it sometimes
sometimes they can't sometimes they'll
get punished why would she why would she
not be able to report it because
sometimes um depending on the company's
structure she'll be the one that's fine
would you would you say it's more common
for her to be able to report it or to
not report it I think not report it do
you think most no no no no no this is
2020 no this is 20. do you think most
companies have HR departments yeah but
okay who runs HR departments
um I think women and men it's much more
yes but the idea that like again HR will
they benefit most of all is a company so
if they think it's easier to get rid of
like a whiny complainy woman even if
it's a woman running it they'll do it
because if that was the consensus they
get rid of the whole HR department
because the HR department doesn't bring
anything into the business doesn't make
the money I know what you're saying
pixie but the problem with that argument
is that
um they've also got to be seen to be
politically correct like because
otherwise they could lay themselves open
to a you know
but I do think that they're
they've got these other non-profit based
concerns as well yeah I think that's why
it's like very like hyper dependent on
the company because you definitely have
some companies that think like oh you
know if we get rid of the woman or
whatever like you know she doesn't have
the resources
okay so I have a question where have you
worked
um I've worked for like a non-profit
before
um I've worked like what kind of
non-profit was it
um it was like what is it like the
medical supply stuff okay so you worked
for a non-profit that sold Medicals no
that was it was um it was like part of
like the mission trip and stuff like
okay and your experience there was that
the women had nowhere to complain to
well it was um like a very small small
Department
um there might have been like in the
parent company they could have but not
like necessarily in the okay and I just
want to know like where because a lot of
the stuff is basically not an actual
real job that most people have a lot of
people work in non-profits compared
people that work in actual jobs you
don't consider a non-profit an actual
job no it's not okay well I think we
have a fundamental disagreement on what
a functional job
my point is I just don't know like where
you get this stuff from
like like women just I don't see women
harassed in the workplace do you make
money and this could be a really dumb
question do you make money and did you
make money there like do they pay you to
work or are you a volunteer what is it
well I was a volunteer oh okay so I
agree with you I don't think so like
it's you just contradict yourself left
right and Center because the job is
something that someone does because I've
also done media management for other
companies and I've got paid for that
yeah so I just use that one okay because
I consider well well no because I
consider real work or important work
work where that helps other people so
that's where my mind went to first
okay okay the fact is labor okay so
I don't okay so and then your other
experience was media media management
yeah okay is that it
um it's okay if it isn't if it is I'm
just asking yeah I know I worked with
another non-profit and I did get paid
for that so I I just think I just think
in a bit you know that's a bit of a
bubble like especially a YouTuber's
media Personnel like media I just think
this isn't real life you know I I think
that the conversations we have sure but
like when it comes to like what most
people experience at work I I don't
think it's really comparable okay I have
a friend so who um what is it she was
she's a civil engineer she was like
working with her um company her
Department her boss was like harassing
her both like making demeaning comments
of her as a woman okay what were the
demeaning comments
um like oh like you wouldn't understand
like literally like straight up like you
wouldn't understand this because you're
a woman even though she got had her
degree are there things that women
typically don't understand about men
um or that don't understand because
we're a woman
um sure but so is it possible that that
was true
um not in the context what was the
context the context was like oh like I
don't want you to um work on this
project or you should go get coffee
instead what was what was the project
civil engineering related okay so she
she had a civil engineering job yes and
what what was she doing specifically
um I can't remember if it was like
something with like Bridge measurements
or like building measures okay is it
possible that he was joking no okay
there's no possibility no he repeatedly
was not trying to give her like you know
actual work and was trying to like make
her get her but does she not get paid
either way if she goes and gets coffee
or if she takes part on the project does
she not get paid either way it doesn't
matter because the whole idea is like
how old is she
um she's my age okay so she's 24. yeah
so I'll tell you what happens at a lot
of these engineering firms my brothers
are all Engineers they do preferential
hiring for women so a lot of times less
qualified women get jobs that they don't
really deserve this is super common I've
talked to Head Hunters about this and
what I what I would guess probably
happened is she was probably in a job
she doesn't she didn't deserve now this
is just speculating right yeah because
really if you're that useful people use
you like people I I've only I've only
been in male dominated Industries pretty
much I I worked in you know cop for your
skills I never had a problem getting
getting the men to take me seriously
because if you're useful people use you
and the thing is a lot of useless women
have jobs they don't deserve and wine
um I think and ultimately it's it's down
to her
what she does with that statement like
this is this is the problem I have with
the whole like harassment and things
like that because it's like all right so
she got told you know uh what was it you
wouldn't understand because you're a
woman that's what you said yeah
even still right if a guy said that to
me I'm not going and complaining to HR
like it is what it is it's down to you
what you deal with whereas something
like actual sexual assault the man
literally goes and sexually assaults her
in the woman's bathroom that is a bit
different like she can't really do
anything about that but what she can do
is decide whether she's gonna cause a
big scene over a comment or whether
she's just gonna
I'm gonna give you an anecdotal
experience I used to work at Amazon
before I got this job and
obviously I'm from Africa and I'm here
and then I got into Amazon and then I
started speaking with these white people
I have to say like that so that you guys
get a picture and the usual comment I
always get immediately is oh wow your
English is so good
and I look at these people and I'm like
I literally have a degree in actual
sense and insurance I'm more educated
than most of you that are here but then
you comment on the fact that my English
sounds so good because I'm black
and because I come from Nigeria and
quotes
that if that was said to a woman HR
straight
oh what is it there's a couple things
first of all my friend is very qualified
um she graduated from Colombia she had
like multiple like already like some
years of experience women always think
they're qualified I mean if we were
going to talk narcissism women always
think we're more qualified than we are
okay but okay she had her degree
whatever she had her degree from like
one of the most prestigious universities
I think those well if I if I ever if I
haven't met so many dumb people from
those universities I would be convinced
but I I don't think that that really
means much okay and my brothers my
brothers all work and I've ten siblings
half of my family is literally engineers
it doesn't matter not much no I just
think okay so so she got a prissy degree
who cares okay I think that if you're
gonna say like oh no like a lot of women
get these positions that they don't
deserve blah blah blah it would make
more sense to be like oh you know I
don't think um you have enough
experience to do this versus you're a
woman but but see the the men don't
really have a say so the higher the guy
that's be that's tiring like they have
they have to do it for their diversity
hires okay and and again that's you
telling men how to talk and this is my
problem I say if you want to be in a
man's world be in it and stop [__]
complaining I'm so sick of women going
into into men's workplace we asked to be
in the workforce so stop [__] whining
when you get into a man's job and they
make jokes you don't like they start
talking to you the way that you don't
appreciate and they don't say it how you
think you should they should say it
because all it is is narcissism where
you're going around telling everybody
how to talk and bitching and whining for
women like like me and other women that
have worked in male environments and
didn't whine and didn't complain and
just did the work if my boss asked me to
get coffee because I was a woman I
wouldn't give a [__] I wouldn't complain
I would just go get it because I don't
[__] and moan about [__] nothing I
thank God what is it you're essentially
saying that you know women can never be
harassed that's okay that's not what I
said I said I said that I said that a
joke is not harassment him saying that
to me was not be harassment and I'm
tired of women whining him repeatedly
not letting you do work like making you
get coffee like I couldn't say it to you
I would say this is amazing I get to
work less and you know what I would do
you know what I would do if I didn't
like it I'd go get a different job
rather than Wine okay
but they have to do it to build up to
get to where they want to be a lot of
times men do things they don't want to
do but they have to do it because that
is just okay what else I want to see
this like how would you feel if somebody
said oh you know I don't think you can
do this because you're black
your question is how do you feel exactly
I I will feel however I feel it doesn't
change anything but you think it's
unfair
no but this is unfair and we should know
this is the problem
but who made you God what do you mean
I'm not God I'm saying that we should
all work this is the problem with
privileged often white liberals as they
think everything should be fair and
oftentimes they grew up in the most
unfair thing because we came from two
parent homes and oftentimes well-off
neighborhoods and then we're whining
about fairness yeah I want everybody to
have a good life we had the ultimate
Advantage ever and that's why I want
everybody to live a good life no but
then and so what they do is they go
everywhere and whine [__] and complain
instead of get on with it they go into
these male workplaces and [__] and
complain men don't complain they just do
that's the difference between men and
women is men just do things like it's
also just patronizing as well to to say
like yeah I I had all of this and I I
just want everyone else to have it as
well like it's really patronizing and it
goes back to the point that we were
talking about earlier of you know
assuming that that people in in all
these places of poverty you know are are
unhappier or whatever you know it's just
it just comes across as patronizing like
you can say how you feel yeah it's but
it is
oh you know what like I just want
everybody to like you know not because
you're saying that because because
you're saying and discriminated one
women cry discrimination for freaking
everything like you know what I'm so
tired of I am so tired of women going to
male dominated Fields asking to be a man
but not being able to take it like one
yeah well men are not being treated the
same way that the women are being
treated
women you're out of interesting anything
else did anything else happen apart from
with your friend did did it go any
further than that well what is it he
basically like kept doing it for months
not just a coffee thing but like
constantly like talking down to her
because like of her sex what is talking
down was this in the states yes
no okay okay no no I want to hear what
talking down and this is why I'm going
to say right there this is why men are
afraid of women because right there that
Spite now I'm going to sue the employer
that gave me a job that was giving me a
paycheck every week every month where
instead of having gratitude for it they
sue them later and this is why I always
say if I was dudes I just wouldn't even
have women in the workplace because all
they're going to do is [__] moan and
then sue you later I don't think anybody
should be a bootlegger I don't think
because somebody's paying your salary
that means that you have to be like but
this is no but see this is no no no no
no no no I want I want to point out that
entitlement right there no no this is
what I want to point out because this is
how women treat men like a paycheck the
same way they treat nobody should be and
this is this is what this is what though
this is this is how women treat men and
and this is the problem is they they
feel no gratitude to people that gave
them opportunity and made their life
better it's always entitlement and I
can't stand it because it gives women
that actually work hard bad name okay so
I find it interesting because you're
saying like oh no the HR department is
why they got hired it wasn't the boss
but then you're supposed to be grateful
to the boss even though I think I think
that people that I think one you have so
much opportunity as a woman I I think
that women whine and [__] over nothing
that that's my opinion I think they get
into into workforces and then they
complain over the smallest jokes men
talk how they talk men are kind of rough
they make crafts jokes they they talk
different than us and then they [__]
wine and sue them later and I don't tell
other men oh you can't do this job are
you do you know you know what's funny
men speak to other men way worse
I mean Chris they don't do it on the
basis of being a man no they don't say
hey you're not smart enough to do this
because they're mad
actually actually on a contrary they do
it yeah yeah because men have that that
challenge this is the thing you have
You've Been Told before oh like you know
you can't do this because you're a guy
okay so listen to this I'm an
entertainment industry right so it's
like as a black man over here right and
some people say I'm somewhat successful
now in order to get in that position I
have to accept that [__] rolls downhill
excuse my French so I don't go in there
crying about how I was talking to you by
MD or director or whatever because I
know what goals I've got and I know the
environment so the point I'm not saying
I'm not advocating that people should
get spoken down to but the point what
Paul's saying is when we put ourselves
in certain Dynamics people can't deal
with it then change then just yeah what
I'm saying is that oh don't but don't
say don't stay in the same situation and
then keep complaining about the same
information that's why I'm saying I am
saying that we should be able to change
this we should be able to like no no you
said sue so you're you're saying you're
entitled you're entitled to more money
because you don't like the way someone
talks do you know what really suing is
literally monetary damage
it's because of my my feeling this is
what liberals do my feelings were so
[__] hurt that I
I have never had a problem getting any
job that I wanted any woman that [__]
and moans about her boss the way they
talk about getting some some job is just
whining for no reason and they shouldn't
be taken seriously because the women
that actually work hard and actually
like do things they don't stand for this
[__] they don't [__] they don't moan
they just do it and I am so sick of
liberals coming into the workplace
wanting to be in a man's world and then
bitching about it later I'm literally
just trying to say like hey you know
what you shouldn't talk down to People
based on their sex or on their race well
maybe she was just stupid oh she
literally
Pearl like I literally because it's
almost like you can't believe that I
just can't believe it
I knew for a fact she had top grades
okay sorry I have a question what are
the hardest workers you're talking about
anecdotes and I'm telling you like I
know this person is great do not mean
you're a company okay she had workplace
experience too well she didn't keep the
last job what do you mean
she had to get the new job no she's
still she's okay this is her first job
um no it wasn't okay so she didn't keep
her last job yeah okay there you go but
like so I have a question do you know
anything about engineering
um do you yes or no no I'm not okay
just so because she's your friend and
she says she's amazing she's an amazing
she's amazing
with the Liberals
either they're totally like oh my
brother told me they talk about [__] you
don't know anything you don't know
anything either
you came to the conclusion that you
should sue an employer how entitled is
that when you don't know [__] about the
adult you don't know
going through that I think she should
too but you can't tell me that I don't
know about the industry but literally
the only thing you know about the
industry is also okay I have oh three
generations of Engineers
like what what difference does it make
you're you're right you're right your
special friend that went to Colombia my
multiple friends I I'm saying you don't
seem like you have a lot of friends okay
girl I I don't know what to say I'm
gonna ask a question do you believe in
like you see that the phrase in the
workplace climbing up the ladder do you
believe that you're going to be met with
some type of resistance or hurdles along
the way yeah I think you are everybody
all right so so if you was like sort of
like I don't know mentoring somebody
else you know that's going into the
workplace what type of advice would you
give them on how to deal with that type
of system would you advise them to quit
or would you advise them to have a bit
more sustainability or just a bit more
tolerance or how what would you say to
them if you would you say if you're met
with that type of behavior just quit
your job would you advise it no of
course everybody's going to be met with
like a level of pushback and they're you
know in general you have to like try
your best to keep climbing the point
that I'm trying to make is that when we
as like Outsiders see these things
happening we should be like hey that's
kind of [__] up that's not she told
you what she would say she'd say Sue no
I said two she got no that's what you
said I'm saying you oh yeah she's saying
when she gets adversity soon
glad I am so glad this comes from the
horse's mouth so when I do these
whiteboard presentations and talk about
how women go into Industries and Sue
later and [__] and moan I can show
point a point B Point C of a woman who
knows nothing about engineering knows
nothing about the firm her boss says a
joke she doesn't like tells her to get
coffee and now lawsuit that's not what
I'm saying I'm saying if you reach a
level where or you know you're they're
not letting you keep climbing up the
career it looks like you're gonna have
to spend time finding another job you
know what they're doing is unfair and
unjust then yeah you should try to make
the company but you don't know that but
actually literally the higher you go up
in any industry the more cut through it
becomes so if you can't handle someone
telling you to get coffee or speaking
down on you at the lower levels how the
hell do you expect no no I'm saying that
if it comes to a point where you know
they're not living they're getting
letting you grow at all then yeah I
think you should make the company pay
I'm not saying that you should do it
every single time that something bad
happens
through every industry you are always
going to get to that point where someone
is not going to let you go yeah and then
I I think you should buy soon do we get
to that by fighting for your spots yeah
yeah no perseverance I think competence
do you know why do you actually you know
why I know that this chick is an idiot
that your friend because the smartest
people the most competent people I know
no they don't complain they don't [__]
they don't Sue they don't talk about
this stuff because they're no no yeah
because they're too busy working they
don't have time and I think also like I
think it's highly probable that
potentially obviously we don't I don't
know your friend but she was she was
hired because she was a woman because I
know a girl who studied engineering and
she was like the only there was like two
girls in the whole grade of people at
University who studied engineering so
the fact that she got this job
potentially is because of this equity
and diversity quota and equity and
diversity quotas are so dangerous like I
looked into the case of
um Travis Rudolph who was a footballer
who was uh charged with murder and his
life was literally ruined by this woman
who lied about being domestically abused
by him now the person that they had lead
the entire investigation for a murder
trial was a woman who was potentially uh
um promoted up to lead detective in the
case just because she was a woman she'd
only been in the homicide department for
three years she was a young woman when
she was on trial when she was like
literally
um on the stand giving evidence she was
wholly incompetent she was completely
out of her depth now he wouldn't have
even been charged with murder if it
wasn't for him her incompetence and she
wouldn't have been in that position if
she was not a woman because she did not
have the merits to be there so I think
given the given what you're saying
potentially that was why she was hired
and potentially that is why she was not
up to the job I don't and I'm not going
to say that I agree with her being like
you know I don't think that people
saying bad things to people in the
workplace is nice I don't think that
that's fine but like everyone's saying
men get it women get it I I'm a lawyer I
work with men all the time and I prefer
to work with men I prefer to work with
men because there's no drama there's no
[__] there's no backstabbing there's
no side comments there's no fakery it's
just all logic and getting something
they won't sue you later for nothing an
idea that men don't Sue I think is not
in reality in the workplace it's very
unlikely because men have a thick skin
and Men give tough love to each other
and that's why they get better and
better and better and better because
they're always I guess taking this out
of each other because it makes them
better and they're like hey bro you
could do this better next minute they're
better you say that to a woman she's in
HR crying and then you've lost your job
and you don't know what's happening
there's a difference between like hey
like I'm gonna be a little bit tough on
you because I think you can do better
and I don't think you can do anything at
all
and that's the thing like men men we
don't speak like women and so whenever
we speak to women all we ever get told
is we're policed and we're tone police
right so you have to understand me as a
man he can tell me some of the most
harsh and you might think it's harsh but
that's what I need to hear and if I
can't take that then that's that bit
when they're gonna start saying oh you
need to man up a little bit because as a
man like so the reason why you don't
understand it is because you're looking
at it from a woman's point of view like
you the world does not owe you or myself
anything it does not always
understanding you may feel and I don't
care I don't care if someone says that
to me because I'm smart I've always been
freaking smart and I've always done
anything that I could set my mind to and
if I want to do it I can do it and I
don't give a [__] if some boss says
something to me some side comment and
I'm sure as hell not gonna Sue and you
know why this pisses me off so much
because it makes it harder for everyone
else and everyone else they think you
have these stupid diversity hires they
think it was just handed to you when
really it's like women like that that
Sue for no reason that give all of us a
bad name not for no reason though I know
you want to minimize it and pretend it's
nothing but it is nothing like do you
hear this is what I'm mean when women
whine and complain we live in the in a
civilization that was built by a man you
used to need a husband to protect you
now the government pays you to be a
single mother the government pays you to
basically be homeless as a chick the
government pays you to have multiple
baby fought all of there's so many
incentives you can get paid to go on
only fit you can get paid to do whatever
you want and on top of that you don't
need to live with a guy if you don't
want to we have all the choice we've
ever had in human history and what will
women still do [__] I just moan don't
complain I don't like the way he talked
to me oh my God he's such a standard
respect everybody should have for each
other no oh no he didn't give me the
respect men know that you have to earn
respect women feel entitled to it and
that's the truth I'm sorry everybody has
a basement I was going to say sorry in
certain workplaces it's especially
engineering when I start engineering
remember like as a as a um Railway
engineer like we're responsible for
people's lives so you see when I start
when I finish my qualification I started
up as a white hat they have to make it
hard for me so the supervisors have to
talk to me because it's a serious job
it's the same way when you go into any
serious industry whether you're a lawyer
you don't start off after you finish
your MLB and everybody's nice to you oh
welcome to the firm like it doesn't work
like that if embarrassed to start going
to do that do do the bar you start for
obey the bottom finding paperwork if
they don't care if you go first in your
degree because because guess what it's a
riot of Passage I'm just from a
generation where I believe in the right
of passage and the people that make it
through the right passage the people
that deserve to be there yeah the
problem is that she already basically
went through that grunt work and like
was already that was already part of her
experience and she was literally High uh
hired for this higher level position
what grunt work she's had like two years
in the workforce okay your entire 20s is
supposed to be grunt Work men know this
they know this they know they go into an
industry and the older guys are gonna
kind of bully them a bit and they know
it and they get over it the meanest you
know what you know what's so crazy I
used to in this horrible oppressive
patriarchy or some times the man made
fun of me was so horrible I worked
around plumbers right and I would go
teach how to like you I sold Plumbing
products and literally I would would go
to these schools and the way the men
would bully each other was meaner than
any man has talked to me in my life they
were so mean and I was like oh my like
they were calling this one guy fat this
one guy ugly this one guy's stupid like
whatever insult you want us it was so
mean and they just got on with it they
didn't [__] to HR they just went and
worked did their job and women can't
handle getting coffee it's not just
coffee it was literally a series of like
harassment oh my God the harassment you
like had to go do something because
you're a woman
with the same pay again I don't I'm just
repeating myself at this point but there
is a difference between just being mean
to someone and being mean to someone on
the base of their gender or their race
there's a difference between like how do
you know the difference because they
quite literally explicitly stated out
saying you can't do this because you're
black you can't do this because you're a
woman you can't do this because of that
factor Yeah question do you think you're
entitled what do you mean I think what
is it the problem she has a problem with
the reason that was given for why she
can't do it yeah the real question is
is there a possibility that what he
didn't want her to do she actually
couldn't do it
because you're a woman maybe okay they
were building a bridge and then they
needed some men I'm just giving an
example meant to carry across some beams
and then he looked at her I was like you
know what you can't do this because
you're a woman no no this was I know for
a fact that this was like are you there
and Mathematics were you there no were
you there but so you don't know no okay
she's literally telling me a story about
like calculation right okay okay okay so
you did you weren't there okay so you
weren't there a civil engineer it's not
the same thing as like literally a
construction worker wait wait so you
were not there
um no but okay so so do you know do you
know it for a fact yeah I know for a
fact she wasn't a construction worker no
I said do you know what happened for a
fact stop changing it okay
um I wasn't there firsthand experience
okay so you don't okay she believes all
women anyways no I just think that I
have reason to believe this story I
think um
yeah
she's a good character I don't go
imagine if I went to every single one of
your anecdotes where you're like telling
about your friend and like but can you
know that for sure actually were you
actually there
I don't have proof that's the point yeah
my anecdotes have proof too no she
doesn't so your proof is what she said
to you our proof is the fact that part
actually see his kids okay so documents
if she has recordings of like this guy
saying this [__] to her would you
believe me then
I believe it I'd still think she's
bitching for no reason probably like
honestly I just think if that's what you
have like I am just God I'm so like do
you know why this pisses me off so much
because I'm just so sick of lazy liberal
women making a bad name for women in the
workplace God I'm so sick of it I'm so
sick of women asking to be in a man's
world and bitching when they get in it
either be in a man's world or don't be
in a man's world but don't [__] about
the way people talk to you they get over
it I think it's really sad that you
think a man's world has to have people
talking down on others because of racism
we should try to but you're a managing
the points you made is like uh that
someone shouldn't receive disrespect
based on their gender age blah blah blah
basically the equality act 2010 that we
have over here which is about
discrimination so
you'd be arguing the same thing if she
didn't get the job but the point is like
the guy said you can't do this
particular task because you're a woman
right he didn't suck her for being a
woman exactly that does it that's still
a form of harassment like that that
would be a form of discrimination yes if
he sacked her purely on the basis of her
sex but saying you can't join in on this
particular task for whatever reason even
if he said it like it's it's words
you're really telling your friend yes
Sue this company because you don't like
the way someone spoke to you have you
never heard the saying sticks and stones
may break my bones what's gonna help me
get a group
and that's the difference between men
and women because you're like if someone
said that to me as a man you can't do
this because of what any reason not
let's not because you're black
[Music]
I'm like I have a question I have a
question China and when you're in male
only spaces do they make fun of each
other for race
in front of each other for gender
everything do they make fun of each
other for Less yes
would you say in a man's world that's
part of it that's part of it anyone has
done peace so so then if women so if
women if women want to be in a man's
world then get then then get over it
that's a man's world because I can
handle it but he can handle it all of us
can handle it right but then you come
and say oh no you shouldn't be spoken to
like that as a man but that's because
you're a woman and you wouldn't like
being spoken as a woman yes I think it's
basic what is it it's human human
decency not just basic human decency but
how else do we come like become better
in society as a whole if we don't by
becoming more confident by becoming more
complicated you cannot you cannot change
the way people treat you yes you that's
part of no you can't that's what
liberals I'm sorry did the Civil Rights
Act not happen in the United States um
did we not get rid of like
discrimination when it comes to voting
like did we not no we should bring look
look what happened when we started to
stop look it I mean ever since women
voted this goes back to my first thing
we treated women in society women can
vote and so okay
and what's happened since women are more
depressed than ever women have made
horrible decisions we have more only
fans models than teachers women have
chosen I don't think that's true
it's the Twitter no it's Dr David Baker
you guys can look it up the history of
sex he's written like 10 books on the
evolution of sex so no that that is a
real stat you can look at that only 10
girls and versus teachers no I said I
said no I I said I said there's more
only fans workers than teachers right
now Dr David Baker look it up [__]
but but
um I'm giving you the source but you go
in bad faith this is what this is what
I'm asking you right this is what this
is what liberals do I'm saying it's Dr
David Baker I'm saying it's right there
right there the history the the history
of sex yeah there you I I'm saying here
is the source we can talk about it later
but you think I'm lying this is this is
this exactly you
also you said the same thing at the
start of the show you're requiring
something I think I think you guys can
look it up because we have literally the
internet right here
in real time but this is this is the
point it's like why not why not we're
not catering to
you it's entire it's entitlement it's a
title I'm just asking it goes back no it
goes do you know what it is it's like
it's like it derails the conversation so
let's take on let's just take let's just
take let's just take on board that the
um the research has been done when the
show finishes you can go and you can go
look up yourself like when you give me
stats I want to take on board your stats
are right I'm not gonna pull up my phone
now I'm Gonna Take It on board that
you're not going to come on here make
yourself an idiot when people are alive
and people can go look at here so let's
just treat it as everybody that's
talking about this that's they've
they've gone and looked it from a source
if you choose not to believe in it
that's fine but on your own time when
you come off the show go do some some
secondary research go look at some
bibliography some references whatever
you want to go and do to make yourself
feel better you go and do it but let's
just say for the process of when we're
in here that we know what we're talking
about the problem is when I have read
things that are like literally like
contradicting but the part no the
problem is you think you [__] know
everything
you think you know everything about
engineering you think you know
everything about the chat
and I gave you the stat so it's like
it's like it's like I can give you I
could literally get this author for you
on the phone I could literally do it I
could I could give you his literal
number he he does research you were
talking about bias samples what was it
you said earlier about like Capital bias
sample bias um and your your answer is
let's look it up let's look up let's
look it up is Google not a sample bias
what you can search results that you get
on the first page of Google is that not
all sample bias no but if you looked up
the specific study though she would get
the result wouldn't she yeah right the
whole point is is that like we're we're
talking about statistics and everything
but the truth is like everything that we
find is all from a sample bias anyway
um that's yes and no because that actual
study itself you can see the methodology
and you can see like if there was um
bias in that methodology or how valid it
is so like the study itself like is not
biased yeah nobody how did you find that
study it is actually literally it
doesn't every single study there's no no
story that has zero bias yeah no but
there are like a lot of methods that you
can take to basically limit bias a
little tonight science there is nothing
absolutely there's nothing yeah I'm not
saying it's perfect there's no study can
do and say oh yeah but it's like it's
like it's like even even the beginning
of the show you you would rather look up
stuff about Africa than talking to the
people in the room from Africa well what
is it I'm trying to say well again what
I was saying is like hey Africa is a big
continent there's some places that
suffer poverty there no but it goes back
to like the know-it-all well it goes
back yeah
being like ah yes you're from Africa so
that means everybody in Africa is Rich
and has like a living right now
no but you know but when you tell me hey
you know what instead of like talking
about studies instead of saying like hey
we should search things up you should
just blindly trust people yeah like
there's gonna be sexy but okay so you
want to live in an ideal world where
everything's fairy tales okay I have a
question
okay so I have a question so when you
read the study okay you you read the
study who are you trusting what do you
mean oh I'm trusting what is it the who
yeah the peer review research okay I'm
trusting what is it so you're okay but
you're trusting an institution yeah but
I believe that these institutions have
like gotten enough Merit to have trust I
don't just like what is it saying like
oh no it's from an institution you see
it's automatically followed no I didn't
say it was automatically false that's
not what I said but but I'm saying
regardless you're still trusting
somebody yeah yeah yeah right they're
providing more evidence okay but but I'm
saying how is it not more evidence when
five men like or three four men that are
from the place like to me it's like it's
like that that isn't that that means
nothing to you
um there's a difference between like
institutions who have literally built up
credibility over decades
what are you defining credibility is to
me what I see in big institutions is a
lot of cronyism and actually no
credibility or qualifications whatsoever
well you have like blind reviews you
have um what is it journals you don't
think cronyism comes into those blind
reviews
um yeah I think at least in the United
States you can get like your license
revoked basically you can suffer like
very severely revoked by who
um by what is it like other scientists
in the field basically and you don't
think cronyism comes into that well no
it's a whole point that like hey I'm not
saying it's impossible for cronyism to
get in what I'm saying is that like hey
like these institutions are literally
built up on these like stringent rules
for a reason you know pixie you said
you're from Puerto Rico yes okay so I'll
be honest when you said Puerto Rico I I
don't know man you know that for me like
you're from Poland or something to me
not Finland I've been honest Puerto Rico
from the image of what I've seen the
Puerto Ricans you don't look like Puerto
Rico like a Puerto Rican person to me
right yeah the image of what I've seen
of Puerto Ricans right
but I don't know anything about Puerto
Rico yeah you're Puerto Rican now if you
tell me actually there's lots of white
fair-skinned Puerto Rican people I'm
going to listen to you because you're
Puerto Rican but I'm telling you like
what the image of of what we've seen of
Puerto Ricans over it's not you it is
not you when the man set up my team's
from Puerto Rico she doesn't look like
you yeah but guess what if you tell me
about Puerto Rico I'm going to listen to
your unadopted experience because
actually it's a big sample because
you're you're from there yeah but you
have one two three four men that have
literally just tried to give you a
little bit of information we haven't
tried to say to you you're wrong we've
just had to say look for my experience
you have a man that came here only a few
years ago a few years ago he's not
suffering from mental health he's not
starving do you understand no that's why
I apologized earlier it's fine no it's
okay it's okay it's okay that's
something that you thought right that's
fine you don't have to apologize for
thinking something you don't know but
once you get a little bit more education
a little more information this is the
point where you need to listen you don't
need to reply just to be right just
listen then you have another man that's
sending you by his experience you have
another man and these are three African
people that are speaking to you about
the experience at this point we know
more than you yeah and it's not because
I know more than you should put my
things no you more know about you know
more about Puerto Rico than me what do I
know I know it from rap music videos
from the culture that I've seen I don't
know anything about Puerto Rico right
and at that point you can tell me so all
I'm saying to you is when you have
people that may have a little bit more
information than you yeah it's okay to
be like you know what I'm going to
listen even if I don't necessarily agree
with you I'm going to listen to your
experience because you know more than me
and that's all I'm trying to say so I
only said it because when you say Puerto
Rico I looked at you I was like right
I've never seen anyone like you that
comes from Puerto Rico but then again
I've never been to Puerto Rico and I
don't know Puerto Rican people right
yeah I think um what is it
and there is something to be said about
like oh you know not trying to like
completely discount what somebody's
lived experiences but if you read about
Puerto Rico before and I said something
like Puerto Rico is like actually doing
like really wealthy everywhere and then
you're like uh I'm not sure if that's
true that'd be okay that'd be valid you
know I think there's like a middle
ground to find here I'm not saying that
like your anecdotal experience means
nothing I don't believe that I think
like everybody has experiences that
inform them of like who they are in the
world around them but I don't think you
should blindly trust everybody too I
think you have to have a middle ground
wait but the oh I said that you
shouldn't the guy that did this research
he said he's calling me
wait she says I'm lying I'm a big liar
just about everything are you here
yeah I can hear you can you hear me yeah
um can you give them your educational
background a bit are you texting are you
listening you wanted you want it you
wanted it okay
yeah okay my educational background uh I
uh was a university lecturer for years
uh decade and a half about broad terms
and natural history and uh the long
trend of human history so a lot of
evolutionary biology about 300 000 years
of human history I recently published a
two billion year history of sex uh and
find booksellers everywhere on October
5th uh I I've got a pretty good mix of
natural and social sciences I've worked
with some of the finest uh
physicists and evolutionary biologists
and geologists on the planet including
one of the people who discovered what
killed the dinosaurs uh statistically
I've got fairly sizable chops
considering I used to do this genre of
History which was Finding broad
mathematical patterns in human history I
mean how much more do you [__] want
from me so my question to be clear the
statement was there are more only fan
models than teachers is that what you
believe
I couldn't really hear the question okay
so yeah yeah you can't hear so um I I
was telling her about the research that
you did where you found that under it's
under 35 there's more only fans models
than teachers now
uh yeah uh the only qualification is and
pearl you always leave this out it's
only fans models and like cameras
okay and under 35 okay well that's a
very different stat than oh overall
there are more it's only found well well
I mean because beauty is currency so
obviously the young hot chicks are gonna
you can't really okay what did you say
the stat was like over four like what
percent of prostitutes quit over the age
of like 40. it's like most of them right
yeah that's the overall uh the overall
majority of them um yeah it's like only
tiny percentage remain it's not
economically feasible uh otherwise I
don't have the exact stat off the top of
my head because as I mentioned I'm
walking the dog
what a guy
the stat for uh online sex work only
fans canning Etc uh for women under the
age of 35 is four percent
um which if you look at uh a sort of a
list in say the U.S or the UK of the the
major career paths or professions that
women pursue it puts it right up there
with nurses and teachers and so forth
now depending on the country and the
year that you get the data from uh you
know the online sex worker will be above
or below some of these other jobs on the
list it'll always be Below Retail
because that's the big one for both men
and women
um but yeah like it's it's pretty damn
close it's it's definitely in the the
top five
um in most countries if not that's top
ten and a lot of that's due to how many
people flooded into it during the
pandemic but it was already advisable
and I have a question that doesn't that
doesn't include like Instagram models
like there's no way to like do that
right
didn't know even though like some
Instagram models are obviously just
purveyors of software pornography no
that does not include any of them yeah
because I know a lot of them like
there's a stereotype Dubai et cetera
wait
um
do they charge a subscription to show
what most people would agree is highly
sexualized content like uh not safe for
work content whether it's masturbation
uh boy girl girl
Etc wait so I just want to clarify
you're saying you can't be certain about
this number globally you have around the
percentages that it's like top five or
top ten but it's gonna vary per country
right
uh could you repeat the question once
again I can't hear that so she's saying
this varies depending on the country
like obviously Saudi Arabia is going to
have less only fans models than other
than the US
yeah no no she's she's absolutely right
um
when I recently put this stat to you and
I forgot to point it off I pointed out
just at the off the top of my head just
now is we're talking to developed World
um in fact we're not even just talking
the developed World we're talking
Western because the stats for Korea and
Japan are slightly different so we're
talking North America Australia New
Zealand Europe Western and Central
Europe
um
okay thank you
okay bye-bye
bro come with the receipts I just I
don't I don't I don't like like I I
don't like it when people come on my
show and accuse me of lying I'm not a
liar well now now and you're gonna and
you this is wait like that you guys
always try to do you'll put some caveat
while they're Saudi Arabia doesn't have
hookers okay we know we're in the UK
we're in the U.S that's what it's about
well what is it I feel like that
conversation was like really productive
because it's a very different statement
to think like oh you know okay a woman
in your country are like whoring
themselves out well when you when you
think about it we really are and I'll
tell you why we are because we used to
trade sex for marriage and someone that
didn't do that was considered a [__] so
96 of women aren't virgins on their
wedding days meaning
um 100 years ago 96 percent of us would
be [__] it's really uncommon and he's
like gone into this with me it's really
uncommon for women to have as many
sexual partners even three which most
guys would say less a low end nowadays
that's really uncommon for any other
time in history and and there's really
big costs of female promiscuity and we
look at the body count stats right you
know the the more Partners a woman has
the more issues she has staying married
being happy there's a lot of it and
you're gonna roll your eyes right but
because I don't know why you have this
like need to be right like you just it's
like
sign language okay I'm sorry if I'm
coming across as too combative I just
think um no don't don't apologize like
you don't have to apologize for being
who you are like it's it's who you are
so don't don't ever apologize for that
it's just that people are trying to
it's not even educate you just provide
you with a little bit more information
that you may have and it's just that
when they do I think you find it
I think you find it very hard to to take
on new information like like I think
maybe like I see you trying to like make
this work like okay well there's women
in Saudi Arabia that aren't an only fan
so it's not that bad no no I okay so the
reason why I'm like okay that's
different to me is because it's not
women in Saudi Arabia that aren't inside
like oh you know it's not all women in
general
um it's not like the majority of big
people are prostitutes versus like
teachers but it's the majority of all
modern women under 35 that's all modern
women well they're not even saying all
of them right they're saying it varies
from country to country but we can just
talk about let's just talk about the UK
and the US yeah it is and it seems like
what is it all modern majority of and he
actually he includes other like I think
Australia's in this too there's it's not
just UK and U.S he said West Australia
North America Western Europe yeah
includes the UK all of the countries
that are in Europe yeah
you see that does it like bother you
like why are you sure are you struggling
to just accept well what is it the
reason why I'm um it's not what is it
I'm just I'm hesitant I got you I got
you a re uh the the smartest Pro one of
the smartest people I know on the line
on the line answer who else could do
that I don't find even more fascinating
is the fact that it's the Liberals that
find it hard to to take on that start if
you are conservative I would understand
why you're finding it hard to take on
that stuff but you're liberal and you're
finding your heart with all the values
we know liberal people seem to hold when
it comes to sex and things like that
that is I mean I think you're probably
just putting on the front no but you
know the truth I think um what is it
they said only fans plus cam girls
Pearl don't misquote the staff
cam girls is really different no I I'm
sorry I should clarify it guys my only
hesitance before like completely
accepting this that is I wonder um
how is it only based off of accounts or
how many of them are active or how many
why is that why is that relevant why is
that relevant okay they just told me
it's relevant because I know girls who
opened up an account but they never like
up uploaded whenever you're like he did
he did provide the metric of its um not
since uh what is it not appropriate for
what content and then he cited uh that
it was things included things like
masturbation man woman yeah okay so it
is the actual porn well I have I have a
question would you agree there's also
Instagram [__] that like just sell
themselves on Instagram yeah sure okay
so it's actually higher
so it's actually it's actually probably
higher because we're not including the
women that accept money for sex through
Instagram what about the women who don't
even ask for money they just put it all
out there for the sake of it yeah well
travel travel is a big thing as well
isn't it you know try girls
yeah so you wanna hear something
disturbing
I'm gonna say it there is a website
right now
that I could give to you right just for
time I'll give it to you off camera so
you have a look at yourself now men can
literally go in there and Order sex like
you're ordering pizza I just go to the
house and I promise I'll give it to you
you can check out our camera yeah of
course so and and it's not it's regular
girls that have got other jobs and is
doing it on the side are you talking
about sugar sugar thing no talking about
other works okay oh yeah okay so you see
what yeah yes yes he's yes he's talking
right but so it's like I'll be real with
you
um
I've interacted I've I've encountered so
many of these probably seen some of the
shows of these only fans girls that I've
been on the show and you see the one
that kicked out you you were on with her
didn't you which one was that one oh I
think well you kicked out I had to she
kept bitching I'm like get out then well
the one that went she was mad because we
were doing as a class you know we were
ranking women yeah we're like this isn't
it no it wasn't even them it was like
like imagine if you had a report card
right and I was like this woman is an A
so I have like a virgin cookbook bride
you know whatever and then like a b is
like okay she slept with this many
people and she just didn't like and I
had the men and it was funny because I
had the men I had the women say what
they thought was an a b c d f and then I
said okay guys let's have the guys do it
and it was really different than what
the women because the women just think
they're amazing and special all the
times they're like we can have sex with
whoever and we're still in a you know
and so so um yeah she just got mad
because I think she did porn or
something okay so then she just kept
like she was like well it's degrading to
rank women but it was so funny they're
all laughing when we were raising the
men yeah they didn't have any problem
and I said all right this guy has to
make this much he's in you know and the
standards for a man to be an a were way
higher than a chick it was like just
don't ruin the value you were born with
I think
I can't get
[Music]
it's so easy
even what you said that some girls open
up account and then they didn't do it
but it's like it's there forever like
women just think that you can just do
only fans for like a year and then you
go back to your to your life and no it's
not it's never gonna it's you leave a
digital footprint and it's gonna be
there forever and I just think
especially for these women with kids it
all comes down to money and money as
well and I I just want to just go back
to that whole high value thing I was
talking about high value thing like for
me what higher value is is a man that is
a provider and that can make things
happen right and that's really what it
comes down to a man that can make things
happen and ultimately if that if that
means you can facilitate holidays if
that means you can facilitate your wife
not having to work if that means when
you're working to play when you come
into places people know who you are and
they make things happen for you and it
all comes down to it it pretty much just
just all goes around to the same thing
when I'm speaking about it so I just
think
I don't know man I'm like poor man like
I just think
and also China you support you obviously
you know all the fine girls obviously
yeah yeah do you know what so you have
you ever talked to own a fan girl yeah
like on podcasts and stuff right you see
how much they love their job right how
does that make you feel when they say
they love what they're doing how do you
feel I mean honestly I feel like
indifferent it's not something I would
personally do but yeah
yeah exactly right so then if you feel
like that why are you struggling to
accept this that person because there's
a lot of teachers in America like a lot
of teachers that's why and a lot of the
teachers have only found
there's nothing worse than meeting a
girl and then you actually like the girl
and you discover that she does camera
only fives it's like now you have a
decision to make nothing I don't have a
decision to make it's very quite simple
for me but for a lot of men they
actually have a decision to make and and
a lot of men find themselves dating
these goals because they don't want to
do that thing and say actually you know
what no because they oh you're insecure
listen if
how is it being insecure that I don't
want my girl doing of like I don't want
my girl doing cam work no that's like
the most insecure thing ever you toxic
if you watch porn yeah like most men
will be watching porn their whole life
but you have a problem with a girl
that's the only fans you got like ask
yourself what would you were you
watching porn for nah you can't do that
that's not the same that's like that's
like hey hey man I've always had
concubines
what do you mean like there's concubines
I'm saying I'm saying it in reference to
the point of this like if a girl is
doing that yeah and you feel like oh my
God you shouldn't be doing that yeah if
you're a person like what's your porn
and you're watching those type of girls
yeah how how do you then sort of like
yeah it's different it's different if
you're choosing to be a relationship
with that person and she's you know I
mean I've Got Friends I watch
Uncle Justin
and a woman I know only five couples too
but but listen I'm not on this this I
can't do this Adam 22 thing man I just
can't do this thing man I just can't I
can't I can't I really can't and in the
whole 22 people but he wins do you know
what Adam 22 wins you know why he wins
I'll tell you why he wins because he
gets divorced and gets a younger model
that's not an only thing but not not
even is the fact that
this is what he married right to us it
sounds wild right but this is this is
what they've been doing this is what
he's married right so the outrage from
us is that oh my God you let some man
beat your goal he's violating but hold
on a second adam22 owns the content oh
mate he made so much money he made so
much money and what did Jason love do he
got to sleep do you know how carnal it
is to be like oh you just got to beat my
wife that that like but to us that is
like uh why are we but to him he doesn't
care anyway but what he's gone and done
he's gonna monetize it he's made lots of
money right off you right yeah and what
did you do you got to sleep more and you
got a one-off cash payment back in but
actually owns the content and made loads
of money and then so my thing for this
is like I'm never going to be on that
but I understand a certain man sometimes
I think it like turns them on and stuff
well I think he was just like just not
that bothered you know like I've got
some friends who work in the industry
and they were saying like it was all
just marketing yeah I'm saying like I
mean he's married to her about how I
mean who knows what the [__]
background in their relationship is did
you see that that little short that he
did like calling out Jason loved though
yeah I saw it I trusted you to pop my
wife
[Applause]
so he doesn't he doesn't seem bothered
he doesn't seem bothered no but he
doesn't seem bother but he so I think
look to to mend that in that whole thing
that like that he's winning do you know
why he's winning because the end of the
day is he literally especially he got a
black guy you know you know how this
thing goes on especially with this whole
club this is these he's creating
fantasies
yeah yeah he's fulfilled them and he's
made money Jason got to sleep with his
wife and get a cash payment cool what
did he get and so I like
ah it's not something I would do like
you know I mean but there's lots of men
that do this for free every single day
yeah but it's about understanding isn't
it yeah it's different formats and it's
for someone like when I see people talk
about Adam 22 now I will never do what
either like because you're not him yeah
so I also think it's like I think it's
uh that was like why when he was like
come you see me on Twitter the other day
oh he like he tweeted at me he was like
tweeting the same thing they always
tweet something like
is that the one we offered you money
no that that was a different time no it
was no he was just how I said what are
because I was having a genuine thought
the other day I was like what are we
gonna do with these only fit because I
was thinking I was thinking about the
stat that I wasn't are we gonna
acknowledge I wasn't lying about it yeah
okay thank you
um so I was thinking about it I'm like
what are they gonna do four percent of
the women are picking to be only fans
under 35 I'm like what are they gonna do
because I talk to women after women on
these shows none of them have a plan
they always have these businesses
they're starting but it's like real
estate but they never have it and so
they're a relationship prospects more
likely than not are slim some have
boyfriends but they tend to break up
like if they come back on they're
usually new boyfriend whatever so I'm
like what are they gonna do like what
like and that's and that's it I was
genuinely thinking about and so I tweet
this what do we do with the only Fan's
horse like when they're old and no one
wants them and I guess he took offense
to this so he like tweets at me he's
like well shouldn't you be worried about
yourself first sir you're single fan
whatever it is
tweet no no I just tweeted it now to be
fair I did make a lot of videos about
him before but I only did it because I
wasn't even gonna do it that's a funny
thing but he kept talking [__] about me
on his podcast after I came on a show so
I'm like okay what was he talking [__]
about you oh he was saying I was a
misogynist and like she's like making
all these misogynistic and I'm like me
[Laughter]
[Music]
it was like him one of his hosts was
talking to I'm like all right you're
gonna talk [__] let's talk [__] so so
then I made the video so but that one
wasn't even about him and then he um
he yeah and then I I I I said like
something along the lines of like if you
like if what you have is marriage then
keep like keep me the hell away from
that if mayor if the definition of
marriage is cucking out your wife then I
I will die alone and I and then I and
then I basically said um that married
people should be offended and genuinely
because this is like when I think I'm a
Catholic and I just think like I'm not
the most like crazy die-hard religious
person in the world but I do believe in
God and I've always gone like I've
always been in church semi-consistently
you know and like you know and marriage
is like supposed to be sacred like it's
supposed to be about like a promise to
God Like For Better or For Worse for
Richmond for poor in in sickness and
health till death do you part and the
shitty thing is for women that actually
want to get married it's it's a lot
harder because all of these people don't
take it seriously and they've ruined the
definition of Merit like marriage is
it's not marriage anymore I think you've
got a good point there actually because
I'm not you know like I'm not you know
the world's biggest fan of marriage is
you know as that tweet would show and
everything like that mainly for the
legal reasons apart from anything else
and also because I quite like the free
and easy lifestyle or whatever but the
reality is I think if you're gonna go
into that seriously then then you know
doing all that stuff and the problem
with the whole item 22 learner thing is
that it seems like it was maybe the
whole thing's been a bit of a setup but
you're right that doesn't undermine the
sacrament of marriage doesn't it you
know it undermines the seriousness of
marriage like if you've got to [__]
do it don't then go do that you know
well yeah and that's my thing like why
do they have to like do it like why do
they have to get married why can't they
just go be a couple like if you're gonna
literally have sex with other people
like that's the whole point of marriage
is to not do I really hate when people
cheap in it because I did a podcast the
other day and a girl was like oh
marriage is just a piece of paper and
she was like she was just like she had
three kids and she was a baby mom and I
was like no you can't say that because
there's people that are married that are
going to take offense of that right I
have obviously my parents are married
and I said normally it's because you
marry because it's spiritual and you're
trying to do that thing in front of your
you know let everyone know this is my
person right but if you don't believe in
marriage that's fine but let's not
diminish it for all the people that have
gone and done it and it's not easy
you're not trying to say to you and work
it every single day because I'm not
married but I understand that yo there's
a lot of people are and obviously is
that you just showing your ring there
no but um so how long have you been
married for a few months okay
congratulations
congratulations and like for me that's
that's amazing because I know that's not
really happening today but at the same
time I came into this whole thing with a
very what was the word was how was it a
very um Rosy blue pill yeah yeah I just
and since I've been here and I've export
to a lot more men and I've had a
relationship breakdowns and certain
things I understand why for men marriage
is very like skit like you know I mean I
understand it I it's an ideal that I
would still hope to have but yeah I just
understand why for a lot of people it is
well and that's and that's like I just
think it cheapens it like genuinely and
and I think it's like it's sad that it's
like we grow up like this used to be you
get married and you're you're married
forever and that used to be like the
white picket fence that they sell and
some people still have it but really
we're in a post-marriage world and
that's the truth about
should I not be trying to be married so
this is this is my opinion on it I don't
think you'll see societal changes until
the policies stop rewarding women for
bad behavior
because that's the problem because
because like when women get leverage
there's just no evidence we do the right
thing I mean she said she was gonna sue
you know when women got the right to
vote what do we do we made these we made
these policies and I say this like half
joking but it's like it's out of the
horse's mouth this is what we do when we
get power we she knows she has the power
to sue so sue and so it's like and it's
the same thing in court this is how they
treat the men like they they the child
support and not every woman will right
so I'd like to say there are great women
great wives great mothers that will not
do that would never do that but the
problem is when you have a system that
is constantly rewarding and telling us
to do the wrong thing the media is
telling us to do the wrong thing you
know our friends are telling us to do
the wrong thing the culture is telling
us to do the wrong thing our phones are
telling us to do the wrong thing you
know even a good woman on the worst day
on her worst day could do something
stupid and ruin everything yeah whether
that's you know cheating with someone
whether that's you know breaking up the
marriage whatever it is and so I just
don't see Society changing until the
laws change like that's just my opinion
on it I I can hope right but I don't see
any evidence that's going that way all
the track codes are trying to push
against the tide aren't they and the
people like Matt Walsh and Ben Shapiro's
and all that law they're all just trying
to sort of like no no you've got to do
the right thing anyway a man up and do
it right but it's just you're you're
arguing against you know the bowl is
coming downhill towards you you know
what I mean it's like nothing's going to
change until the laws change and the way
so I I looked into this a little bit
with work and they were saying that
there it's very unlikely that they would
ever change the divorce laws because
they need the votes of the single women
the baby mamas and the single women
because they are the easiest to
manipulate so when the politicians even
proposed changing the divorce laws of
the country they said we don't want to
do that because it's going to ruin the
vote and we need the single women to
manipulate because you know you can tell
them anything you can put you know
emotional things in front of them like
say for example with everything that
happened in 2020 it was all emotional it
was all about you know your grandmother
don't don't don't you want to you know
don't hug your granddad and all of these
things so they said we won't we will not
change the laws because it's not in the
politicians best interests it's not
we're not going to get that vote that we
need and it's sad like you were saying
like Pearl the other time that I was on
your show when you had the only fans
girls here I think there was like two of
them it was a bit of a wild show and
that the way they were speaking about
marriage was so despicable like marriage
means nothing we love sleeping with
married men there's nothing horny than
sleeping with my men like they were
saying all of these despicable things
and it's like just because you don't
believe in marriage does not mean that
it's not real and that it is not
important in society just because you've
never had a real relationship with a man
who actually loves you and cares about
you and doesn't just want to sleep with
you doesn't mean that it's not real and
but the but in their heads they're like
yeah marriage means nothing yeah and
it's sad yeah and and that's why I I can
never give like in my opinion I don't
think you can give men advice on this
stuff because every guy just kind of has
to weigh the pros and the cons and
decide for himself but I think it's like
the blind advice so just find a good
woman I just think is very naive to
female nature because even a good woman
on her worst it's like okay imagine if
we equipped men to legally Murder Men so
imagine on like because I I one guy
hasn't wanted to kill another guy at
some point right
you know what I mean so but like imagine
if the legal system said hey you you can
legally kill them women are at our worst
when we're spieded and mad and like we
hate our boyfriends or like what what
chick hasn't done if we talk about so
yeah we've been talking about the single
parent home versus the like obviously
about having two parent outcome so what
do we say to a guy right what do we say
if marriage is not the Pinnacle anymore
right it's not the White gate now what
is the new Pinnacle so what do we say to
men now what is the new thing well I I I
just do we say you know go create a baby
mama because you're never gonna get
married and there's no point getting
married and if you create a baby mama
then we go and create those success I
mean that's why that's why there's
there's so many different I actually I
started a list you saw it on Twitter of
all the options I mean some guys go to a
different country and live there
sometimes go to a different country
bring her back some guys get a vasectomy
and just buy a Playboy for a lot like
like there's different some guys like
the way I classify women there's no good
women or bad women because I'll
interview guys that married virgins and
The Virgins made their lives a living
hell it's like there's really high risk
women low risk chest tattoo hype but you
don't know necessarily now because
people say oh yeah you've got to vet her
you gotta vet the woman but you I don't
believe you could really do that what's
the highest woman
um I would say like a high-risk woman is
more promiscuous only fans like it's
basic stuff there's going to be some
very obvious things like if she's got a
like a problem
I agree with a tattoo thing why do women
seem to have a problem because I went on
a podcast when I said that like tattoos
for me is the red flag like especially
like sleeves and long things like that
it's a green flag for me man
I saw something that you said [__] and
spontaneous I could I could have stopped
laughing because but for me yeah because
it tends to be
bad decision making and also it tends to
be attention seeking when you have
people with long sleeves on the arm
longer than leg it's all attention and
it's not attention from you it's just
for other people so like the reason I'm
asking this is because
what does it look like for men going
forward what do I think is going to
happen I think it's going to be really
sad I think you're not really going to
see families I think that's like pretty
much done I mean think under 40. how
many families do you really know that
are still together like that have been
married 10 years it's it's it's starting
to go away I think there's going to be a
declining birth rate I think we're going
to see it drop below one
um I I think you're gonna see the
Obesity keep going up
um what else I think yeah I just think
we're in a post-marriage world you're
gonna keep seeing like men with multiple
baby mothers I think that's going to be
a new thing I think you're going to see
older women start to date like younger
guys and do that weird yeah it was isn't
it like more than uh a huge percentage
of women are going to be single and
childless by yeah 50.1 in the UK well
think of think about this okay I'm gonna
break this down I know you're so ready
but wait
um okay so we have a hundred percent of
people now they're predicting half of
women are going to be single and
childless now they're not they're not
saying this because you okay so they're
they're predicting that half of women
are going to be single and childless
right now these are Bankers they're not
saying this because they have a vested
interest either way they're just saying
invest in this right so now we have half
of women no kids now the other half of
women let's say get married well we know
half of marriages end in divorce so
that's 75 okay now let's take let's take
the remaining 25 we can agree that
marriage has a bad reputation and I
would say at least half of marriages
that stay married or unhappy so that
leaves maybe 10 of people 20 of people
with a happy ending maybe and I don't
say this like in a happy I was kind of
sad when I started to think about it but
we're just in a post-marriage world
you're going to see long-term
relationships that's the new marriage
don't see I don't see it changing unless
and then some people are like somebody's
wrote comment on one of my videos
recently like yeah there's gonna be like
this complete civil upheaval and it's
gonna all change I don't even say I
don't see that happening really and I
think all the other countries that say
they're like better
I I just think they're 20 years behind
yeah I think like because what I see is
it goes the black Community First in the
U.S then it goes to the white community
and then it goes
um overseas and like that's just the
trend you know if you go to Poland now
Poland's very very westernized now
really yeah I mean the Ukrainian women
is a bit different but the punishment no
even Ukraine because this is the
interesting thing I started researching
some of the like more based women's
places yeah all the birth rates are
below too right so if you're none of
them are living Trad right and that's
why I say I really don't think
traditional women really exist anymore
um I think there's a lot of like there's
women that are like trying to learn and
play catch-up but I think there's very
few women that were actually like raised
to be wives and I'm talking like
cookbooks from scr like you know like
the the women of our great grandmothers
and grandmother's time because really
what I've seen just from doing all these
interviews there's like my generation
which I would put like under 35 Maybe
and then the the women between like 35
and like uh 45 50 is like the the career
women that really didn't put their
families first so none of them really
taught yeah kids and then above that
like they that was the beginning of the
propaganda so they they didn't believe a
lot of the generation before that like
while they had skills to be wives they
still raised the next generation of
wives so they they typically don't
believe in obeying or submitting to
their husband like traditional roles and
a lot of them separated and that like so
I see this as three generations and like
when I interview more like 90 year old
women like those are the only ones that
I don't understand why you're not like
super pro contraception with everything
that you've said I feel like um it would
align with your views if you believe
like modern women are like this and
they're uncapable so so I'll tell I'll
explain it to you I I would only be I'm
only anti-contraceception if the other
[__] goes to
okay so so like right now I mean
the way the way it is now I mean you
have to have it but if this was Pearl's
world I would get I mean this isn't
gonna happen sadly guys but we can try
but but like I would get rid of voting I
would I would get rid of women voting
I'd get rid of honestly men that aren't
net taxpayers they can't vote either but
um I would get rid of uh birth control I
would make divorce illegal like all of
it would come it would be together yeah
but like no I don't think you could ban
it and not ban divorce it's got to be
both that's how I would do it um
okay I'm gonna Read Super chats and then
this is the longest show I've done in a
very long time
I I honestly don't even remember the
last time I've done this long show but
I'm gonna read the supers okay and then
we'll close up Daniel high-risk women
are those with tattoos colored haired
and speak all feminist buzzwords red
gorilla um Islam and I'll tell you I'll
tell you why like and you're young I I
hope you could we can save you but
probably not
um but but okay so the issue that you
get with women that talk about suing and
talk about like like coercion sexual
assault as those are typically the women
that are more likely to pull that [__]
on you in divorce because when they get
spited they feel the need to sue to go
to the police and the thing is like the
way our brains work we just find a way
to like like make things oppressive I
don't know why this is just what we like
a lot of feminists do no offense but
um okay Daniel red gorilla um all right
Islam was the only thing that protects
the family structure I think Islam the
issue they're gonna have I I see them
having a lot of the same issues and like
20 maybe 30 years I don't wish that I
hope they don't but I think you're just
gonna have a hard time with social media
unless they do something to limit that
that that's my feeling
um 90 free topic corn was made for older
uh men it's like the military for
um oh it's a corn was made for older
women it's like the military for men the
common average guy might be lost the
corn that's corn for women the average
IQ Nigel pixie show your feet you would
make a killing on only fans
Chris Chris imagine being married to
pixie and having to argue like this all
the time it's insufferable this is why
modern women are for recreational use
only
um is Amy Dangerfield you know her yeah
yeah she says she's your friend sorry
at pixie does have friends
[Laughter]
good job keeping up the momentum in a
4v1 you know I disagree with your points
but commemorated the effort WPIX W Pearl
W Troy great show tonight mad um I'm 25
years involved in men's rights has got
me removed from two health clubs and two
churches still trying to find uh who
made made changes and what the changes
are I have a 17 minute video explaining
oh send it to me maybe I'll react to it
American virus is freedom pearl men do
not have the right to vote
um uh Pearl men do not have the right to
vote or federal financial aid for
college at 18 in the U.S they have to
sign up for Selective Service or the
draft if they do not have selective
service they do not have the right until
they're 25 lifted pixie say I might be
wrong and I'll Super Chat fifty dollars
it just for you Pearl just for you
please do I might be wrong
you better send it or I'm suing
um 90 free-toe probably like I was um
coercively like financially abused
I'm your mom
for boys
um to force politeness but she can't
because she's being Mama Bear Dragon
stallion one zero zero one pixie you
can't change how people treat you the
only thing you can change is how you
take it [__] moan and complain let it
push you or let it roll off your back
bass OMG Pearl's got beef tonight well
done Undisputed 93 10 pie I remember
when Disney made a movie where the
female character reported to HR or
whoever bullies them and then sued and
then quit her job and purpose in life
that was a Disney movie
what Disney movie I'm supposed to go
straight to DVD
lifted by the Wind made where the female
character I don't know okay lifted by
the wind Pearl towards a massage and a
deep breathing session are you drinking
coffee again shut up I quit I quit I did
do like a three-month coffee sober but I
quit all right you know some people do
really well and they overcome their
addictions I'm not the one all right I'm
addicted all right um Jesse office 304s
are crazy Ben Hunter Pearl I've never
seen you with balls this big much love
from California boundless Guardian it's
weird every time a woman or a person of
color has issues with discrimination
they are a diversity higher are none of
them highly qualified or just
experiencing discrimination weird Chris
pixie you have low self-awareness
blackups the NBA is basically paying the
WNBA instead of saying thank you they
will be paid equally as men when they
bring in basically nothing no gratitude
that's what I say honestly guys as a
female athlete of 16 plus years I'm
about damn near ready to tell them to
just cut women's sports because I'm so
sick of hearing them whine yeah [__]
if you wanna if you wanna whine about
not getting paid equally
um I'm not here for it I say men you're
in the right to cut it because
we should be saying thank you for for
funding our leagues instead of bitching
but that's what I mean we're never happy
um Bibi Pearl undefeated enter black
dragon most modern women do not
understand the biological nature of men
if women were required to learn about
men you'd be less offended you'd feel
more protected I would know how to
select the first mate Bounty Guardian
Pixies doing well in a 4b1 I have a
question for the panel is there anything
a woman can say to a woman that would
weren't reporting it to HR if we exclude
sexual comments
no I don't think so
I I just say get on with it you know
um yeah I mean honestly guys I swear
seeing that plumbing those plumbers
I just was like men talk different you
know what I mean they just that's just
how they talk they're mean to each other
and they're much nicer to us so if you
ever think they're mean to you they're
not
um lifted by the wind funds to install
The Graham Norton red chair in the
middle of the couch Doug MPA I don't get
it what does that mean so he uh The
Graham Norton Show he has this big red
chair where he like talks to people and
he has a lever and he can pull the chair
at any time and it like knocks them off
the chat oh wow all right I've never at
Doug MPA thank you King in China for
speaking up for men uh Chris Christine
is a gem pixie is a demon snake dog
ponytails thing be breathing fire demon
you see like these are the guys they're
just Roasters Sasuke
um HR is bi women and four women do you
think auto repair shops have HR do Road
workers have HR do bricklayers have a
chart no Chris I support you pixie but
pixie is the type of girl that will
co-sign the BS I tell my side check so
they'll continue to sleep with me we
need three or fours and side chicks in
the world pixie understands sausage what
would mandatory paternal testing
um what would mandatory paternity
testing would it increase birth rates or
decrease divorce rates
wait wait would mandatory paternity
testing at Birth increase or decrease
divorce rates increase that's a stupid I
mean I'm not
all right red gorilla men need to stop
getting married it's completely skewed
and hugely disadvantaged Bryden I back
her the ginger Menace for a king the
king to get a camera my donation Kick
Out camera King yes please 46 and two
um dude with the Black Panther t-shirt
needs to take his Adderall Desmond pixie
I don't um agree with a lot of your
opinions but oh I've read that one
um she he liked the way that you
expressed yourself tonight
um 90 free-toe pie it was sarcasm lifted
by the we got our Super Chat
fifty dollars Super Chat okay all right
guys we'll do final thoughts thank you
all for you know I'm gonna do a break
Round of Applause for everyone this is
like the longest show in such a long
time okay um go ahead yeah so thanks for
having me pal it was a lot of fun
um you can follow me my husband and I
have a podcast and a tick tock and
Instagram where we do red pill content
modern dating Street interviews all that
fun stuff I also do lawyer reacts videos
on there as well so it's SJ underscore
underscore Rose and we're also on
YouTube and twitch and you can find my
music on Spotify and YouTube as well
it's shusty Jade which is
sh-r-i-s-t-i-j-a-d-e thanks again
hi I'm pixie otherwise known as a demon
um you can find me on you know twitch
pxiee or Instagram or Twitter with Pixie
love pxie l-o-v-e
um I guess my final thoughts I enjoyed
being here
um I hope that there's another one soon
I even though it was like tough
sometimes I think everybody like kept it
fun so thank you
do you live around here
um sadly I don't I'm just here for now
uh it's yeah Troy fraud says thanks ever
so much for having me on Paul it's been
a great show and uh lots of interesting
points been raised
um if guys want to learn how to escape
the west and really embrace the bachelor
lifestyle then you can come to Mexico
with myself and James Tusk fifth to the
8th of October we're running a boot camp
we're going to be teaching you about how
to cold approach and how to charm the
ladies how to get your Riz
on top tier with those Latina lovelies
and then get out of the get
out of the sphere sorry yeah and then
get in the ocean every day right get in
the ocean every day
extra but uh yeah definitely we're gonna
be doing having a lot of fun now so
Mexico City could email me Troy
realtyfrancis.com uh follow me on all
social media platforms at real Troy
Francis YouTube uh Twitter and uh
Instagram and I'm now monetized on
Twitter thanks to that
destruction
I'm trying to be a responsible tweet but
listen on the other hand if you want to
come to Mexico with us then get in touch
uh thanks very much
uh yeah it's Vic Santoro and thanks for
having us bro um you know so much I was
a bit nervous coming in there because I
didn't watch like I've seen your stuff
in Snippets but I didn't watch the full
episode and I was trying to get to work
this week but I have so much press to do
so I you know one of my teammates I was
like please can you go and research I'll
probably I need you to do a deep search
and he came back and I was like oh quite
interesting I had a message and said
what's the conversation is going to be
about but it's been completely different
and insightful so I've learned a lot so
thanks thanks for having us and I want
to say to anybody listening even people
taking in podcast content from YouTube
just like sometimes seeing like
antidotes like you would say is not
enough to have a you know like an
overview of what the show is about this
has been really interesting and compared
to most of the podcasts are they and
people can find me on across all socials
is Vic is that official
um I've just had a new film come out I
might even have to say that
but yeah please take it in and you know
look up my stuff on Netflix and you know
all the other films film stuff there
thank you for having me and yeah
appreciate it
yeah thanks for having me back it's
always fun to come on here
um yeah go check out my Instagram if you
want to hear uh my Instagram my YouTube
it's been a long show I'm all scrambled
yeah it's in the title guys so all you
got to do is just click right in the
title says with Christine Grace Smith
get her to 20K great yeah go check it
out um go check out my series debunking
The lunacy on my YouTube channel where
we look into some of the liberal Madness
going on right now and trying to discern
some sense of it so yeah I'll see you
over there
um yeah and you did one debunking like
birth control this week or something
yeah we've got debunking contraception
um debunking the idea of democracy is
one that's coming soon as well which is
a very fun one uh debunking Health yeah
pretty much all aspects of society right
um okay guys
um also
um we're looking to sign a couple
talents probably in the next month ish
so she don't remember me
[Music]
because
no I've actually enjoyed your YouTube
videos lately he has these like um
celebrity sort of like gossip but he
does his commentary exactly it's funny
you are funny
um yeah my name is China the my name's
voice and I haven't actually been on
polo show for about 10 months this was
the first ever podcast this was actually
the first ever podcast I've done uh I
came and this is a guess that like a lot
of people had lots of viral content
millions of views since then I've gone a
loads of different podcasts and yeah man
like I just you know I've I've have a
relationship with pearl sometimes she
says things like let's say agree on but
we always talk behind the scenes and I
wanted to come on particularly now
because there's a lot of stuff going on
within the community and I think that
podcasting as Vic can be saying people
look at clips and they don't and they
don't really look at what's going on and
and we need more we need more unity and
less Division and in the 10 months since
I've been on personal I've been on lots
of different podcasts and and
there could be a lot of criticism
sometimes about the Pearl show but what
she does is she brings a lot of people
together and I sit next to people I
wouldn't normally sit with my
conversation you wouldn't have and that
is what I'm trying to take back into the
into the podcast space within the UK
there's a lot of um crabs in a bucket
mindset and you know before you start
criticizing people and what they do and
you need to make sure that what are you
doing so and the reason why I say this
is because my whole thing is about
what am I supposed to do now with my
platform my voice I just got monetized
as well so which is good
but I I and it could have happened a lot
faster but that's not the point it's
it's the fact that I'm starting to
understand what I what type of content
I'm supposed to be creating and what
type of things I'm supposed to do and so
yeah Paul man like you know appreciate
for having me on the show I know like
you know I think three hours is probably
one of the longest shows I've ever done
but it's good to be in the studio it's
good you know King the producer you know
and
and yeah man and obviously it's good to
see Vic that's that's family over here
it's good to meet everybody in in the
studio Christine I've seen your stuff
before pixie while you I mean it's a lot
enjoying the rest of it so it's just
just for me just thank you for having me
on the show and yeah make sure you go
subscribe to my channel
um and yeah go check out some of the
stuff I'm doing thank you thank you
yeah
um go
subscribe what's the mantum yeah my name
is China with a while yeah my name is
China yeah I was like just
um my name is voice yeah yeah yeah
um okay guys
um oh you should tell all the podcasts
we're doing it we're doing uh except the
ones you know who can't come but we're
doing a meet up in two weeks oh so so
you can tell former show guests well no
no in two weeks like we're gonna do it
in London okay yeah we're gonna sign up
for the Google form me or follow my
Instagram for updates on that's gonna be
a lot of fun gonna be a big party you
know so we can all hang out
um also guys like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel also if you
want to apply to be a talent at the
audacity Network like our friend
Christine here uh right fun time great
fun better than copier sales
all right um uh DM me on Instagram let
me know like what type of Channel you
want to do like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel and I'll
talk to you next time
[Music]
[Applause]